Previously on Big Show.
Guten Tag setzen Sie sich bitte.
Darf ich Ihnen etwas zu trinken anbieten ein Kaffee oder ein Glas Wasser haben wir zum Vorstellungsgespräch sehr schön.
Erzählen Sie mir mal jetzt etwas von ihrem bisherigen Lebenslauf war noch nie eingestellt meine 5g brauche ich nie auf sehr gut 14.000 mag damals irgendwie Aktien gekauft.
Du hast ja gar kein Mac ne ich habe tatsächlich keinen Mac ich habe ein Hackintosh.
Und bin total glücklich damit auskennt Sportgerät mitgenommen sein habe jetzt auch gerade kein LAN Sport Laptop noch nie einen Laptop besessen.
Ja sehr schön vielen Dank das war's was ich von ihm wissen wollte.
Music.
Schlaf schön lustig als Anfänger aber es reicht dann auch schneller so ein Punkt wo man sich denkt so starb enough enough is enough.
Die Nachrichten sind schon seit drei Tagen in meiner Timeline Overlord Overlord ich als moderner Mensch als digital Timeline basiertes Wesen.
Kann ich mehr Rente mit seinen ganzen first World problems würde ich mal wieder das Elend der Welt.
Welches Elend von den Tieren generelle alles so also was er sonst noch so ist er wird ja immer direkt in unserem first World problems.
So Gott mein Telefon ist zu langsam oder ich kann auf einem Gerät keine SMS mehr empfangen.
Also eine Sachen halt irgendwie so unwichtig werden muss ich mal um richtige Dinge kümmert gottova Calcit mir schon wieder ein Akku alle und ich kann im Podcast nicht weiter hören.
Genau sowas wobei bei Podcast Konsum Problem fühle ich mit dabei.
Bei uns ist ja auch mal Schluss also Krieg und Frieden meinetwegen so ne aber wenn die Podcast nicht laufen ist was falsch im Staate Dänemark.
Sage ich hier ist ja was man gelesen komplett komplett Hamlet freiwillig.
Perverser sag ich müsste das Lied dann geht das nicht ja nicht nur in Auszügen.
Lesen Filme finde ich mache mal mehr Spaß das Lesen ist schon auch immer ein bisschen.
Ich glaube das Hamlet hatte ich in so einem kleinen mini Büchlein wo eine Seite um Englisch und die anderen Seite Deutsch war damit man das noch irgendwie so.
Macbeth habe ich das glaube ich auch versucht aber um wie geht das lese also beim Lesen nicht so sein oder Nichtsein das ist hier die Frage.
Ob's edler im Gemüt die Pfeil und schleudern des wütenden Geschicks zu erdulden.
Oder sich was nimmt in einer See von plagen im Widerstand zu enden.
Salzlake gehört zu diesen fünf Sätzen aus irgendwie berühmten Werken die man auswendig lernt um auf,
Partys nachhaltig Eindruck zu schinden weil wenn man sowas kann gehen ja auch alle davon aus dass Melissa auf meinem Vater starb,
der Vater und auch dieser verlor den seinen Mist mal das habe ich sogar für nicht gelesen das kann sehr gut sein dass das da drin ist oft das war auch Hamlet aber das ist nicht so bekannt als dass jeder aber ich fand halt wirklich weil muss erstmal nachdenken,
woran starb welche Reihenfolge Monarch auch dass der Vater und auch dieser verloren seinen.
Also IV sterben erinnere mich nur aus mir gemacht woher Romeo und Julia.
Da habe ich ja mal den Merkur zu gespielt und das war eine der Zeilen die ich noch.
In Erinnerung habe ich diese schöne Tweed irgendwie durch den Heimleiter und absolvieren Shakespeare Bord der wir auf Twitter die ganze Zeit irgendwelche.
Shakespeare Zitate macht und irgendwann schrieb er dann nur noch irgendwie was mit Open SSL error das war seinerzeit echt.
Na ja,
hier ist auf jeden Fall eure literaturrunde das literarische fünf Quintett Entschuldigung fünfte Element,
schon wieder sauber Einhorn guten Abend das Einhorn,
und Schalke egal an Dennis genau.
Dennis EKL 11 Berlin.
Mellerud.
GT3 nettes haben wir jetzt hier anbei erhalten an der Seite gehört nicht dazu die anderen.
Heute gehört zu den Schmuddelkindern Sachsen.
Mit beiliegender weil Cola Powder was muss man nicht erklären mehrere der Unterricht endet einfach Wolters weißt du auch was damit gemeint ist,
gesellschaftspolitisch gut aber wir nehmen dich ja nicht in Sippenhaft aus dem müssen wir ja das so.
Gute BB wisst was vorangeht.
Evelina Zehner die haben sich aber alle wohl dran gemacht das mit dem Akzent doch er sein zu lassen.
Du bist ja aus bis Bettina Clemens ich bin in Wessum GTA V Rat hatte dazu geben dass mich meine Eltern in jungen Jahren jüngsten Jahren obwohl ich in Berlin geboren bin nach Spandau verschleppt haben aber da kann ich nichts für.
Bin dann auch relativ bald wieder von der Weg aber wann warst du das erste Mal im Osten.
Na dann erstmal wir haben immer viel Verwandtschaft also ich war schon als Kind immer viel im Osten aber das erste Mal seitdem ich selber konnte damals mit dem behelfsmäßigen Personalausweis den wir hatten.
Mit 16A kannst du als Westberliner hatten wir in diesen Status dass wir nach Ostberlin und zwar nur nach Ostberlin ohne Visum fahren kann.
Da gabs denn dieser diese Tages Geschichten Tagestouren gab's oder eine Zehnerkarte mittellanges Umtausch.
Dann musst du mal auf die muss immer noch bezahlen bei DSDS war 13 gläubig und dann 25 oder sowas,
aber das habe ich auch häufig gemachte boilerman günstige Vergnügen die hat nachher lustige Spaßbäder während die Elbe in Westberlin I wie in Ende der 80er oder den 18 Uhr auf die Idee kam wie man sowas zu machen,
Hasan hier im Osten erdet das blub in Neukölln dann in Westberlin aber vorher gab es ja hier schon diese Sport und Freizeitzentrum oder sowas SEZ Sport und saunazentrum,
und soweit so lustige Sachen und war alles für den Westberliner war das alles scheiße billig und den Rest hat mir den Literatur angelegt da Stein.
Nee da gab es nicht jetzt irre also diese 25 auszuwerten Konto bei der Bank Konto.
Da konnte man annehmen.
Lamonte ja und wie gesagt Literatur war günstig und dann gabs halt so Sachen einfach nicht mehr kann mich noch heute dran erinnern die haben ja viele viele Sachen nachgebaut im Osten.
Z.b. auch so Mikroprozessoren und damals waren noch so Z80 war noch so ein geiles Ding von Zahlung,
und der hieß im Osten einfach u880 und da habe ich jetzt noch nicht noch gerade beim Aufräumen alte Datenbuch für den u880 gefunden von Militär Verlag der DDR,
kannst du ganz normal kaufen hier im Buchladen in Ostberlin und den halt keiner hat ein Zehntel von dem kostet wartet Originalteile Datenbuch Vincent 80 gekostet hat.
Und so und Mathematik oder andere naturwissenschaftliche Sachen da war relativ wenig Ost-West bias drin so politisch oder so da konnte man machen und von dem Rest der denn immer übrig blieb konnte man ordentlich essen gehen.
Und O Saft trinken na ja dann hat zwar noch was kaputt gehen.
Wohl gerne mal gerne war war Gastmahl des Meeres is it,
und so die jetzt gab es ein paar Sachen die seine Hauptstädte DDR hatten so zum vorzeigen,
Gastmahl des mir diese Wortwahl war der Name auch deine wie ist die ganze Zeit lang noch in jedem Dorf ich habe nämlich nämlich diesen Begriff der ist mir auch noch in meiner,
wann weggelaufen Obama denn so ein Dings mit Preisstufe S Plus 200 oder wieso hat,
aber diese Preisstufen du kannst ja nicht einfach irgendwelche Preise machen für Essen oder so dann,
so die normale Dorfkneipe hatte dann keine Ahnung Preisstufe 1 oder 2 oder so dann gab's die für so diese Sachen gab es dann in der Hauptstadt oder in anderen touristisch interessanten Städten oder in Meßstetten Garbsen auch.
Restaurant 200 Preisstufe es also sonder Preisstufe den hat einen spezielle Preise und dann gab es noch S + 100 + 200 x 100 oder 200 Prozent drauf.
Aber es war trotzdem immer noch so billig das heißt man konnte sich dort durchaus mal vergnügen oder ich bin auch gerne hingegangen wenn sie Outdoor Veranstaltung waren hier Insel der Jugend weiß ich noch so viel Musik gemacht viel Benz gespielt und so.
Und wie gesagt als Westberliner konnte man sich so eine Zehnerkarte holen.
Zehnerkarte Skalitzer es wirklich so wie so wie so eine gesunde Strippen karte in in in Holland also Aussage einmal hin gehst dann nur diesen Typen bis ich kenne gehabt alt ist Erzählcafé diese diese Büros in West-Berlin,
von Ost Berliner Polizei,
bitte auch sehr lustig da gab es in Westberlin an zwei drei Stellen in der Stadt gab so Büros die waren das spartanische was er jemals vorstellen konntest dann einfach Raum Tür.
Weiß dreckig weiß gestrichen grauer Boden.
Tisch Stuhl nicht exakt nichts doch Erich Honecker hing an der Wand.
Und die haben dann dann gab's so Rituale dass du bestimmte Uhrzeit mit diesem Büro saufen hatte halt diese Barkas vor dazu sagen die Ostfront ist das VW Bus.
Erstiegen denn so die entsprechenden Grenzpolizisten aus mit ihrem Köfferchen die hat ja mal so ein bisschen kennst du vielleicht noch mal ganz Kontrolle so ein so ein Köfferchen was man so sich von Bauch schneiden kann.
Um einen schönen stempeln konnten in der Bahn hatten die denn auch so ein Ding,
die stinken ausnutzen von diesem Typen gegen diese buero setzt sich an diese komplett leeren Tische mit ihrem Köfferchen macht einen auf und vergaben dennoch Visa oder eben Zehnerkarten oder ins wie sowas,
unten aber waren freundlich höflich klar aber war jetzt da war sonst ging Gespräch mit denen zu erwarten oder was.
Und zur Mittagspause stiegen dir den einigen Werkers vor eine Stunde nach Hause weil dann die Mittagspause verbringen im Westen ging auch nicht und dann kam sah einer Stunde wieder an haben dann wieder ihren Laden aufgemacht haben wieder Zettelchen verteilt dort wo war das.
Bekommst du zwei drei Stellen in der Stadt also unter einem Ausländer weiß ich glänzender.
Nee nee das war ja wie sagt der Vergabe eben von von von Visa für Reisen in die DDR oder halt auch eben Spandau ist ja grenznah gewesen.
Ja ganz Berlin war ganz nah ganz Westberlin war die einzige die einzige auf der ganzen Welt in der in alle Richtung Osten war.
Ja das stimmt aber da kann ich mich auch dran erinnern also ich war da immer in meiner Jugend oder sagen wir mal in meiner frühen Jugend Kindheit war ich sehr gut über die über die Raumfahrt des Ostens informieren.
Weil da gab's nämlich die wunderbare Bildbände und und andere Bücher mit mit,
tollen Geschichten drin gut das war alles ganz anders gewesen eigentlich aber egal Geschichten waren super,
wie gesagt Mathematik Bücher Physik Bücher und eben sogar was ich damals Verhalten zu Elektronik war auch für,
für Leute in meinem Alter und so also ich hatte da kenne keine Berührungsängste gesagt ab 16 Uhr konnte ich alleine fahren habe ich denn gemacht.
Lassie was hast du denn noch mitbekommen eigentlich vielleicht klappt das bei einigen aber ich habe da eigentlich nicht so dass die Mauer ist genauso lange weg ist wie sie existierte.
Zu kurzer die existiert eine Lehrerin vorbei.
61169 an von Sergej also.
Das kann man sich mal vorstellen wie lange also auch nicht alle aber die die jetzt mal was zum ist die letzten 20 Jahre so mitbekommen haben.
Wissen wie lang ist die Mauer garen länger als die ohne.
Gefühlt ja interessant dass ihr das von den Büchern sagt dass da vieles halt also viel günstiger war und also Fachbücher dann wenig also Naturwissenschaften vielleicht weniger.
Unterschied weil meine Oma hat halt alles was du Weltliteratur war gesammelt und.
Die hatte halten passives Probleme an alles ranzukommen hat sich da auch diverse Tricks natürlich ein verlassenes gute weil sie ist Krankenschwester gewesen und musste teilweise so über die Dörfer fahren und hat dann halt wirklich so alles mögliche aufgekauft wenn sie irgendwie Weltliteratur gesehen hat,
es gab natürlich nicht alles aber das brennt darauf.
Genau aber ich meine also bei denen Sachen war es vielleicht anders als bei Weltliteratur was halt schnell vielleicht vergriffen war oder leicht auch.
Für das Publikum hatte ich weiß es nicht aber meine Oma hat er wirklich versucht zu alles was Rang und Namen hatte irgendwie zu bekommen und.
War teilweise nicht so leicht in der DDR genau und halt auch bei Maschinen und so weiter also die hat mein Opa hat halt superviel selber gebaut und jedes Mal wenn sie irgendwo anders war hat sie dann.
Ist das die übliche Tauchschein Heilweise Schnaps also da hat man dann auch so gegen gute Maschinen gute Bohrmaschinen und Aufsätze und so was bekommen wenn auf der hat halt wirklich eine sehr sehr gute Werkstatt.
Heute eine gute Schnapsbrennerei bekommen unter anderem auch Totenköpfe wenn man Medizin studiert hat,
meine Tante hat Medizin studiert und wenn man ein Totengräber kannte und eine Flasche Schnaps hatte hatte man auch ganz schnell einen Schädel,
das Wasser des Wortes,
heute habe ich chille wieder ich habe kurz nach der Wende mal einer mitgenommen so beim Trampen und der hat erzählt er hat eine Aalräucherei,
gearbeitet im Osten Feuer und hätte sein gesamtes Eigenheim nur mit Räuchern bezahlt.
Danke dafür gab es ein paar Sachen damit irgendwie aus dem betriebshandwerker Handwerker waren immer sehr sehr begehrt,
dann sowas in der Familie zu haben wurde denn gerne mal schnell an geheiratet hat also anfangen.
Bei der konnte hast du überhaupt beim VfB vor sich hin Schnarchen und dann nach der Arbeit wie noch mal und ich weiß Kohle machen.
Adapter schon ganz interessante Auswüchse ja.
Echt sehr interessant gewesen was sie haben sehr viel von ich nach der wenn du willst auch sehr sehr deutlich den Unterschied so dieses.
Das ist Handwerker die hatten einfach noch mehr die wussten einfach noch wo beim Schraubenzieher vorne ist.
Wenn du der wirst Handwerker so scheiße mein Akkuschrauber ist Lehrerin Anna küssen sich Elena Hegmann lieber nach Hause für heute dann haben die Ostarbeiter ich schrauben.
Beamten aber umso gewesen also wie.
Das jetzt schon nivelliert ja aber das war damals kurz nach der Wende schon deutlich einfach eine bessere Qualifikation vorgebracht,
Samstag gerade die schönen Ausdrücke Mann ist so zu Gastmahl des Meeres ich hatte gerade neulich noch meine Diskussion auch mit Leuten die dort groß geworden sind ein bisschen so Erinnerung Tralala und so gab da noch so lustige Läden,
die hießen delikat und Delikatessen also ein Versprechen an.
Ja Delikatessen also sag mal so etwas wurde Problem mit gab er schon diese Intershops auch aber bei dem Konzert nur mit Westghats.
The barber so ein Problem halt eben auch für die Führung weil sie natürlich bringen dafür gesorgt hat dass die ganzen Getreuen im Staate keine West Kontakte hatten als Volkspolizist hast halt auch selten mal bist du selten an West Bruder rangekommen.
Nicht wie so ein Handwerker die halt eben schwarzer mal irgendwo bisschen was nebenher gemacht hat so und dann war natürlich blöde dass die ganzen Leute die sozialen mit dem Start nix am Hute am Hut hatten die hatten alle West Kohle und konnten dann schön im Intershop einkaufen gehen,
und die Leute die systemtreu Leute konntet nicht.
Also haben sich einfach mal gedacht die machen jetzt auch mal Läden auf indem man für viel aber immerhin für Ost Geld eben auch auch West Ware kaufen hat.
Also ein delikater hatte halt eben Milka-Schokolade.
Die du denn dort für 40 $ ausbohren der Ostmark Ersatz und gab noch einen zweiten für Klamotten.
Jan Annekathrin exquisit exquisit delikat und exquisit waren die Bilder lustig.
Oronos Mark aber gab sie dort.
Also eher Ende der 80er Jahre und dann gab es ja noch Genex sonst an den Otto Versand für der war leidingshof Festgeld.
Da konnte man denn z.b. wenn man zu den Wiesen GMX.
Vielleicht ja wenn du wenn du westerwand schafft hattest die die gewillt war einfach mal ein paar 1000 € paar tausend Mark Westmark sozialen anzulegen konnte doch dein Trabi auf sofort kriegen und nicht erst nach 10 Jahren.
Consult AG nichts bestellen dann kannst du von meiner Freundin gehen erkunden Westler sozusagen oder Leute für Westgeld diesen Genex Versand laden Sachen bestellen auch für Ostholstein ist das Amazon des Ostens.
Ja aber noch mit ohne webseite und so aber mit Versand,
da gab es neulich ist das Ding voll von 3 3 oder 4 Wochen mal so rum welche welche Schlauberger welche,
jungchen schon alliston oder Journalistin unbedingt von welchen Altvorderen Netzaktivisten wissen wollten wie den ednet Sonar DDR war,
der Typ hat ja die Nummer war das doch nicht gar nicht gepeilt das kam gar nicht in ihr,
irgendwie auch nur in ihren Gedanken Horizont dass du zu der Zeit vielleicht noch gar nicht gegeben haben könnte oder sowas und schon gar nicht im Osten ja aber sitze,
die wenn gesagt haben ein Netzneutralität werden nie ein Problem damit er genau,
also für die Leute oder liebe Leute die wissen das ja mal festhalten also das Internet kam.
Anfang der 90er Jahre nach Westdeutschland Innenraum dann auch nach Austausch oder nach Deutschland.
Anfangszeiten der DDR also auch im Westen noch kein IP also zumindest nicht mehr als zwei oder drei Orten vielleicht was ich,
alter Wiking wann los noch mal genau also riecht nach dem See ja ja 81er 4809.
Von Westberlin nach Dortmund,
wetter.de habe ich damit rumgespielt aber dabei nicht nur Unido und die Leute die dahinter halt die Holländer und so,
Warte damals schon gab sehr viel weil sie PI ne,
also so Sachen wie Newsgroups und sowas gab es schon E-Mail gab es schon alle da aber eben nicht auf Basis von einer Mailbox im Osten.
Nein nein also zu Ostzeiten nicht aber die sprießen relativ schnell aus dem Boden sozialen nach dem Mauerfall was hast du denn genau das erste Mal LP.
Was ist noch.
Ich müsste nachgucken war aber war vor vor der Wende weil sie sagt ich bei started habe damals besonders 95 Softair rumgebastelt ich musste echt mal anders zu ändern oder so in dem Dreh.
K19 Cookies dieser dann hatten Amateurfunker mit diesem!
Hat geschrieben das war Satan I 1 Walsum monolithische Programm da waren ip-stack drin TVT suissetec und dann konnte der Telnet und FTP.
Unsere eigentlich für Amateurfunk gedacht konnte man aber auch so mit Modem betreiben somit Slip damals noch gab's noch nicht mal PPP und dann schlimmer synchron im Urlaub so ein bisschen IP gemacht mit sagenhaften wie zugesagt von.
9,6 Kilobit irgendwie diagnostische K9 Cooke einen eigenen Eintrag nicht ein Gesundheit Geschichte des Internets Anrufer da.
Wie schnell gemacht haben noch im Winter 89 nach dem Mauerfall haben wir haben wir Modem so Trailblazer modern sowas damals am besten ich war nach Ostberlin verschleppt.
Und dort auch da gab es ja auch eine Computer Hobbyisten Zähne den in die Hand gedrückt und dann erstmal sozusagen über diese über die Westberlin nach Ostberlin hat ja noch einen speziellen Telefonstatus war nämlich auch.
One call forever und so ja jetzt keins Herrn oder Auslandsgespräch oder sonst immer der Westen hat ja immer gesagt die I kein Ausland also haben sie schon aus Prinzip gesagt im Gespräch von Westberlin nach Ostberlin kann kein,
Auslandsgespräch sein und damit Berlin und Berlin war Harald also sozusagen ein Ortsgespräch aus politischer Sicht nicht technisch aber aus politischer Sicht,
und deswegen haben wir da eben auch Modemverbindung dann aufgebaut die Hilton zwar nicht so lange wie die innerhalb Westberlins aber sie hätten lange noch dass man darüber you Zippy erstmal so Newsgroups oder drüber prügeln konnte.
Was ist die Stasi wo dabei gedacht hat am Rhein handverlesene.
Na man damals gab es auch noch Top-Level-Domain DDR.
Als als Ländercode und so aber hätte auch soziale TLD werden können.
Gab es war aber nie offiziell indem in den Domänen Baum drin es gab ein paar Leute die einen selber ihre Knoten so genannt haben es sich in welche Unis in der DDR.
An der Nordsee ich Ende 89 Anfang 90 dann noch so über die US IP Netzwerk und soeben News gruppenaustausch und Meer und tralala Hunter Sachen die sich dann selber Domainnamen gegeben oder Namen Noten angegeben dient mitbringt DDL.
Aber gab es nicht auf Zettel ganze Domäne im System bestand ja damals nur aus com net org will.
Da diese ganzen country country code TLDs wie wir sie heute kennen für die Länder die sind ja auch erst in den Anfang der 90er entstanden muss mal nachgucken wann genau aber das ist danach.
Ach Opa muss jetzt wieder vom Krieg erzählen muss mehr hinterher wieder in Tucson lesen dass die Leute egal wenn Opa erzählt er sieht ja keiner.
Wo ist der Wärme damals auch schon gespielt wärmer als ich wie Hannover und Hin und Her hatten auch welche Links.
Meinst du zu mir Hannover nee hier bei dir bin aber ping und du oder.
Nee ich war im ich war auch über alles EP aber über die Focus in Hannover lassen und von da nach Unido und habe da irgendwie für Ärger gesorgt.
Soll ich dir schon erzählt oder mein Mann I Internet Unfall nee muss ich mir heute keine mehr richtig vorstellen aber ich hatte zwischen zwei erzählt,
und Anna Burkhard keine Ahnung Alter sicherlich auch noch so mehr oder weniger auswendig was damals so für newsgroups,
na und dann also vielleicht mal so jetzt hier nicht nur so reden als wissen alle wovon die Rede ist also vielleicht noch mal kurz also you Zippy und E-Mail.
Im Usenet das war sozusagen etwas was ohne das,
tcp IP aus kam und was die ganzen Datentransfer halt anders abgewickelt hat spricht man hat seine Mail geschrieben und man hat irgendwie in Foren,
gepostet quasi nur die vollständige Information lagen einfach auf dem eigenen Rechner und wenn man daneben neue Nachrichten beitragen wollte.
Dann oder abholen wollte oder abholen weil er wurde die also eingepackt und nächtens in der Regel also aus Tarifoptimierung Gründen Namen dann der eigene Rechner halt für ein oder zwei Stunden Kontakt mit einem,
anderen Rechner auf und dieses Protokoll dieses Hippie,
Protokoll was er für Unix to Unix copy steht zum wesentlichen so ein was hast du für mich ich habe was,
fahre jetzt hier hats ich habe gesagt hast du es noch so Files und dann,
dann wurden die halt so ausgetauscht und jeder kriegt er halt das was er noch nicht hatte hören Prinzip sind Tauschgeschäfte Mail Mails hoppelt halt eben denn auch wirklich noch so hopplahopp ne dann hast du halt vermutlich gegen und eine Uni oder irgendwas,
wie sieht die Austausch gemacht die hat auch irgendwie weitergeleitet und irgendwann gab es dann in welche Größe und Unis in Aufhausen central,
die denn z.b. meine Strippe hatten auch wie auch immer geartete langsame Strippe über den Atlantik rüber z.b. und,
Mandanten hat halt eben so eine mail schon mal von der Übertragung her paar Stunden gedauert.
Großer Sonne so fett attachment sowas gabs alles später erstmals hat man noch textuelle E-Mails also meine erste Email nach Kalifornien war glaube ich so drei oder vier Tage unterwegs ist aber schon.
Aber so scheiße scheiße aber normalerweise ging also muss das Verlangen und wenn ich den halt angerufen habe,
nachdem der schon seine nächtliche Kommunikation durch hatte blieb halt erstmal noch mal am Tag hängen also zudem Zeitung war da schon teilweise zwei Tage weg.
Wir hatten wir hatten in Berlin seien wir mal gabs gab's ein paar Freaks die da auch schon früher Spaß dann hatten wir hatten den Vorteil wir hatten eine bitnet Leitung an der TU.
Ja das war so ein Ding von ihr Wasser EBM Netz virtuelle Lochkarten sage ich nur sehr lustig.
Also dessen Kommunikation bestand darin dass er dass er gedanklich Lochkarten transportiert hat und darüber konnten wir also etwas nicht wann stand Verbindung.
Und dann hat meine Watt bei der TU Berlin abgeliefert hast bei ESET verschwand relativ schnell dann auch in den Gefilden muss da sind noch fünf Monate.
Mehr Unterricht noch mehr unterbrichst genau also ich mache auch kurz,
war das Newsgroup Sie also genauso hier Eiche strukturiert waren wie man das eben heute von Domains kennt das hat man nur andersrum halt mal hatte dann halt so ein Top Level sowas wie kommt.
Für Computer Kram und lang für Programmiersprachen und C14 kommt lang C und da hat man sich halt mit der Menschheit über C ausgetauscht und dann gabs noch.
Ja ist ja bald Gruppen dann das war dann so wie die Revolution aber es gab halt so ein paar wohl etablierte Top-Level-Domains und dann gabs halt auch noch die schöne Top-Level Gruppe RAG.
Re Zählerstand für recreational Staffel sozusagen so Hobby.
Und unter rec. Music gab es zudem Zeitung als ich mir das erst mal angeschaut hatte.
Also ich will mich nicht hundertprozentig darauf festlegen aber das ist das was mir meine Erinnerung sagt es gab dort zwei artist die da vertreten waren.
Also das Internet seiner frühen ausprägungsform mitbenutzen wir doch das Internet mal um uns mit unseren Hobbys und unseren Lieblingsmusik an auszutauschen er fragt man sich natürlich was was könnten wohl die ersten beiden.
Musiker oder Gruppen gewesen sein über die das Internet angefangen hat sich zu unterhalten sowas wo.
Sonntag am meisten Potenzial drin dass das Nerds anfangen sich darüber zu unterhalten lassen Heino.
Nein keine Ahnung keine Ahnung Philipp also.
Vorbehaltlich meiner Simmering Erinnerung aber soweit ich mich erinnere war das eine war Beatles.
Interessiert mich damals nur so begrenzt und das andere war Kate Bush.
Die Kate Bush Fans waren einfach.
Musical Porsche nein Rick music Cover Cover ist die AfA.
Du weißt du bist das jetzt von diesem Zeugs Archive gibt ne gibt Leute die haben das aufbewahrt und dann ja Taufe,
keine Frage mag sein dass ich da falsch liege aber definitiv eine überschaubare Anzahl von Musikern die Sonntag überhaupt diskutiert wurden oder Musik die diskutiert wurde,
und jetzt bescheid definitiv halt ganz vorne dabei und regelmässig dabei ist es halt deshalb weil ist das ein Blick von dir gibt mit Kaffee.
Bitburger fertig gemacht und ich war halt auch so.
Wie haben die sich genannt anhören aus waren ja auch eine Mailingliste Laufhaus.
Lafer ich war ich war total von Socken weil irgendwie Kippe für mich irgendwie überhaupt so die größer und auf jeden Fall.
Das war so wie ich soeben festgestellt habe so Internetkultur so also man könnte sich aufeinmal über Sachen unterhalten die nicht unmittelbar mit dem Zugang,
Selbstfindung hatten sozusagen das waren dann habe ich halt irgendwie das so,
verfolgt uns gab dann halt auf diese Medien bist oder ich hätte diese Mail ist aber das war glaube ich die erste internationale meninist ich überhaupt abonniert habe nur Kate Bush notiz und Genossen und jetzt war mein Internet Austausch immer über,
man mein Piya Ring points und dann hat mein Rechner hat quasi ein ich nur einen einzigen Computer selbst wirklich jemals gesehen und alles andere kam indirekt eben darüber rein ich mich darüber irgendwann.
Mit dieser Firma bisschen da zerstritten und habe dann halt,
genau irgendwann kandima wutschnaubend auf mich zu und man sollte sie hätten jetzt irgendwie mehrere 1000 € Datex-P kosten erzeugt weil irgendwie die ich mit Hilfe Gesamtliste immer wieder hin und her,
Bautzen zwischen den Teilchen und ihnen und wir nicht geschafft haben das abzuschalten und wollte nur wie die Kohle von mir haben.
Habe ich den Vogel gezeigt hast und wie euer Problem das ganze so zu sehen aber da hatte ich soll das erste mal so einen Daten Unfall mit mit mit Fallout so ist warum die ganzen Tag Sand und schuld war Kate Bush das interessante für das Lied,
nachdem diese Gruppe benannt ist,
was I spend it in der fahren das beschreibt sowieso Befehle wo man halt unsere gaffa-tape irgendwie hängenbleibt und so ein bisschen war das dann sowieso mit dieser E-Mail.
Das Server Austausch fürs Internet dann auch.
Dann hänge damals faltet Internet war damals noch so schön naiv kriegt jeder jeder konnte jeden eine mail schicken jeder mail server hat für jeden anderen E-Mail weitergeleitet.
Weil ähm gab es damals nicht halt höchstens Unfälle in welche Leute die in welche schleifen gelegt hatten alleine welche Meter hintenrum rotierten also was arbeitet für alles noch friedliche easy-peasy und.
Keine Access Listen kann nichts kein gar nicht so schmeiß halt was rein ins Netz und kommt drüben einfach wieder raus einfach so aber es gab schon ohne Haftung.
Ja toll aber okay das ist jetzt rein technisch gesehen war das alles noch gab es noch keine access-list und so genug vom Krieg geredet.
Ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß ich weiß aber ich glaube.
Erzähl was Runde vorgestellt,
hallo hallo bist du auch da Hallo.
So kennt man wenn ihr fühlt euch ausreiten begrüßt eine halbe Stunde ist doch schön ist doch früh.
Wo Du gerade über Raumfahrt des Ostens sprach ja.
Würde mich ja auch noch mal deinen Eindruck von deinem deinem Erlebnis von Raumfahrt Raumfahrt du nicht mal hast du nicht mal Jaehn interviewt Wer umfällt oder sowas ja.
Da haben wir doch gar nicht verkehrt gewesen richtig Person ja war ziemlich cool sigmund Jähn der will,
wenn wir Filme fast noch verstorben und wie vor meinem Interview war ganz lustig kann auch nicht,
ich habe Tim noch nie so respektvoll im Gespräch mit jemanden anderes erlebt wie mit sigmund Jähn,
eine Frage das war aber ehrlich somit mit sitzen und ganz vorsichtig fragen und so großartige Folge ja gehört haben,
irgendwie also so,
man hat das Gefühl der musste erstmal am werden der musste erst merken dass du ihn nicht in die Pfanne hauen will er wäre auch kurz vorher fast noch gestorben das ist ja das Ding ich bin dass ich zu ihm nachhause gekommen und schaut mich daher zu ein bisschen um Unfall zu.
Einfamilienhaus am See irgendwie jetzt nicht übertrieben das ganz normale Wii.
Und wir quatschen halt so ein bisschen und auf einmal ging so ein Kuckucksuhr los kuckuck kuckuck kuckuck da halt das hin wenn man das macht mir die Kuckucksuhr losgeht und.
Stelle fest dass ich um die Kuckucksuhr Handarbeit kann keinen Krokusse Kuckucksuhr kann stattdessen kamen Sputnik.
Und dann dann dann sehe ich warte halt noch meinen Kram auf und dann wuselt irgendwie rum und er hatte da ungesunde Wintergarten Situation Assistenz und Glas umbauter Balkon macht er da irgendwas noch einmal so voll noch am vorbereiten und gucken und Essen und so.
Mach das auch immer so holterdiepolter krachbumm und irgendwie beim Weg aus ist ein Wintergarten wieder zurückkam und wieso diese ganze,
Aufhängung der oben sind dann zu trennen Geschichte irgendwie alles auf ihn runtergekracht,
Bike Novitas außerhalb,
mein Interview Zeit lang irgendwie vor der Nase und jetzt jetzt wird erschlagen oder überlebt so ein bisschen bisschen Angst,
Blitzer.
Ja der lebt noch den habe ich auch noch weniger wie hier waren wir auch jüngst bei der Eröffnung von mir.
Letzte Mal gesehen genau vor dem Planetarium eröffnet hat genau nämlich auch da ist noch was.
Knuffel knuffiger Opa irgendwie zumindest in dem in dem Podcast genau jetzt habe ich das wollte ich noch mal kurz über auch da ja ne.
Ja erzähl doch mal aus eurer Sicht dass es klappt Raumzeit live im Blut hat ein großartiges Intro und ein großartiges Auto hingelegt also da war ich echt beeindruckt von den Socken ja.
Also mir geht's Musikanten sehr gut also.
Nächster Bollywood wenn er so weitermacht.
Der ist ja schon Hollywood ich meine ist ja der macht ja auch Filmmusik also das merkt man ja auch das ganze.
Pompöse und und und so ganz ganz so ganz wunderbar kann halt auch anders aber da kann er halt eben auch.
Und da ich halt auch so ein bisschen so ein Freund bin von so einen pompösen Kram und ich mich noch gar nicht über die schon seit 7 Jahren gehadert habe mit mit dem Raum Zeit Intro weil das Wasser irgendwie ganz okay und eingängig und so.
Was war damals noch Mama noch recht und aufwendig produziert und die Melodie von dem Raum Zeit Intro wurde halt so einer,
freie verfügbaren Sounds CD entnommen,
was hast du denn dazu führt dass immer mal wieder andere Produktion auf diesem Planeten gab die halt dann dieses Thema auch verwendet haben,
was hat immer dazu führt dass Leute bei mir aufschlagen und hier und Arte hat dein Intro geklaut und das war mir dann irgendwie nicht unique genug und dann habe ich halt jetzt diesen.
Auftritte implantarium dazu genutzt dann endlich mal weil du sprichst schon länger das neue zu machen lassen,
die Melodie aber ich konnte nicht zugeordnet immer noch drin kannst ja mal an spielen heute Melodie ist.
Die ist mir irgendwie.
Beim Nachdenken über irgendwas die habe ich auch irgendwann mal einfach vor mich hin geöffnet ich kann dir nicht sagen was in dem Moment der.
Das Einfluss gebende Element war es war vom Gefühl her nah genug dran an diesen ganzen Kram Hallo.
Intruder Auto ist es nicht dasselbe wie bei der Freakshow na also Intro ist halt den Haushalt kurz.
Und das Auto nimmt dann das Thema auf und verschwurbelt das dann noch mal so ein bisschen ich muss länger aus play.
Music.
Da ist definitiv was drin was auch in dem anderen liegt drin ist ein metal Song Frequenzen also.
Metal Songs erinnere mich einerseits ein bisschen an Herr der Ringe und andererseits ein bisschen am Corvus Corax.
Was ist das eine Mittelalter während wir sind die mit denen ich zweimal in Wacken aufgetreten bin Mittelalter Band.
Warte mal stimmt hinten im Chor ne ja genau.
Stimmt daher daher kommt mir das bekannt vor ich würde auch denken dass das auch so also entweder von irgendeiner Mittelalter Band oder von irgendeinem Metal-Band ist auch fast dasselbe,
Mittelalter Mittelalter,
dass da irgendwas drin ist was ich irgendwoher kenne egal,
aber wenn sie auch so geht dann ist mir ging das im Internet herrensahnetorte irgendwoher bekannt vor und die ganze Zeit drüber nachgedacht bin aber nicht.
Mein Gedächtnis konnte mir nicht sagen woher ich es keinen Arbeitsprozess also es klingt ja jetzt musst du aber nur noch ein pompöses visuelles Intro haben.
Serdar konnte noch was in der pompösität gehen naja hat mir ja dann.
Eben im Planetarium gab es ja auch es ist ja pompös ne.
Ach.
Zum bist du zu spät gekommen Sterne und Planeten.
Ich würde ich Musik Mittelalter Band.
Mittelalter Band Mittelalter.
Gefällt mir dann muss man ja da fällt mir immer eure Mütter ein Kind ja ne.
Eure Mütter das Meer hat dass mir jemand vorgespielt und ich fand es nicht lustig eure Mütter nicht lustig,
nicht wenn ich bin wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche ist es etwas wo ich dachte es ist mir ein bisschen zu der so das ist halt wirklich ein bisschen teilweise zu abwertend ist,
eine gewisse also ich finde so eine gewisse Lustigkeit.
Kann ich mitgehen aber wenn es mir zu krass abwertend gegenüber Menschen ist man sagt kauft man mag kaum glauben kann ich das halt an einigen Stellen nicht mehr so lustig.
Ja das hört jetzt von dem Misanthrop letti ich weiß,
nein ist nicht gesagt irgendwie ein bisschen.
Wann bist du irgendwie also.
Ja ich weiß nicht was ich find halt lustig ist eine Sache aber wenn es dann halt so platt wird und dann einfach nur noch so.
Seid ihr alle dumm finde ich halt ist es einfach flacher Humor und dann hat es nichts mehr somit wirklich lustig zu tun und ich glaube das ist mir bye-bye also wenn es das ist was,
woran ich denke dann ist es mehr dabei halt auch auf die Nummer jetzt nicht sonderlich schlachtet eure Mütter sollen den Tag legen also schon wirklich eine ziemlich ziemlich gerissene Combo die meiner Meinung nach das Humor Spiel schon auf dem relativ hohen Niveau spielt.
Kommt ja auch immer ein bisschen drauf an wie es beim Gegenüber ankommt aber ich fand es irgendwie ein bisschen spielen.
Was sein muss muss in den vergangenen Jahren aber geradezu Heuschreckenschwarm hat sich ausgebreitet haben dachten wir uns es wird Zeit ihn ein Lied zu widmen.
Und dieses Lied begleite ich auf diesem historischen Instrumente es handelt sich dabei um eine laute.
Ihr bietet eure waren feilen davon und den Städten wird sie durch die Lande und zeitvogel Mut ihr Tag teilte geeignet Schmuck und Ketten.
Music.
Macht ihr den Scheißdreck weil ihr blöd seid oder hat den Scheißdreck euch erst blöd gemacht leider da da da da da.
Na hoffentlich.
Mittelalter,
Fußball war bei YouTube Essen war gut gewesen er ist auch ein bisschen Glück mit dem,
Gesprächspartner das ja so offen also man hätte halt nicht auch denken können wenn jemand Gesprächspartners könnte also von diesem Raum auch so ein bisschen,
eingeschüchtert sein aber wirklich cool drauf,
ja der war auch schon oft irgendwie hatte der ist halt so einer der auch am laufenden Meter irgendwie die Öffentlichkeit sucht und findet und du gesagt auf jeden Fall war glaube ich nicht so erstmal implantarium.
Also großartig fand ich ja den den DJ,
der hinter euren Themen hinterher gegoogelt hat und die entsprechenden Videos und Bilder da ständig projektiert hat das war das war wirklich großartig,
genau der live in den Zweiten der hat die Bilder gesucht hat und Sachen vorbereitet hat er.
Das war wirklich super also hatte das ja schon mal in Darmstadt gemacht und hat ein ähnliches Konzept verfolgt da was wir zwei Leute von der ESA die das auf der Bilddatenbank unterwegs waren als was hat noch mal ein bisschen ausführlicher weil eben.
Auch eben noch mal die ganzen fulldome Videos Jahr auch mit der Zug haben und so ja das kann auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen ausbauen und das wird auch.
Das war so unglaublich weil ihr da irgendwie über dieses wie hieß es extremely large telescope gesprochen hattet und,
Dinge die da ausgeschnitten wurden und aus Glas gelegt damit man mal sehen kann wie groß es ist und dann zieht der im Hintergrund so ein YouTube Video raus wo hat Leute passen auf die Wiese legen und man konnte richtig schön sehen,
ja das Teil ist scheißen groß und die hatten viel Spaß mit ihren 42 Yards.
Der hat auf jeden Fall funktioniert ist auch alles nachzuhören gibt's jetzt als Raumzeit x 860 m mit schönes Intro und schönes Auto und.
Schnellsendung muss ich noch zu Ende hören jetzt länger als der Weg zu meinem Landsitz und zurück.
Deswegen bisschen bisschen Stückchen hinten.
Da kommt man eine Filme die ein bisschen schnell war wo ich auch relativ am Anfang gab es einen sehr schnellen Flug durch die Sterne glaube.
Ja Papa hat's mir auch den Magen gehoben.
Eine Beleidigung Antworten,
hast eine geile Animation das war aber auch so ein Flug mitten durch die Galaxie durch ne so,
also das war schon das war auch eine geile das oder verwirrt dass sie das auch noch so aus dem Kontext herausgerissen hat das heißt dann wie ganz gut.
Ich persönlich konnte nicht soviel nach oben schauen ich muss da ich fand es bewundernswert dass sie nicht oft aus dem Kontext gerissen,
toll wäre auch wir saßen ja auch ganz vorne hatten von daher garnicht sowie optimale Perspektive waren das einfach nicht so gut gesehen,
aber hat man das eigentlich dann auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite also hat mir das wahrgenommen dass ich dann was über Schwacke oder was anderes wurde aber ich.
Ich war.
Bin ich in Umfrage Modus bin dann schaue ich auch nicht mit links und rechts dann nicht einfach immer im Augenkontakt.
Und das was jetzt über uns direkt zu sehen war ist ja auf der Rückseite nicht noch mal gedoppelt worden.
Mich mal ist aber ebenso diese Flüge der durch den Sternenhimmel hätte ja sein können dass man das auf der Rückseite Aura-Soma ich hätte dem sicherlich auch mehr Aufmerksamkeit schenken können aber da hätte ich halt automatisch tippen Gespräch keine Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt und ich war schon sehr,
sehr Flitzebogen mäßig unterwegs also ich.
Wollte damit einer maximalen Konzentration rein weil was für mich war so der Terror darf halt nicht langweilig werden.
Also Längen die man sich jetzt unseren Podcast wie wir das jetzt gerade wieder hier machen leise so das geht schonmal ne aber live,
musstet irgendwie fliegen und dann muss er irgendwie jeden Oase von Entschleunigung irgendwie schauen ob die ob die sozusagen jetzt passt und ansonsten halt wieder andere Termin aber das war alles überhaupt gar kein Problem,
mit dem du bist Partner im Jochen Distelmeyer super so jetzt aber Vimeo Video Orte tippen.
Ja ich habe eine Kamera mitlaufen lassen aber da ist nicht Fieber rausgekommen also ich kann dir doch gerne zeigen aber das ist alles sehr dunkel weil es ist halt im Planetarium hast halt sehr wenig Licht.
Und glaube ich hätte da ja das hatte ich aber nicht ich habe halt jetzt einfach so eine normale Kamera wie sie jetzt irgendwie auf dem Kongress läuft.
Vorträge zu machen aber dann halten Scheinwerfer.
Versicherung Spiegelreflexkamera mit Video Optionen mit irgendwie fettem lichtstarke Weitwinkel,
navigiere müssen habe ich das halt gemacht um zu sehen was kommt eigentlich dabei raus was was bräuchte man eigentlich und das aufzunehmen,
andererseits könnte man auch überlegen ob man vielleicht einfach am Rechner aufnehmen weil es halt auch Romy nicht dasselbe.
Also dann du die Atmosphäre nicht erinnert ist auch irgendwie schwer zu replizieren ist besonder weil du ja diesen 360gradzahn Folterung Optik die die die kriegst du einfach,
mich aber geil wäre natürlich wenn man die fulldome Optik des was auf dem Dom passiert.
Aufnehmen könnte und dann als 360° zum ja ich gucke mir das in der Brille an aber,
das weiß nicht genau ob die Software das leistet implied haben die das alles auch aufzeigen,
ja die Frage ist auch weil du weg bist ja zwischen zwei unterschiedlichen Software teilen also Tim hat mir gestern gezeigt das sind zwei Software,
Software Surfer dir da bedient.
Lotto Sachsen-Anhalt.
Gleichzeitig bedienen Maus und da ist eine Frage wenn natürlich der Domänen Screen ist dann könnte man das.
Ja du hast heute natürlich wenn du wenn du den richtigen Projektoren schmeißt der nicht Video macht sondern tatsächlich echte Lichtpunkte als Sterne projiziert das hast du deine dich im Video nicht drin.
Was stimmt und das ist das schon das schon.
Gewaltig also weil die halt so unglaublich viel schärfer sind als die wie verhalt zu Andy diese läppischen 8k.
Oder wollen wir wie ist die Auflösung der auf'm 8000 Andersen 8000er.
Das alles zu wenig ne für so eine riesige Kuppel ist es ist es jetzt nicht so viel essen f**** schon ganz schön groß also sagen wir mal so wenn wenn du erst die die projektierten Sterne.
Also didia Sterne sage ich mal hast und dann schaltet er oft auf das Video um dann wird das alles sehr verwaschen für eine Weile.
Lederstempel du kann ja dann am Schluss noch mal zum Einsatz aber was.
Wasser schon mal da Nando gesehen in Baustellen Zustand.
Der nach Reno Renovierungsphase oder nicht da wir eigentlich Beauty regnet gewesen aber.
Mama ich soll was Licht aus mache ich zeig dir mal kurz hier was irgendwie noch rüberkam.
Aber das ist halt kaum was zu erkennen auf diesem Video na wenn man es ein bisschen heller macht aber dann noch dran rauscht wie Sau aber ich glaube es gibt genug Leute die sich das trotzdem angucken würden.
Ja ich gucke mal vielleicht liege ich einfach es halt auch in vier Strecken einfach dunkel,
macht ja nichts der Ausschnitt ist halt auch sehr reduziert ich kann mal gucken ich kann meinen ich kann mal den Mund wie Honig wie es eine auf Honig gibt.
Romane zum reinschmeißen ein Meister der schicke Bilder in Rust.
Also nicht weiter auf jeden der genauso wie auf Honig gepachtetem die Haare schön und keine Ahnung.
Die bildersalat okay inhalt jetzt nicht farbstark das ist alles sehr grünlich der Film ist schwarz-weiß und fertig wie unsere jetzt alle sehen.
Wie gründe ich ein Bild aus irgendwie wie man so.
Da wäre ich gerne gekommen aber ich noch in fernen Gefilden nee das hat sich gelohnt auf jeden Fall gelohnt.
Noch also ich fand das schön dass Tim einfach noch ein bisschen was von der Software wirklich gezeigt hat wie das funktioniert.
Wie man dieses Planetarium halt an sich auch bespielt weil ich finde das ist ja auch noch mal was echt interessantes da vielleicht sogar konnten für wirklich zu produzieren warst du in der Kuppel auch zeigen könntest also ist schon echt.
Ein schönes Spielzeug dieses Planetarium und wie ich hörte hat der Termin auch schon nächsten der nächste.
Termin ID Services alle Leute mit Tim Tim Tim also,
eine multifaser Tim Florian Horn ist halt der Chef vom Planetarium und verziert im Quadrat ein bisschen verwirrend.
Genau also Tim Tim Florian Horn von Santarem hat uns unter anderem halt noch ein bisschen was von der Software wirklich gezeigt und.
Das ist ja also spannend wie man diese diese diese diesen Dom bespielt und was da so rein kommen dass er von Film ist über Bilder das halt auch konnten für wirklich produziert wird Filme für produziert wird.
Was ist von Spanner sie hat auch kurz noch da fällt mir noch was ein dass er noch ein Anliegen hat das können wir ja nicht durchaus mal diskutieren ja das stimmt,
ich habe auch den liebend immer gefragt Tim Florian Horn war ich jetzt noch für die eigentlich benutzen weil also wir haben im Nachgang darüber gesprochen das ist ja und wie auch interessant wäre für.
Das Planetarium vielleicht mal Content zu produzieren und mir stellte sich natürlich gleich die Frage wie macht man das überhaupt was gibt es für Software sich bin jetzt z.b. nicht mehr 3D Bereich eigentlicher unterwegs aber wenn man.
3D
wie heißt das 3D Modellierung auch kann hat man denn eigentlich alle Möglichkeiten für den Planetarium diesen Raum zu bespielen weil du einfach Kamerafahrten haben kannst in den dreidimensionalen Raum und das ist schon sehr spannend und.
Tim Florian Horn hat auch gesagt er sucht in der Tat wieder einen oder zwei Person ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie viele aber.
Er will dein Tim alles eintippen Team ja also konkret.
Besteht wohl auch der Bedarf also die Software ich war kein wie sie heißt jetzt es ist doch diese Microsoft Geschichte.
Für das notiert der digistar Sex und zwar das ist in dieser Link ja ich habe sogar mehr.
Die Software zu sagen lassen das andere ist es ist wohl eine schwedische Firma die den unibio herstellt um sonnendom zu.
Spielen sodass II Lenker sind diese beiden Programme gibt es da wohl die genutzt werden und,
ver.di vor allem während der Präsentation,
live hin und her geswitcht werden mit denen man dann also aus der Kombination der beiden Inhalte den Dombes spielen kann und wahrscheinlich auch noch mit anderer Software die jetzt aber hier nicht im Planetarium genutzt wird.
Ja und wenn es richtig verstanden habe was eigentlich fehlt ist dass man quasi Unity Software.
Direkt für Planetarium.
Ja das wäre genau das hat sich das hattest Du danach noch gesagt das Unity ja eigentlich wahrscheinlich dass er hat das gesagt dass er hat das gebe ja mehrere Optionen aber ist natürlich sodass im Gaming Bereich jetzt Unity.
Schon zu den etwas populären environments indem man halt 3D Games Macht darstellt.
Und es wäre hier quasi die Herausforderung mal einen Weg zu finden wie man halten in Unity.
So also Unity environment quasi portiert oder angepasst bekommt.
Für diese konkrete Situation Implantaten wie kann ich es leider auch nicht so richtig gut beschreiben aber im Kern ist es ja so man hat dort halt so einen virtuellen Screen ebendieser 8000 x 8000 Pixel die von X,
Laserprojektoren gespielt wird.
Die hat alles im Teilbereich auf ausleuchten und mit entsprechenden Überlappung und gib da halt irgendwie so eine Software Ebene.
Die diese Überlappung daneben rausnimmt und jetzt verlässt es mich jetzt auch schon so ein bisschen dann muss ich auch selber noch mal forschen vielleicht,
euch für die nächste Sendung noch mal genauer an wahrscheinlich die Anforderung sind aber auf jeden Fall.
An deiner Stelle muss man halt hier das Interface zu dem System suchen und wenn teilt eine Anpassung gebe,
dass man quasi gegen Unity programmiert aber automatisch implantarium landet und sagt okay hier stehe ich hier in der Mitte von diesen 3D an warmen und ich sehe das halt Cave mäßig um mich herum weiß ich jetzt auch nicht unmöglich oder so es ist halt nur es müsste mal in dieser konkreten.
Konstellation auch mal wirklich zum laufen gebracht werden weil bisher Arbeit nehmen die ganzen Planetarien noch so mit spezieller Planetarium Software dass du noch mal so ein eigenes Ding aber die haben noch nicht diesen Anschluss gefunden,
andere Idee wie man das eben so kennt und mittlerweile der Output so enorm ist und ich meine wenn man das hätte.
Wiederum wäre ja auch der Weg nicht,
soweit jetzt auch wirklich extrem wie hast du schön immersiver Erlebniswelten herzustellen und auch ganz andere controls zu machen also man stellt sich mal nur formal würde halt mal das Planetarium im wirklich so als paved interaktive Cave benutzen und dann würde da irgendwie ganz interessante,
Spiele mit Wii Controller an oder was weiß ich spielen an dass du da irgendwie Dinge projizieren kannst anderen oder so eine Wii Remote in der Hand jetzt mal nur so als Idee Nadia so so grob und wie die Richtung hat und dann hast du gesagt was ich wieso eine virtuelle Taschenlampe auf dem Planetarium und kannst irgendwelche Dinge anleuchten,
Sohn Sport wär interessant wird man sich auch gucken ob man damit,
lasertracker an arbeitet oder was auch immer nur man muss dann halt überhaupt erstmal einen im warmen haben wo man eben dann generischen Software dann eben auch schnell auf auf auf diesen Dom umgesetzt bekommen und.
Wo man könnte sein point and Click Adventure dafür bauen also wenn du es Leute zu hören die da so'n dir so ein bisschen auf dem Stuhl rumrutschen und sagen habe ich doch schon mal gemacht und da kann ich mir aus.
Meldet euch ruhig mal weil das wär cool und ist halt auch etwas was ich euch viel drüber nachdenke.
Dieses ganze Podcast live,
denk meine Seite Podcast machen gibt's halt und wie Leute die irgendwie sagen und du musst auf YouTube machen und Video das ist doch das große Ding und Wasser.
Ehrlich gesagt mich interessiert einfach dieses Gehampel nicht einfach YouTube ist für mich einfach eine hysterische Käfig voller Narren die irgendwie vom ein Bein aufs andere springen also der Video Aspekt der ist halt aller aller aller meisten Fällen.
Überflüssig ja ich weiß wie du bist voll mit interessanter ich will so habe nichts dagegen sagen und,
gibt es für die Sachen wo wo Video dass es gibt es gibt Sachen wo Video wunderbar sinnvoll ist er aber aus meiner Perspektive heraus mit dem was ich so sagen annanan konnten machen die einfach primär,
zum Hören gedacht ist macht Video keinen Sinn,
ja also ich kann ich mich jetzt hier Film Maja auch manche Podcast als die ganze Zeit irgendwie Talking Heads anzeigen dann kannst du die ganze Zeit irgendwie Kamera Kamera B Kamera Kamera B dass heavy Star Wars 2 und 3 gucken langweilig,
das ist auch so ein Abischnitt Hölle und.
Habe ich überlegt okay wie wie bereitet man jetzt so ein Live Event auf wo es halt schon,
ein bisschen blöd ist wenn du so zeigen jetzt nur so in der Dunkelheit sitzt kann natürlich machen das hier auch so Hörspiele und Nachbarn wir sind wieder alle zusammen in einem dunklen Raum kein mir halt eigentlich auch,
Augen zu machen und unter der Bettdecke mit dem Kopfhörer verschwindet auch hier ist nicht so sehr also wo ist dann der Vorteil,
irgendwo zu sein deswegen war dann Sie diese Idee na ja okay dann dann nutzen wir einfach das visuelle als Assoziationskette und Unternehmen möglichst schnell in Echtzeit das Gesagte auf und und spielen das eine wenn man aber jetzt,
was ich einen Podcast macht der eben über konkrete Dinge geht und wo man sowas was ich konkrete Pfade machst dass ich,
mondland die Mondlandung ja durchaus mal ein Thema so dann würde man halt auch wirklich mal versuchen.
Die Mondlandung wird ja auch in jeder stage sozusagen auch zu begleiten also also den richtigen view.
Tatsächlich die Position zu jedem Zeitpunkt einzunehmen ja wie sieht's denn jetzt aus wenn man dann da ist und,
hinter der dunklen Seite des Mondes wieder auftaucht und dann geht die Erde auf und und und und sowas und das dann halt auch wirklich in 3D in dem Moment abspielen drin dass ich sicherlich ein Stück weit auch.
Ohne jetzt spezielle Software zu machen einfach so mit einer Platte Planetarium Software man kann es ja beliebig weiterspielen wenn du einfach auf meinen anderen Universen bist wo es halt nicht die echten Planeten sind so irgendwelche.
An Anwältin es muss ja auch jetzt also das Kofferraum Zeit nicht ausprobiert aber was ist wenn du mal in ceret machen möchtest über Blutgefäße,
also mal ganz ehrlich ich habe soviel halt durch die Medizin Bezug den ich halt habe.
Wo Leute an uns herangetreten waren auch mit Eier wir könnten uns eigentlich auch vorstellen entweder Claire wieder zu haben wie funktioniert das Herz das war zum Beispiel in Semesterprojekt was ich im,
zeitnah dritten Semester wo ich mal Computeranimation belegt habe wie sieht es aus wie läuft dieser wie verläuft dieser dieser,
tut mir leid,
ja genau,
ja das hat einfach wie funktioniert das mit dem Hammer und Amboss im Ohr ist wirklich ein sehr,
Entschuldigung,
nee passt schon ich vergess das immer wie funktioniert das wenn die Flüssigkeit sich im Hammer und im Amboss bewegen im Ohr also was heißt das oder wenn man was heißt das wenn man wenn einem schwindelig wird,
wenn man ebenso diese dieses Problem hat das irgendwas im Ungleichgewicht ist dass diese diese Kügelchen im Ohr vielleicht abgegangen also dann aber ich meine.
Planetarium oder den Bezug zur Raumzeit Geschichte,
dann das Publikum Auffahrt einmal aufzustehen habe dein Schicksal und das Gleichgewicht.
Ja aber das ist dein Zimmer Sievers erleben und dass dass das und das ist das was ich als Mehrwert empfinde so und maximale Interaktivität und Reaktion Freude.
Das Interface ne also okay aber das cool dass er dann,
YouTube und so weiter gesucht hat man ja auch gesehen wie wir mit der Maus so schieb schieb schieb das Fenster quasi dahin geschoben hat,
das war halt nicht schick aber wenn man halt ein Interface haben wo man sagen kann so hier dieses Video jetzt da youtube.com 30. Und dann wird es halt stop eingeblendet und ne du hast aber auch sagen Merksatz sofort also im Prinzip braucht man so eine Art.
Planetarische Video Jockey Software wo du halt so dieses oder.
Unabhängig von Planetarium generell so ein Video zu Spiel bzw auch irgendwelche System aber dann halt man 3D Back-End damit man zum Teufel halt auch.
Dort abspielen kann.
Und vorher platzieren kann je nachdem welches welche Größe hat das Video du hast verschiedene placement kannst du sagen ok dieses Video geht jetzt hier.
Die linke Seite des Raums das steht in der Mitte da steht noch da drüber,
da kommt was von oben rechts oder vielleicht auch hinten einfach die ganzen Platzierung Optionen hast und dann eben flexibel schnell mit wenigen Tasten oder Mausklicks weil sie so ein so ein Kanal hast wurde eben dieses ganze.
Audiovisuelle oder im Zeitverlauf interaktive zusammen gegossen bekommt und das Ganze eben mit dem Podcast begleitest ja eigentlich so ein bisschen den pace voll.
Ich hatte es aber nicht ganz sympathisch dass du da angefangen hat die Fenster rum zu schieben die Haare richtig sympathisch,
das ist aber auch das will man ja auch selber nicht genau aber das ist ja genau das Problem was er halt auch so klassifiziert hat mit du hast zwei.
Programme die du gleichzeitig bedienen muss zwischen den du wechseln musst und du siehst teilweise einfach nicht.
Wie sieht das gerade auf dem Dom aus wo muss ich das gerade hin schieben das ist natürlich auch für denjenigen der das vorbereitet halt einfach so dann.
So eine Stresssituation die du wahrscheinlich für uns nimmt in dem Moment halt auf die Zeit nach beschäftigen die nicht das eigentliche Jogginghose oder willst du bist du willst irgendwas machen wenn du willst vor allem auch unter Umständen Workflow haben,
wo mehrere Leute das tun hast halt auch wieder eine Person die kriegt uns hier die Pappen irgendwie in Hamburg,
guck doch mal ob da was ist recherchiert sag sucht er ja hier Videos guckt kurz rein ahja das Video Zack und dann irgendwie.
Paste und damit geht das Insulin Puttkamer Eier womit sozusagen II Personen,
dann eben so sieht ein neues video input wo platziere ich denn das ja das packe ich jetzt mal auf die rechte Seite so und dann.
Willst du sie genau aber das Auto 1 jetzt in dem Moment 5 genau diese Anwendung und ist ja auch alle Skin Hexenwerk muss mal Nummer.
Zusammenzucken interessant ist also du sagst es ja gerade so eigentlich will man ja dann gemeinsam Workspace haben in dem man arbeiten kann wo der eine dem anderen etwas zu arbeitet,
kann mich erinnern als ich angefangen habe in Rostock zu studieren also visual Computing gab es genau relativ viel Forschung,
genau dazu wie kann man eigentlich kollaboratives Arbeiten.
Vereinfachen und seitdem habe ich aber komischerweise nicht mehr so viel darüber gelesen was interessantes weil eigentlich ist genau dieses kollaborative arbeiten mit so einem gemeinsamen space.
In so einem Fall genau das wichtigste ja dass du eben man zu arbeiten kannst,
weiß was der andere gerade machst du hast irgendwie voll den Anlass noch dazu liefern und das ist halt bisher noch gefehlt na ja es gab Erzählforschung in diesem in diese gemeinsam Meeting Räume was halt so diesen und Viagra mal der Anfang war,
ja aber dass die Leute dann halt zufrieden mit irgendwie ja wo ist mein PowerPoint hat man jemanden Adapter,
so dass es die Ansprüche sind ja dann irgendwie auch nicht besonders hoch ne,
sagen so Keynote Apple Style haben die Anforderungen an wie das am Ende aussehen hat schon erhöht was ist halt nicht dass der Kunde in dem Moment auch erzeugt wird dass ich diese Echtzeit Verbindung die die ist ja die eigentliche Herausforderung ne du weißt,
eigentlich erst jetzt was du in 30 Sekunden spätestens,
auf dem Screen haben willst dann bist du es nicht irgendwie auf dem Screen haben mit ich check da mal ein Fenster jetzt hier quer über den Bildschirmen,
Terrasse in dem Moment auch so ein bisschen diese Illusion dass das alles irgendwie aus einer Traumwelt an zugespielt wurden bisher auch die wird ja auch nicht dieses.
Dalmak das charmant seine so so aha okay auch hier arbeiten noch echte Menschen so ne aber eigentlich willst du ja da reingehen und sagen ok ist mittig aber willst du doch gerade überarbeitet werden.
Ich will YouTube also doch willst du doch YouTube nein nein winisan nicht sein hektisch,
über überhaupt nicht hektisch kannst du Gegenteil das soll so flüssig kommen als wäre das irgendwie monatelang vorher schon geplant merkt halt bloß nicht dass es quasi alles in Echtzeit erzeugt worden ist aber halt keine hüpfenden fressen die irgendwie voll,
dicker Mann ganzer alt bist du nicht halt nicht das ist ja nur ein Teil von YouTube sagte ich auch.
Aber das ist der einzige die man malen kann wenn man halt.
Nichts Wirkliches anzubieten hat so ja ich meine wir könnten uns jetzt hier Filmen und sicherlich gibt ein paar Leute sagen oder kann ich dazu gucken.
Aber ich meine schottisch rumsitzen eisenhaltiger als ich will jetzt nicht Kamera drauf zu halten.
Wollen wir mal angeschaltet meinst rausgebracht,
ja weil du Point-and-Click-Adventure sagtest mir kurz reingrätschen,
es gibt bei Kickstarter gibt es gerade ein ganz wunderbares Projekt wieder mal einer deutschen Firma die einen Point-and-Click-Adventure machen möchte das heißt trüberbrook.
Ja darf ich sofort geweckt.
Link Link Link Link ja ich schmeiß ihn mal von hier nach da ja ja.
Was gehört immer dass das Interessante ist dass die halt alle ihre Hintergründe als Modell bauen.
Und dann die Funk die Figuren auch als Figuren bauen und das dann alles irgendwie zusammen animieren also das sieht schon sehr sehr sehr niedlich aus und der Humor scheint auch nicht zu kurz zu kommen insofern bin Nils nerdsheaven the world.
Dann erzählst du aha okay.
Und ich habe das nicht so ganz verstanden was ist das genau ein Point-and-Click-Adventure verstehe.
Das wie gesagt in einer als Modellbau gebauten Welt spielt.
Bisschen so was wie Liebe luminocity ich weiß nicht wer das mal gespielt hat auch ganz großartig weil es eben auch eine neue als Modellbau gebauten Welt spielt.
Hübsch aus ja und die haben ihre fundingziel schon fast.
Doppelt erreicht also fand es sieht so aus das ist so gerendert als wäre das so poppig so Puppenhaus Puppenhaus mäßig und dann so.
Ach so das wird bestimmt gut und es gibt in dem in dem Video.
Genau irgendwie Tochter Jan Böhmermann auf warum auch immer und indem in dem Video von von Kickstarter Tochter,
der Typ der Monkey Island gemacht hat wie heißt du doch gleich.
Und uns auch Family Park der Tochter auch irgendwann auf ja und guck durch eine der Kulissen durch mal so eben am Rande,
das auch schon voll hierdurch gelandet alles das ist alles voll durchgefallen IT und kann man aber wenn man will noch aufspringen aber dann Windows gestört anfühlt dafür kaufen dann nein du hast jetzt gerade Weg gestreut da war,
das Video war gerade zu Ende und es gibt auf allen Plattformen weil.
Qualinox kommt jetzt irgendwie.
Bestverdiener kurze Ron Ron Gilbert so heißt das genau oder Gilbert Tierheim Armin ausspricht,
trüberbrook trüberbrook mit einem richtigen Umlaut so schön es ist so witzig sie auch nass wird die Amerikaner noch ausreichend,
da wäre ich ja das ist echt schön wieso ich habe direkt reingefahren das muss dich sofort haben.
Ich habe Post bekommen außen.
Den Vereinigten Staaten Kalifornien und Washington.
Meine genaue ramp Seattle von unserer ehemaligen Freundin,
Fabienne also falls jemand hier Maschen verdoppeln viel Maschen pro Pixel eine unserer epischsten Ausgaben die Wäsche machen ich weiß nicht was du bei der dabei also ich war dabei.
Du warst aber alle die dabei waren haben es nicht vergessen.
Für die die die Sendung noch nicht gehört haben hört ihr euch an ist ganz tolle Freakshow und Fabian ist überhaupt,
mit die coolste Sau weil sie ist einfach eine begnadete leckeren mit Fähigkeiten in allen nur erdenklichen erforderlichen und nicht erforderlich den Bereichen,
und sie hat dann als sie dann gleich nach der Sendung weiter so ihr letztes Wochenende in Deutschland wieder zurück in die USA gegangen hat dieses und jenes gemacht und war dann aber beseelt,
von einem Projekt und dann hat sie auf Kickstarter halt das Projekt mit Jack gestartet.
Und mit Jack ist sozusagen ihr Wunsch gewesen gibt uns doch mal Geld,
und dann kaufe ich mir nämlich eine industrielle Strickmaschine von Stoll,
so ein richtiges Monster Teil irgendwie 3 oder 4 Meter breit,
und dann fange ich an das Ding zu programmieren dann hat sie und wie die Kohle zusammen gehabt ist die Dach Schwaben Stuttgart irgendwo keine Ahnung wo die gebaut werden sonst anzusteuern hatte vier Wochen abgesessen sich quasi umfangreich in die Technik dieses Gerätes einweisen lassen weil Zeit so industrial ne,
consumer damit irgendwie quick start manual und so ja und dann hat sie halt angefangen da sozialen gegen zu programmieren,
wie sieht das ja früher mit ihren anderen Sachen das hat ja einer Sendung ausführlich berichtet.
Das auch immer schon gemacht hast du nicht so kleine Strickmaschinen ja und jetzt fängt ja inhalt an,
ihre Kickstarter versprechen auszusenden dass man halt diese ganzen elementary cellular automata Muster,
also quasi so game of life in Indian Jahn Detlef.
Professionellste was du an Strickmaschine bekommen kannst auf diesem Planeten sieht man auch mit top wolle auch da hat sie sich auch richtig viel Mühe gegeben dass in Rhino wolle glaube ich.
Anderes immer noch nicht verstricken hat drei verschiedene Farben gekauft und wieso ein lila in schwarz und weiß.
Und dann halt konnte man dann so zeigen sich eine Zahl aussuchen und damit quasi dann dieses Muster des vor generierte Muster.
Bestimmt so und dann hat man halt einen Schal der ist like no other oder sag mal was dazu du hast das gerade in der Hand du bist der Profi.
Das Bereich I Strick Ware die ich in den Händen halte wo ich mir denke ja so muss das aussehen diese ganzen Popel Strickmaschinen die man so.
Auf dem Kongress sieht und alles ich will das nicht abwerten aber wenn man handstrecker ist und Weiß wie gute Qualität auszusehen hat.
Also ich will das dann halt mit es mir nicht kaufen um es zu tragen an aber das ist das erste Mal dass ich sehe dass der also dass die editis Maschenbild halt sauber ist.
Qualität der Maschen gleichbleibendes also gleich bleiben Herz weiß das nicht und welche Fäden da drin oder Schlaufen das ist echt richtig richtig gute Qualität.
Habe ich schon begeistert ich hätte nämlich nicht gedacht dass Strickmaschinen so geil stricken können.
Geil und das ist halt auch doppelt gestrickt so wie das aussieht schon mein Name drauf,
Business letter drauf angefangen und ich dachte mir schon so ein Hertel automata ist ganz nett aber so erfüllt mir nicht so richtig wie wechselt man mit Mandelbrot und dann.
Mache ich meinen Twitter auf und dann so ja jetzt hier auch mit Mandelbrot und es gibt halt hier so wunderbare Mandelbrot Fraktal Ausschnitte.
Als Schal.
Und ich bin schon fast versucht da gleich noch mal hier Sarah den Schal nachzuschlagen gleich mal auf seine eigenen Bilder einschicken.
Na ja das weiß ich jetzt gerade noch nicht wieder so der Motor eigentlich ist es doch jeder macht kann sie doch programmieren.
Und die dauert immer gleich egal wie das muss das nicht mal so ungefähr jedenfalls also wahrscheinlich wechselt einfach dazwischen zwei Farben und und ja ich weiß nicht ob jeder wechseln bisschen Zeit kostet aber,
eigentlich könnte man auch sagen ihr schickt eure Bilder einer kriegt einen individuellen Schalker seid mit dem er aber sie muss jedes Mal einrichten oder irgendwie so aber,
ja das wäre doch das eigentlich aber er sonst habe ich einen Schal mit dem toll Muster den aber auch tausend andere Leute haben wir noch mal diesen schau noch mal genau an dann guck dir mal an wie die Pixel Aussehen ja alle sind ja am Ende immer noch machen.
Und ich bin erst nicht so richtig tief drin und verfolge Ihr Projekt nur mit einem Auge und quatsche ab und zu mal mit ihr aber da hat sie glaube ich auch eine Sendung mal also,
es gehört schon noch mal ein bisschen was dazu das Bild sozusagen so gut zu machen dass es dann auch in Maschen gut aussieht weil es handelt sich hier nicht um quadratische Pixel.
Du hast ja quasi immer so V-förmige Maschen Verschlingung und wenn du jetzt einfach irgendwie ein Bild nimmst und das dann so aber auch nicht so eine quadratisch aus.
Findet man denkt immer dass das quadratisch ist aber sind deine Becher würde ich sagen.
Ja geht aber es ist halt gut gemacht ja das da das ist ja sozusagen der Sinn dieses Projektes ist.
Einfach extrem gut aussehende Muster direkt zu stricken ist ja keine bedruckten Schals oder sowas ist ja sozusagen wird die Rückseite ist einfach das negativ der Vorderseite.
Na so entweder wenn man mit der Handstrick hat man quasi zwei Nadeln die man so parallel strickt mit den Fäden das kann ich dir das bei deinen Industriemaschinen ist.
Sieht auf jeden Fall sehr sehr gut aus das musste halt deshalb gerne anderes.
Wie irre na ja ich weiß nicht dass ich Migräne hatte es ist für mich so einen visuellen Dingen was mir halt so Auge flimmert ja so eine fahrradrückleuchten ins Gesicht hält dann kriegst du auch noch so ein Epilepsie Anfall,
nee ich bin aber also brauche ich überhaupt nicht ich bin halt extrem empfindlich auf Licht wenn ich oder so so einen krassen Eindrücke wenn ich Migräne habe.
Ja also die Macht damit natürlich jetzt auch so ein bisschen Welle wenn man auf.
YouTube gibt's einige Berichte darüber,
jetzt gerade keinen guten Tipp es gab von ihr auch irgendeinen Tag ist es dir hier ich glaube das ist der hier genau da hat sie sind zum kotzen,
vorgegeben darüber wie sie sozusagen das alles macht genau den schmeiß ich mal hiermit in die Links mit rein.
Und.
Da geht ja so ein bisschen was es alles so für Hintergründe hat und wie sie darum Jahr angeht und so auch die Sachen die sehr Bautzen ist und geschrieben hatte diese einfachen Strickmaschinen,
und irgendwo muss ja auch ein Foto sein von ihrer aktuellen Maschine erinnere hier das ist das.
Was sonst Wohnzimmerecke Monster wie sieht das natürlich jetzt nicht also Stoll was steht da.
Nähmaschine ist das Universum.
CMS 640 HR oder im Meer oder sollte man sich reinlegen so wenn man die Klappe aufmacht blauer Saphir was ist schöner Tag sagst das.
Genau.
Bitte Solarium Zimmer also wenn ihr zu viel Geld habt jetzt ist ja Weihnachten kriegt jetzt schöne wir noch ganz andere Themen zahle Shirts scheiß hat ja aber das ist.
Das ist eine tolle Ware die man halt sonst einfach nur ums wo so bekommt und ist auch alles frisch geprüft und von daher.
Und man hat wahrscheinlich auch ein Trip zum zum Hauptzollamt dann Vorsicht hat man im Kosovo noch mal extra so und hier.
Ja aber die schalt halt nicht und wenn du das zugeschickt bekommst dann ist halt auf jeden Fall noch mal Einfuhrumsatzsteuer fällig und Zollgebühren.
Also ich habe noch mal 40 € wie.
Draufzahlen müssen Mutter nicht dass der Schal 90 $ kostet noch mal 70 €.
Weshalb USA ist halt nicht EU und deswegen Handelsabkommen und Pipapo und wenn du dann halt keinen Importeur hast dir das dann sozusagen für dich alles regelt und du das selbst importiert dann fällt halt,
toll an dann fällt halt Einfuhrumsatzsteuer auch an und dass er sich aber nicht Prozent oder so ist das dann,
Versand Zoll wirklich drauf ist nachdem der Einfuhrumsatzsteuer,
nee man darf da nur Software klicken.
Buch geschickt ich bin jetzt auch ein bisschen am Zweifeln wieder was anderes.
Das kann der Wassergehalt allenfalls Namen habe ich auch schon gelernt also da.
Finding unangenehm ist ja nicht dass das jetzt noch mal extra kostet sondern unangenehm ist es zu wirklich den ganzen Vormittag beim Zoll kriegst du eine andere seit zwei Stunden da nee ich habe das natürlich die Rechnung dafür bekommen per Nachnahme.
Eine Person services gibt so guten die DC auch ohne so einfach kann einfach vom Zoll I Service.
Ich weiß gar nicht wer das veranlasst hat oder wodurch das kam aber auf jeden Fall das Ding kamen.
Bei mir direkt an und es muss ja nicht altern oder.
Zu den chinesischen Kollegen,
und seitdem muss ich irgendwie beim Zoll auf einer schwarzen Liste stehen weil immer wenn ich irgendwas aus dem aus dem Ausland aus dem Nicht-EU-Ausland irgendwoher mir abschicken lassen dann landet immer beim,
beim Hauptzollamt einmal sogar die die Socken aus der Schweiz die dort schon verzollt waren.
Nee also das ist echt schlimm Wegelagerer lustig wenn ich weiß nicht ob das heute noch ja aber danach hingehst sag nur Brixen liegen die den Formular vor dann sollst du denn welche lustigen Codes eintragen und irgendwas und der Zöllner steht denn dann neben dir.
Guck zu und helfen darf er dir aber nicht weil wäre Steuerberatung Schütze Beruf,
also steht da da und guck dir zu und dann kannst du den höchsten Sachen fragen wie weit ist denn das jetzt hier in Deutschland Land schreibe ich da de hin nein nein nein da muss 360 hin natürlich klar Deutschland.
Wäre schön und wo gehen wir denn dahin wenn man internationale Standard benutzen würden einer lauter so Sachen und dann was ich groß für,
Herstellerland blablubb Tralala in der steht im daneben wie du diesen Zettel ausfüllt zerkratzte kriegst du auch gerne die schwarze von ihm die ganzen Codes drin stehen also.
Meistens wenn,
beste und gerade keiner zuguckt dachte der auch weiterhin schreiben sollst du natürlich auch keinen Bock da hat Wurzeln zu schlagen aber offiziell darf alles nicht weil wir sind ja in Deutschland und.
Beratung beim verzollen von Sachen Wer ist wer Steuerberatung und darf er nicht.
So sieht es aus so alle zum bis vor paar Jahren mal vielleicht haben Sie denn zwischen einer jemandem eine s******* aus dem Arsch gezogen wurde aber Berater sind zurück mein Land erkenne hatte bisher noch keiner an dem Stock.
Angefasst ja ja die Steuerberater dran sich allen ihren.
So weiter weiter und alle.
Ausreichend abgesichert nach hinten ja weiß nicht wer will einmal.
Ich hatte jetzt auch mal was über so ruhig,
Rose fahren in einem in einem großen Spielzeug drin sitzen und zwar da wo es auch Spaß macht,
war ja jetzt mal wieder zwei Wochen in Singapur Nähe ITF Meeting und so war das wäre so meine Tweets liest musst du sicher das über das über sich ergehen lassen,
das spannende war dass wir haben auch Zuhörer und zwar nicht nur einzelne sondern auch mehrere in der fliegenden Branche.
Und einer von denen.
Es ergab sich so dass dieser jenige auch der Pilot meines Fluges war mit dem A380 von Frankfurt nach Singapur nach wie habt ihr euch die Überschneidung festgestellt.
Das ist ja wohl kaum einer Stimme erkannt beim Boarden oder nee das war so ein bisschen.
Nee das sieht ja sicherlich im Vorfeld waren bisschen im Vorfeld ein Beobachtung wir hatten nichts vor ein paar letztes Jahr schon mal probiert da ist das aber dann schief gegangen weil dann die Luft an sich kurzfristig überlegt hat,
den lange geplanten Flug dann,
Zeitpunkt X ungefähr eine Woche bevor ich den geflogen bin von A 380 auf 747 umzustellen hahaha aber dieses Jahr hat es geklappt und ich durfte dann mal im A380 vorne im Cockpit ein bisschen mitfliegen,
das ist schon mal das ist schon mal wie auch technisch so durchaus begeistern Teil was ein bisschen ernüchternd wenn man mal so guckt dann.
Haben die da auch so einen Laptop am Start da ist natürlich Windows NT drauf.
So Karten und Manuals und so weiter und sofort aber,
auf der anderen Seite ist es auch irgendwie schon bisschen lästig weil du das hat hast ein Riesenteil ne keine Ahnung 80 Meter Spannweite und allein die Heckflosse 25 Meter große 500 Leute wieder mit fliegen und so schön zu wissen Monster.
Und dann sitzt du da so und unterhält sich mit denen und dann die sind ja,
unglaublich pressiert dadrauf ihr eigenes Kennzeichen im Funk zu erkennen da kann ja irgendwie so was gehört.
Und ist ja wirklich echt krass dahin in Asien ist ja auch weh vom Verkehr wirklich teilweise.
Mega krasse hat welche die Funken von mehreren Bodenstation gleichzeitig diese welche release angeboten haben das heißt du hörst die drei oder vier Mal hintereinander.
Wieso und wieso ein Echo.
Und dass sie da überhaupt irgendjemand verstehen sie schon cool aber jedenfalls dann kommt da so eine Durchsage ja mach mal bitte und der Sahnehering was ich 170 und dann,
dann greift der Copilot so ein bisschen ganz gelangweilt vorne so an deinen ich sag jetzt mal Amaturenbrett und dann sind ganz kleinen Knöpfchen da oben oder Susanne hedding einschätze,
mach dieses Monster Sicherheit ebenso und machte eine fette Kurve und so als man weiß ja schon,
klar es ist jetzt auch der dritte am Auto verändert und Henning blablabla es sind aber es trotzdem schon wieder dieses riesen funktioniert,
gibt es schon ganz lustig und das ist muss ich schon sagen Essen ist ein Sattel Erlebnis Waiblingen weil konnte da konnte man paar Stunden vorne mal mitfliegen.
Zalando beim Start oder nur wenn es verboten im Flug kann man damit wenn der Kommandeur.
Sozial der Kapitän von is also mit Copiloten alleine lassen soll keine fremden rein aber wenn der Kapitän da ist die Finger zu dritt,
so wegen Schicht und so das sind ja also was ich je nach Wetterlage sowohl 12 13 Stunden oder so nach Singapur und ja wenn denn der Kapitän fahren ist in dürfte ich doch mal ein bisschen.
Kickern und man bisschen mit denen sich unterhalten Isa haben auch so schön gesagt ist halt eben wie größere größere Phasen der Langeweile gepflegt von kurzen Terrorattacken.
Je nachdem Bad Hall irgendwas ist ja immer irgendwie mal.
Durfte noch mal umso umso diverse Gewitter mal so ein bisschen rum fliegen weil irgendwie auch lustig war weil die erst fliegst du ja ganz gemütlich das Ding fliegt ja auch hoch 380 ist auch schwer und neueste Technik der wackelt ja eigentlich nicht der macht er sonst.
Aber dann irgendwann merkst du schon in Witzen bisschen unruhig und dann machen wir mal da an so ein bisschen gelb und aus grünen fliegen wir da dann und da ist dann rot.
Oder ist Magenta,
wie die da so zusammen funktionieren.
Ist natürlich klar für Leute die sich für sowas interessieren es sind alle zu alter Hut aber ich fand es mal ganz normal ganz spannend auf wie diese Arbeiten wie so ein 380 ist er ist auch so ein Joystick Ding.
Und arbeite eigentlich machen mit dem Joystick nichts.
Du hast du sehr spannend von Musik und sagen denkt man gar nicht die Steuern ja viele Sachen über Ihren Rechner eben nicht mit Tastatur sie haben zwar vor sich so ein so ein wieso ein Visum Tisch also wenn er so normal passagiersitz hast kannst du auch den Tisch vor die ausklappen,
wir haben auch so ein Tisch den so ausklappen können den könnte aufmachen dass der Tastatur drin.
Damit.
Gänsefüßchen der neben ihnen steckt somit so remote console oder sowas wenn Sie das Bedienen habe damit fliegen würde Ding nicht das Ding vliex und steuern Sie mit.
Trackballs.
Und zwar auch sehr sehr witzig so in der Mitte in der Mittelkonsole zwischen Pilot und Copilot ist auch so ein fetter Bereich und tausend Schaltern und haben Peter Brunner sind so hätte richtig fette metallhobel.
So Hügel.
Wo sie denn vorne wenn die Katze ganze Ding greifen mit der Hand dann hat sie vorne mit den Fingern an diesem an diesem Trackball darum machen und damit navigieren zu halt auf Ihrem System rum klicken welche Sachen an.
Und habe mich dann auch gefragt ja also wie jetzt Maus okay Maus ist blöde somit Strippe oder schnurlose Maus entfällt die runter zu auch nicht aber Touchpad oder vielleicht auf die auf die Glotze tippen gesagt nee das ist dafür baut das wenn das Ding so richtig am ruckeln ist,
wenn die ganze Welt ganze Ding hin und her Shake da willst du nicht auf dem Touchscreen tippen oder auf dem Touchpad oder so und diese Ding da kannst dich komplett dran festhalten und immer noch dann mit den Fingern diesen Trackball den Steuern und damit welche Sachen anklicken,
so eine Sachen wie du zur funktionierte und ja was ist immer und im Funken dann schick sie halten in welchen Gegenden rum wo du den air traffic,
Controller nicht verstehst oder der dich nicht oder so also man macht er immer auf Funk da immer noch rum aber dann gibt's halt eben so gingen da wird dann auch Luft zu Luft noch mal.
Gibt's da gibt's nur bestimmte Kanäle wo Flugzeuge sich untereinander unterhalten können die werden normalerweise nicht so benutzt also aber gegen gingen.
Dann hoffe ich mal angesagt so hier Lufthansa 778 super der ist ja nicht mehr mehr hä wieso ein A 380 ist ja super.
Und so richtig schwer das heißt du möchtest innerhalb der nächsten 20 irgendwas Kilometer hinter ihm nicht irgendwie was anderes rumfliegen haben.
Und ja dann sagt er mal so an dass er da so ist und er sich dadurch die Gegend willst und dass mir nur noch gefälligst Aussage aus dem Weg gehen soll sehen wir sowas Maja.
Soll ich da so ungefähr nicht ganz so aber so ungefähr sah so ein Ding kann ich halt einfach mal sehr spannend das mal auf ein lustiges lustiges Spielzeug.
Ja schöne Grüße an Steffen Stefan den ich ja auch zu Gast hatte im TAE.
211 das war noch vor seiner A380 Zeit da ist er gerade umgesattelt sozusagen aber berichtet da sozusagen aus einer langjährigen Erfahrung mit Boeing verfolgen viel geflogen und dann halt irgendwie ins.
80 königsklassen Team aufgenommen worden sind.
Genau dann auch mal ich war mit ihm mal im.
Simulators for katzentante Lufthansa in Hamburg.
Wollte dieses Training macht derweil die Piloten am laufenden Meter immer wieder.
Trainiert werden müssen und vor allem auch fortgehen / sensibilisiert werden müssen für diese ganzen note to Aktionen weil man hat sie halt nicht so oft aber wenn man die hat dann,
will man die halt drauf haben ne vielleicht ganz interessant nur mal so sehen konnte okay Mama das jetzt Mama dass wir auch ordentlich mit bewegt sich ja alles relativ,
ich zwar soweit ich das nachvollziehen kann leider keine auch welche Dinge aus das Schicksal mal das Umfeld wieder irgendwas aus was,
tschüss geht ja auch wir unseren unser Triebwerkes irgendwie aus und ach nee und dann können wir auch nicht mehr richtig landen und als die ganzen Dinger wieder so passieren Fahrrad für mich natürlich irgendwie mega Extremsituationen wie alles.
Erst mal anlernen muss in dem Moment sehr schöner Besuch.
Du sagtest gerade gibt's Monitore die Devise lisieren aber spätestens da ich aufgehört mit den mit den Vorhersagen wie es Wetter ist.
Jedes Rathaus einfach gnadenlos Wetterradar selber mit Sicherung fliegt also Ritze,
weil ich weiß es auch doppelt und dreifach und so aber.
Ich weiß das nicht eine Forschungsgruppe gab auch die genau das versucht hat zu visualisieren wie man mit Unsicherheiten im Flugverkehr umgeht wenn du ebenso auf Wetterphänomene Hinweisen willst wie du das mit dem Piloten sichtbar machen kannst.
Versteh mal sehen.
Ich weiß gerade ne also auf dem auf dem Weg Richtung Singapur relativ kurz davor sozusagen meinen letzten Minuten vorne sitze auch geleitete und von einem Bodenmann wo ich echt erstaunt war.
Wie gut er auch das Wetter im Blick hatte die Jungs waren selber auch ganz Ich wollte mal so ja können wir nicht der hat aber vorher schon sehr Boden Mensch,
hat vorher schon gesagt nee fliegt man da und jetzt da Deterding unter langsam und damit die halt so machen sollen und immer schön genau um es geht der Lotse der Lotse ja und die ganzen die ganzen kleinen Magenta Fleckchen darum so das war schon,
war schon ganz spannend,
pass auf da also da gab's auch durchaus mal schöne schöne Aussichten ist ja jeder Tageszeit bisher immer so ein bisschen hinten in der Kabine dem die der gerne mal die Sicht.
Weil die haben die Figur hat sich wie so ein Schema ausgedacht wie sie gerne möchten dass die Leute da hinten die 500 Leute gerne pennen.
Oder so nah und deswegen heißt ja dann immer zu bestimmten Zeit jetzt mach mir die Sonnenblenden alle zu.
Und dann ist der Dusche an den Pen die alle aber im Cockpit macht natürlich kein Handy sondern runter und das heißt ich habe dann auch schöne Sachen gesehen Mount Everest z.b.
Von oben also hinten in der fahren aber so eine Sachen DC info da hinten in der Kabine war du sauer weil die da alle wie alle sagt haben jetzt mal pennen oder so eine heiße Nase.
Sag das auf das kann ich auch welche welchem Flug ist da gemacht habe aber auch so über Brasilia ich mal wieder mal rausgeguckt sowieso Willen weil ich nicht schlafen konnte sofort die Stuhr diese anmachen,
hast du nicht immer meine,
weil guck wo die ist weil ich habe das kann das auch super über den Amazonas zu fliegen und runter gucken nee ich meinte über den Anden gibt ja auch so viele der Verwirbelungen vom Wind deswegen müssen die ja beim Landen noch immer weiter übers Wasser an Bogen machen.
Um landen zu können Alina von da bin ich gestartet nee ich bin einmal in Santiago gelandet Santiago de Chile und in Ecuador Quito.
Das war halt echt über die anderen immer diese Verwirbelungen auch im Flug gemerkt war schon gesagt ist eine ziemlich fette Sause und 380 den.
Den kann man schon bisschen rütteln aber nicht so einfach glaube ich.
So ein bisschen Monster euch wartet wie gesagt ganz ganz spannend auf so die Technik sich der Mann zurückkommen jetzt gar nicht so viele Details bei mir ist nicht mehr so eine aber.
Ja wenn man mal irgendwie mal die Gelegenheit dazu hatte oder so ein bisschen Tennis interessiert ist dann.
Dass man Empfehlung kann man einfach das gerne mal sehen,
und dann sagen die jo klar oder muss man da gibt's schon drei jetzt nach nine eleven gibt's da so Spielregeln also Zeit geht jetzt auch nur Wallet Lufthansa flight wer der nicht über USA oder ihren 51 Bundesstaat also UK.
Gegangen ist da da wäre sowas striktes Dance verboten und zwar so richtig strikt komplett verboten.
Barra Lufthansa wenn man da eine Beziehung hat und das vorher anmeldet also dann geht das.
Ja gut.
Leidensweg danke ich hoffe dass sie auch immer noch mal fernflugreisen antreten kann so ein bisschen der Anlass noch ordern.
Ich brauch mal wo,
wo wir schon bei höherer und wo Leute fliegen die man kennt und im Cockpit und so weiter,
mich hat jemand angesprochen der sich vor einem halben Jahr einen Hyundai ioniq gekauft hat ob ich den mal fahren möchte,
möchte sagt ja klar mache ich also Hyundai ioniq ist ein Elektrofahrzeug von Hyundai eben,
der Ursulinen an der letzten Sendung mich versprochen habe mit Honda und Idioten gemacht wurde aber Jürgen 300 von Hyundai.
Hört sich super der hört sich super als er es nicht nicht ganz so es nicht so aggressiv ed3.
Aber das ist insgesamt ein sehr unauffälliges Auto also der ist angenehmsten Sinne unauffällig von vorne bis hinten hat Platz 40 gut.
Ist.
Sieht nicht so komisch aus wie so ein i3 z.b. und ist halt auch nicht so übermotorisiert wie andere Elektroautos also ich war da sehr angetan von dem.
Wann ich war das ganz nett da irgendwie mal eine Runde zu drehen mit dem Ding also,
unterstelle ja einfach nur ohne aufregend ja was ich was ich ganz spannend fand viele viele Autos also so Elektroautos haben ja noch so einen,
so einen Schalthebel wie man ihn von so Automatik Autos kennt ne hast du Nebel wurde als off drive und newtral und reverse und und irgendwie Park und so weiter stellen kannst hat er halt überhaupt nicht der hat halt für,
diese DNF weiß ich nicht alles hat er hatte also vier Tasten die du dann halt also drück drück szon.de und dann fährt er.
Die Warentester ich habe auch keine Gänge hat ein Hebel ne.
Ja er hat nicht übel alleine hebelten wie bei den Amis auf der Automatik Schalthebel ist bei manchen.
Ja der hat der hat überhaupt kein Hebel mehr sonst also ist er so wie ein Blinkerhebel ja ich weiß ich weiß.
Ich dachte erst zur AAR nicht was ist das für ein Auto aber der ist der ist irgendwie so der fährt sich echt nett wenn wenn jemand so einen Sohn,
Elektroauto will was einfach auch unauffällig ist eine gewisse Größe hat sich als Familienauto eignet und so dann kann ich kann ich den tatsächlich empfehlen.
Lustigerweise hat er den von dem von dem einen ionic Autohändler dem ein Hyundai Autohändler in Landsberg,
am Lech der irgendwie in Deutschland alle ionix verkauft,
der hat sich irgendwie darauf spezialisiert von euch auch gehört ja nur die auch nichts zu kaufen weil Sven so hast du viele Grüße von hier aus der hat halt zu dem Zeitpunkt noch da unten gewohnt,
und hat so ein bisschen geguckt,
Was gibt's so für Autos wo sind denn deine nächsten Händler und ist halt also den ironic angucken wollte genau bei dem gelandet aus Zufall und hat halt über den dann auch relativ flott sein Auto bekommen,
also der also man muss auf die Toilette.
28,5 Kilowattstunden genau genau so knappe 30 Kilowattstunden was jetzt nicht riesig ist aber es ist viertel vor.
3 von immer du hast immer gut weil er verbraucht hat noch 11,5 Kilowattstunden.
Er meinte sowas von 11 Uhr bis 12 Uhr wenn man jetzt nicht aggressiv wird das kommt schon hinten ja so Model X macht schon irgendwie seine 15/16 oder.
Hängt davon ab und damit fahren wir mit in Schweden Fahrer komme ich so mit 16 oder so hin wenn ich damit hier in Deutschland fahre meistens um die 200.
200 also nicht 200 also 20 Kilowattstunden für 100 km aber ich rechne mal in Wattstunden pro Kilometer.
Was passiert Unterschied zwischen in Schweden und in Deutschland fahren.
Na dort Langstrecke hierher Langstrecke ueberstorf ordentliche Geschwindigkeitsregelung und nicht so deutschen die Ameise brustschilder so hinzustellen so.
70 dann für 50 m 100,
dann wieder für 50 Meter 70 und besser so eine Geschichte Nummernschild oha ich natürlich auch automatisch das macht er,
kaschieren.com jetzt kann man ja immer besser wird dann Schild hingestellt dann halt eben noch von meinem Mann von Sommer jetzt im Schweden sagen dass sie da Ex,
deutlich weniger verbraucht er gesagt ungefähr so 160 Watt schimpfen Kilometer.
365 aber deutlich weniger als hier hier kann ich halt wenn ich extrem drauf achte kann ich Ihnen unter 200 lassen aber wenn ich jetzt einfach nur vor mich hin farbig meist 200-205 oder sowas.
Das ist halt hier einfach dieser Verkehrslage geschuldet und diesen diesem Affenzirkus mit den Schildern und den Bremsen und Beschleunigen auf dem Plan Block und,
Stadtverkehr auch Tickets in Schweden auch nicht soviel interessant bei dem ist das so dass er nicht ganz so viel Rekuperieren macht oder rejane,
der hat so derzeit am Lenkrad wieso im Rennwagen so zu 2 so Taste die man zu sich hinzieht.
Damit vorderste Texter an zum Bremsen damit kannst du auf der einen Seite mehr auf der anderen Seite weniger rejane also Rekuperieren Einstein hatte sind wir von 0 bis 3,
so Stufen warum will man das einstellen wollen bei mir auch gerade ich weiß es nicht ich habe es gleich auf die höchste Stufe gestellt,
Ja und wandern damit glücklich ist so schön so eine Motorbremse fact unterschied oder ob man stark abgebremst wird oder eher nicht so ein kleiner gleich dem garstig final verstrichen runter und dann war es halt sofort ab und wahrscheinlich so,
weil Leute das nicht so gewohnt sind ja das glaube ich auch an so ausrollen wollen das blöd ist ja eigentlich super lade ja damit dann,
Bremszug sagen ne das macht der Tesla z.b. jetzt stehst du da nicht ein Salat hängt davon ab wie schnell du den Fuß vom Fahrpedal nimmst,
bin in schnell nimmt wenn ja dann wenn ruckartig runter nimmst dann denkt der sich oh du möchtest auch gerne relativ ruckartig stehen bleiben Dateien der Operette stark wenn er langsam einfach nur den Fuß runter nimmst dann kolata halt eben,
deswegen heißt das soll Segeln.
Dörte hat mir sehr gut gefallen ok kostet.
In der Liste steht da glaube ich mit 35 oder 36 er meinte er hätte die Vollausstattung genommen rechts unten.
Quasi.
Wenn du dann noch den Rabatt abbrechen ist und der Händler hat die mögen ja auch noch so ein bisschen was nachgelassen meint er wäre auf 30 gekommen.
Völlig in Ordnung ist für dich also gute Elektroautos und halt ein bisschen teurer Moment noch aber.
Also wenn wenn das jetzt nicht in billiger dafür langfristig ein bisschen billiger ja wenn du sendest jetzt mit mit.
Was ich nicht mit der neuen Zoe vergleichst dann oder dem Kia Soul dann ist sie sind alle so ein bisschen in dem Bereich,
aber es ist dann auch so mit Akku mieten oder nee nee das ist mit kaufakku okay.
Aber die soll die neue Zoe wenn du den da den Akku auch kaufst du kannst ihn jetzt mit kaufen ja das ist ja auch relativ teuer also.
Eva kein was besser ist also diese mietmodelle fand ich jetzt auch so falsch nicht aber am Ende ein Rechenspiel ne.
Ja ist ein bisschen merkwürdig also ich meine wenn du so ein Auto least dass du dann auch die AR den akkumiete sitzt sehe ich noch irgendwie ein aber ein Auto kaufen und dann den akute in dem besten im Auto verbaut ist nur zu mieten des.
Irgendwie fühlt sich das komisch an finde ich warum ich finde das hört sich komisch an also ja komisch weiß.
Nur weil es nicht gewohnt bist oder weil es kann ja wohl zu kaufe ich das Auto wenn ich dann den Penis als Teil halt.
Doch die Bremsscheiben und so überlege es klappt noch nicht mal diese Bremsscheiben Elektroauto.
Wenn du rekuperiert wenn man entweder nur eine normale Bremsen mit drin aber nur für Notfall,
fang an zu rosten und wenn du dann sieh mal benutzt den quietschende erstmal merke ich dass es eigentlich ungern benutze zu bremsen Magnete und einfach,
verstärken also im Normalfall.
Also ein Freund von mir ja der wohnt in Norwegen und der meinte schon beim normalen Auto hat er das Problem dass die Bremsen relativ schnell rosten.
Und er könnte sich das nicht vorstellen mit einem Elektroauto in Norwegen aber keine Ahnung.
Perle warte im Winter mit mit Salbei und so verliert Wasser Energie in diesem Fall ein solides Auto also,
früher hatte ich so jetzt nicht erwartet nicht auf dem Schirm so gut ich hatte auch überhaupt keine Erwartungen aber.
Verstehe Yvonne erfüllt.
Schon mal Autos in sehe ich da sehen wir uns dann ist noch Tesla oder das ist hässlicher wenn man den Block haben dann genau.
Kann man upgraden von Model X auf auf den Roadster aber du kommst ja kein Model XL.
Oder ein Sattelschlepper ist wirklich nur die Zugmaschine der den Aufleger den hast ja ein beliebigen dann.
Auf dem Winkel bei allen LKW so also ja also.
Mich alle Maschine für etwas was man dann LKW nennt so wenn es dann zusammengebaut ist und das Ding hat zwar jetzt nicht die mega Reichweiten sowieso was wir 100 km.
500 Meilen bei Highway speed.
Willst du von dem Roadster nein nein von dem semi sehen wir uns heute 1000 € 2000 km ja ja ja,
bei amerikanischen Highway speed wahrscheinlich aber ja okay gut dann habe ich das vielleicht durcheinander gebracht ich hatte so den Eindruck bekommen dass das Ding Premiere eigentlich für dieses Tagesgeschäft gemacht ist also für diese Kurzstrecken delivery,
für Just-in-time-Produktion ist ja aber was weiß ich ob wir was ich da ganz sicher aus und hat irgendwie ein komisches und lädt schnell,
sagen wir mal,
Holland Süditalien in NA mit Fahrerwechsel in einem Rutsch schaffst du mit dem Ding nicht ja sondern du schaffst halt.
Weiß ich nicht Holland Ruhrgebiet.
Ich mein entscheidendes ja wie viele viele Witze an einem Tag damit fahren so und wo du halt fahren und ich denke mal das Ding bitte sich jetzt primär nicht unbedingt für Langstrecke an.
Weil im Langstrecken Bereich ist glaube ich die Notwendigkeit nicht so gegeben wie halt jetzt in den Städten wo in zunehmenden Maße eben auch fahrverbot für Lkw ist der gibt ja auch schon so ein paar,
Titisee ganz konsequent auf LKW in der Innenstadt z.b. nicht mehr haben wollen aber es halt auch einfach eine Frage wie hält man richtiges Innenstadt Fahrzeug ist es dann auch nicht halten Sattelschlepper,
und ich mitten unbedingt mit deiner also Mittel mittellange streckenweise jetzt nicht so last mile delivery.
Also die die Werte die das Teil liefert wann kann ich schon.
Extrem also von 0 auf 100 in 5 Sekunden wenn kein Hänger drauf ist,
da fährt er heute Model 3 davon zumindest von der Zahl her weiß ich auch so ein bisschen absurd finde und mit Volllast er sprach von 80000 Pfund das müssen also 40 Tonnen sein.
Ist da irgendwie die genaue Zahl Band 20 Sekunden oder so also irgendwie immer noch Battlefield 4 komplett albern.
Weil das jetzt,
so ein Quatsch werd niemals niemals wirst du irgendwie jemand der damit mir ernsthafte Ladung befördert,
den sehen dass der auf Pedal tritt und guckt in seiner Ladung hinten aus dem aus dem Container rausrutscht oder ihm das Ding oder den es gibt gibt mal so ein anderes Bild wird schmaler Wind habe gibt es ein anderes Video und die man mal ausprobiert hat Model X hat ja eine Hängerkupplung.
Ob man da Sohn Sohn Sohn Wohnwagen dran macht oder so ob das Ding denn immer noch lustig beschleunigt wenn man einfach drauf tritt.
Ja mach das man sieht denn auf dem auf dem Video wieso sagen er diese den Hänger,
diesen den Anhänger Unterbau mit der den den Metallteil mit den Rädern unter dem Wohnwagen wegzieht,
ja dann halt einfach Lea denke ich da auch albern was willst du da jetzt was interessant ist wo sie natürlich recht haben ist dass das Teil auch Amberg nach performed,
oder was hat mit 0 auf 100 in 15 Minuten 30 Sekunden nichts zu tun aber das ist den können sich Leute vorstellen.
Also er hat trotzdem Event wenn du halt wenn der halt unter Volllast 514 Steigung immer noch normal in normaler Geschwindigkeit den Berg hoch kommt dann,
Bad ist natürlich auch Zeit also das ist ja die die eigentliche Rechnung dahinter,
ja genau du sagst du immer Zeit und Geld zahlst du bei voller Beladung oder halt einmal runterbremsen musst wegen irgendjemand es langsam,
dauert das halt in der Regel eine Weile bis hinauf wieder auf seinen Speed kommst und wenn du sowas schnell überbrücken kannst und auch irgendwie bei kurzen Unterbrechung Stausituation Zittau,
da schnell wieder auf Fahrt kommst dann ist es ja gut für die Durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit und die ist entscheidend.
Ich habe das erst jetzt neu Venedig von paar Tagen gab's sommer Sonne Sonne beachtrekker irgendwie bei mir ich meine zitherwirt rauschte,
von dem lade Connector von ihm denk weil es gibt ja für die Eier gibt ja für die für die anderen Tesla es gibt ja diese die schönen supercharger für das Ding brauchen sie jetzt mega charger,
die anderen mit angekündigt war die letzte so ein Ding brauchst ja selbst ein supercharger braucht Erding eine Weile deswegen hatte mega Charger wurde wirklich mit Megawatt,
das Ding rein. Na super charger sind zu 140 145 wieder one hour Zahlen genannten ich glaube nicht so dass die viel können die mir gerade und das jetzt auch elektrotechnisch wieder spannend und interessiert dann auch so ein Netz.
Immer so ein ordentlicher supercharger somit Version oder noch mehr Station ist auch was Interessantes für Netz.
Sie hat mir aber heute nicht mehr zurück mit Pufferbatterie und und und Solar und hast du nicht gesehen brauchst du auch weil du hast du ja auch wieder wie auch für Sonnenphysik örtlichen Stecksystem.
Perfektes Ding an alle Windräder in der Umgebung bleiben stehen.
Das hat nicht verstanden das ist nicht so eine Windräder erzeugen keinen Wind mit dem Strom aus dem Netz nein aber der Widerstand.
Also der ist ja energie aus der Luft und.
Lässt das Video ihr gerade richtig interpretiere ich dachte das gerade einem anderen Fahrzeug zugeordnet aber sich das richtig dass der auch so eine rundum LED Technik hat das wenn der fährt.
Ich streite nicht nur nicht nach vorne soll er beleuchtet total auch sein sein links rechts Umfeld weiß nicht genau der ist immer so eine am nicht zur,
zur Sprache in dem verspannten an dem Ding ist mal so eine andere Sache der Fahrersitz bei dem Ding,
in der Mitte es gibt nur einen Sessel und er sich in der Mitte deswegen bauen sie nicht links und rechts Fahrer Variante sondern gibt halt ein so ein Ding und der Typ sitzt halt in der Mitte.
Aber realistisch.
Erstmal einfach mal anders für kürzere Strecken ist es halt auch sinnvoll du fährst ja nicht mit mehreren.
JRC wie wird es irgendwie geil damit 0,36 wie auch schon woanders besprochen,
CW Wert ist halt nicht alles weil der eigentliche Luftwiderstand ergibt sich aus cw-Wert und der sogenannten Schattenfläche also das was du von vorne siehst unten.
Sonst frag halt halt die entsprechende Schattenfläche Rede.
Ja der hatte einen cw-Wert wie ein ICE oder so aber dass der halt nicht in CW Wert hat also das so ein Bugatti Chiron halten schlechteren cw-Wert hat das sieht man dem Ding ja an mit seinen ganzen Tieren,
geh dran beim LKW nein hatte den vergessen.
Dass der SAM einen besseren cw-Wert hat als Erzieherin und du siehst es dem Chiron an weil der hat halt über Ecken und Kanten obwohl er rund und flach ist es wäre diese Diskussion mit dem Roadster gewesen egal.
Nee in einer Elan Masters ist auch nicht mehr das mag ja irgendwie wirklich ein interessanter Typ sein ne.
Aber seine Kinos ich will nicht reden und Anni reden ich will immer nur mit Eiern werfen wenn ich das sehe ich kann ich kann es auch nicht ertragen ne,
also sie schon die Zusammenfassung machen mich wahnsinnig was ist ich meine was ist denn bei dem kaputt,
der W ich glaube der war einfach komplett über der ist meine ist aufgeregt und komplett übermüdet na so.
Immer jede.
Timing nur dass das für die auch ist dieses immer die hatten ja dann so noch aber ich wollte LKW angekündigt und dann haben sie ja so nen rosa.
So und dann habe ich so gehört ja die große Überraschung bei der Präsentation der mir dann auch noch dann Tatar war auf einmal so großer dass wir so okay gucke ich mir das mal an schon wie diese Stelle an.
Dass ich wahrscheinlich gleich geguckt.
Und ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich da vielleicht sitzt so in dem falschen Zusammenschnitt aufgeworfen bin aber in der Chronologie wie sich das davon mehr abgespielt hat,
oder so ja LKW und dann irgendwie Schnitt das irgendwie über und dann lief um die 30 Sekunden lang dieses Ding dann hatte das irgendwie in die Halle rein wie hast du nein wahrgenommen das war anders das war anders er hat den Event,
quasi beendet,
aber nur so quasi sehr also ilon ist so erhalten Steve zu Polen mit meiner thank my fingers Osu von der Bühne gegangen es wurde dunkel und dann haben sie dieses Video gespielt mit dem Spaceballs,
na also von von Ludacris auf Platt,
also der fährt der Joe hinter hinter insane Mode und ludicrous Mode ist ja Spaceballs wusstest du nicht.
Durch die Simpsons lange her dass Hilfe bei Spaceballs gibt's doch diese Szene wo sie mit dem Raumschiff losfliegen und normalerweise bei Star Trek ist es ja so dass die Sterne einfach nur Streifen bilden ja und,
bye bye Spaceballs ist das so dass die Sterne bilden erst Streifen dann gibt es irgendwie Querbalken und dann gibt es noch mehr Kram weil sie immer noch einen Hörschaden dann noch ein neuer scheint ja noch einen hörscheid genau und,
insane Mode und der Ludacris Mode sind schon die ersten zwei Mal höher schalten bei spaceborn daher kommt das,
und der Platz Mode den der Rotsee jetzt hat das ist das dritte Mal hochschalten bei leider ist Bolzplatz PLA,
geschrieben ich fahre los ich habe den Film auch immer nur auf Deutsch gesehen ich weiß nicht genau was jetzt wie die das übersetzt haben deswegen war ich auch so hell wovon reden die da ja genau also es wurde dunkel dann hatten sie das Video eingespielt mit diesem.
Streifen Querbalken und so weiter und den haben die Leute schon angefangen frenetisch zujubeln und der eine der eine LKW ist halt nur so high von der Bühne gefallen dann ging hinten die Klappe auf.
Na haben Sie so die die die runterfahre rinnenthal runtergeklappt und dann fuhr halt Franz von Holzhausen oder friends from Neuhausen oder Viren mit denen aus Sprengsätze,
dass der Designer von dem Auto von Tesla ja,
der alle Autos des Johnny Ralf von genau der Johnny alive von Tesla ja und der Vorteil daraus winkte und drehte dann noch eine Ehrenrunde relativ flott und dann kam WLAN wieder an und hat dann,
Anfang 14.
Ja also da verging 30 Sekunden oder so oder 60 Sekunden bis jemand mal gesagt hat was da eigentlich passiert.
Ja aber das war den Leuten die da war allen klar die sind ja alle übergekocht.
Warum hast denn klar also ich übergekocht weiß vorher ja schon dieses dieses referral Programm gab von,
von Tesla,
das mit wo du mit genug Lieferzeiten verbilligten Roadster bekommen hast und wenn du 55041 hattest dann bekam zu den Roadstar nexgen Roadster immer umsonst also,
war schon im Raum es wird ein NextGen Roadster geben das war das ist voll viel verlangt eingeschlafene Füße mäßig ist immer Vollkorn.
Ja ich habe viel drüber nachgedacht aber ich kann mit dem Auto sowie habe ich nichts anfangen.
Ja genau und dann kamen sie mit diesem komplett unsinnigen Auto also wo.
Ison halt nur meinte wie hat er das genannt so hoch dass all purpose of this KAS Zugriff.
Combustion engine Card count Hardcore SmackDown oder so ähnlich hat das genannt also einfach mal ein für allemal darzustellen.
Das sind alles Traktoren.
Wahrscheinlich nicht ne.
Obwohl du mit dem Rott wahrscheinlich noch am ehesten zur Arbeit fahren könntest zumindest welchen Termin ich bin wenn er dann ein super chill Mode hat den brauchst du dann glaube ich aber.
Ja also ich meine es schon irgendwie ich weiß ja gar nicht wie sie in dieses kleine Auto so viel Akku reinkriegen dass er sowieso eine Reichweite hat Wasser bei 1000 km 1000 km 200 Stunden.
Haben sie gesagt hätte der also es wird vermutet aber auch die,
übermäßige Option mit extra Plus muss die normale Version Enterprise model,
also es wird gemunkelt dass diese neuen zählen die sie ja für das Model 3 gebaut haben dass die leistungsfähiger sind.
Und deswegen eine höhere Leistungsdichte haben.
Und wahrscheinlich packen sie auch zwei LAN zwei Lagen Batterien da rein.
Na also die anderen Tesla's haben ja alle eine also muss ich denn sonst so ein so ein Akku Ding sieht halt aus wie eine normale Batterie so ein rundes Teil und die werden zu so Paketen zu so blocken zusammen.
Geschlossen und dann werden mehrere Blöcke zu so einem kleinen Platte oben Titanplatte und zu lachen Akkupack zusammengebaut und.
Die Vermutung ist dass der roadster zwei Lagen von diesem stehenden Batterien im Boden hat.
Weil irgendwie müssen sie dadrauf kommen aber ich nehme mal auch an die brauchen so viele Einzelzellen und tatsächlich auch so viel Strom rauszuziehen wenn da halt dann so drei Motoren betreiben willst und frei.
Drei.
Na hier das Hinterrad je einen und die fingernagelform Gewitter und irgendwie mit Kraftvektoren damit das Teil auch gerade ausfährt wenn.
Du drauf trittst wenn du drauf trittst und das geht und so weiter dass es dich nicht gleich so Ferrari Style von der Straße Haut.
Auf YouTube zu schauen also ja kann man machen ist ein schöner Technologie Demonstrator aber wahrscheinlich keinen.
Gebrauchsgegenstand im üblichen Sinne,
okay also was halten wir fest und es wird weiterhin viel angekündigt was vielleicht unter Umständen irgendwann mal vielleicht auch zu kaufen ist und vielleicht auch irgendwann mal das magische Jahr 2020.
Was ist dann,
da gibt's alles da gibt's dann alles was Elektromobilität besonders in Deutschland gibt's dann alles ja weil alle deutschen Hersteller für 20/20 ankündigen ja und jetzt scheinbar gibt's da noch ein bisschen Konkurrenz zu den vielleicht hier auch schon endlich 200 Megabit,
mit super Hyper super rückwärts Vectoring und so 220 x 220.
Uplink braucht man hier nicht höher im Gegensatz zu anderen Ländern.
Dass das mal kurz einschmeißen Marcel ja Singapur.
Du hast ein Singapur ja ja ich wüsste A380 geflogen richtig,
ich habe da auch wieder ein bisschen was gemacht und da hat er dazu natürlich auch Kontakt mit lokalen Leuten und da jetzt gerade ein bisschen Regenzeit ist es da eher so ein bisschen so,
was macht seit Wochenende und am Abend sind so rechtzeitig zu Hause und habe also da mal Leute mit dir ich aus dem Hotel da zusammengearbeitet habe gefragt so am Freitagabend so was machst du am Wochenende in die Serie Wetter ist scheiße auf einmal zu Hause gucken bisschen fern gucken bisschen Internet und so,
sowas habt ihr nie so viel Internet Gigabit so symmetrisch.
Um 6 Uhr vor vier Uhr für 20 € ne 24,
nicht mehr das was es mal war ganz einfach klicken muss jetzt nicht speziell und wo betteln gehen oder alle dass sie das eigentlich gar nicht brauchen.
Dein scheiß sie haben trotzdem und es gibt auch dieses Angebot was auch kein Mensch braucht was aber trotzdem gibt's wenn du das Gigabit nicht reicht kannst du auch 10 g haben für 139 Singapur-Dollar Staffel 39.
Was ist denn die Scheiße sehen wollte jetzt mal wieder 839 Singapur-Dollar waren ungefähr 24 € bis ungefähr 0, also zwei Drittel Volieren.
Alpha R.
Uni Lenkung macht das noch so lange dass es bald billiger ist nicht mehr Leistung aus und vorher lesen.
Man kann natürlich das jetzt mal hinterfragen warum und wie machen die das wieder so und sie machen so wie alle Länder wurde erfolgreich funktioniert.
Sie trennen den Inhaber vom Glas von dem Provider,
das haben die Deutschen bis heute nicht verstanden es geht einfach nicht in deren Hirn rein.
Singapur Set oder gibt es halt eine Handvoll Firmen die LEG Glas und zwar nur Glas.
Ja in der ganzen Stadt überall rum in die Wohnung und überall hin wo man das haben will und dann zieht man dort eine Wohnung ein guck dann auch seine Dose was da für eine Nummer drauf steht und dann ruf sucht man sich irgendeinen von ein oder zwei Dutzend Provider in aus,
und sagt hallo ich möchte gerne Internet von dir haben sagt dir wie ist denn die Nummer auf deiner Dose und dann.
Inge dadrauf in Pettstadt heißt es gibt dort unabhängig Instanzen die dafür zuständig sind die Infrastruktur zu erzeugen.
Garantiert bestimmt aufgefordert für diese Preise aber ist ja okay kann man ja machen und dann gibt's halt Leute die darauf Dienste anbieten.
Inserted so kenne ich dich eben auch Ausländer wie Schweden oder sowas wird auch selber erfolgreiche Modelle.
Und deswegen gibt es da halt eben auch Markt deswegen gibt es auch Konkurrenz Preiskampf lalala Pipapo und deswegen kann man sich daneben auch ein Weg symmetrisch für 39 Singapur-Dollar klicken.
Bereitstellung üblicherweise am selben Tag manchmal auch 2-3 Tage später wenn man selber mal drauf geklickt.
Auf dem Ding nicht auf dem Ding bei dem Kollegen zu Hause weil da war ich nicht aber ich hatte auch Leitung wir hatten wir sind diesmal ein bisschen überschwemmt worden von den Providern.
Dort was bisschen unübliches in einer Asien normalerweise muss man einmal ein bisschen betteln gucken dass mein Mann findet Beats gibt in Singapur war das so dass wir mehr gekriegt haben als wir angefordert haben,
also vielleicht für die nee dann zu regelmäßigen Fritz eurer du warst wieder auf dem IDF,
Meeting Agenda gemacht mal wieder teilnehmen auf der zählt hast immer aus anderen Ländern und jetzt was hat Singapur.
ITF 100-102 Party neben.
Da war vorher richtig ab.
War sehr lustig,
wie sagt zu dem Thema wie viel Material wie viel Classen so was haben wir da am Start also wir hatten eine kann man noch nennen da bist du auch so ein größerer laden.in großer Telekom Anbieter die haben allzu gesagt ja ich doch gerne von uns in Gigabit hier kein Thema und der Tag kam ich habe,
meiste davon aus Berlin vor koordiniert also.
Den Kollegen aus dem hotel.am am Telefon ich hatte vorher Kollegen die im August da waren die haben mein Scout Router der immer so ein bisschen vorneweg schon fliegt.
DaB geschmissen im Hotel und haben gesagt so hier Hotel Leute da sitzt er das Depot da sind die Ports beschriftet und wenn hier was passiert ruf durch den Clemens an und extra mal was drauf.
Und es kam also der Tag das da das da habt denn die Isomatte so wird das liegt ja jetzt muss jetzt noch jemand in den Router einstecken und ich rufe dann im Hotel an sagst du mal bitte die Start-Stopp in den Router rein,
und der so welche die Wurster habt draufsteht nee wir haben zwei Fotos Dahab draufsteht und ich so.
Dahab kontaktiert und diese.
Ja wir waren grad dabei haben sie bisschen Glas gelegt sie und dann Mittag du auch zwei Leitung wenn er auch besser als eine oder steck mal rein Dinge die sie in Deutschland,
einfach mal zwei davon ab geschmissen und ich glaub halt eben auch andere andere Provider die haben vom Prinzip mit derselben Technik gelegt war jetzt nicht da habe aber kann man auch nennen,
Bandit Quest Immortal die haben mit derselben Technik gelegt wie etwas Leute zu Hause kriegen mit mit keep on also geht Bonn,
persofort Pickel network,
kann ich bei einer Ringelnatter die haben aber symmetrisch befahren als mit 1 Gigabyte in beide Richtungen und wird Crystal auch Blogger raus ist als sie sind auch gut konnektiert die Leute Singapur ist ja auch so einer der größeren,
hab's dort in der Gegend nämlich jetzt eben bei dem Privatanschluss eigentlich fragen also wenn die jetzt sagen Gigabit,
wie weit reicht das dann auch also ich meine ist das quasi nur die letzte Meile kann das theoretisch und dahinter versiegt ist schon wieder irgendein Sumpf oder kriege ich halt zu YouTube tatsächlich Gigabit Datenstrom hin,
dazu YouTube die ganze facetube Puppe Chris natürlich hin weil die haben ihre eigene die haben natürlich data centers in Singapur CDs die diesen Bereich dort,
bedienen geografisch,
das ist alle gar kein Problem du kriegst auch nach Europa du hast das jetzt nicht irgendwie noch nennen und fertig die machen auch keinen Sex oder so.
Und du kriegst es auch wenn du deine Software entsprechend Dienst weil du hast natürlich schon ein bisschen Delay nach Europa,
der beste was ich hingekriegt hatte war die eine Strecke sieht eine Route über HNF wartet auf wirklich geographisch richtig rum geht,
also sozial von Singapur gen Westen Richtung Europa waren so 185 Millisekunden Delay.
Je nach Berlin und werde dann natürlich deine dann Datentransfer machst du mit entsprechend großen Waffe aus und Windows heißes und so dann kannst du das auch,
also Christoph durch aber normal sind jetzt so ein Mac SCP machst oder so weiter Ungetüm und oder so weiter muss platzen wie bei 70-80 Megabit oder sonst was hängen,
weil die zu einfach die dein dein System ist nicht darauf vorbereitet der Dicke Datenmengen mit einem solchen Delay zu transportieren sind dafür die Verfasser ist zu klein.
Und die Richtung wie sagt ist auch sehr wichtig da habe ich noch eine Weile dran gefummelt weil wir wie gesagt dann auf 5 Provider hatten und dann habe ich so ein bisschen mal getunt was wir die Richtung ist wichtig,
Lilly Richtung Runde um den Welt bald ist es soweit möglich ins drehen oder rechts steht und da ist der Aufbau von Internet ist,
fern Verkehrsleitung sind teuer und von Asien gibt es hauptsächlich Leitung in die USA.
Und du möchtest nicht von Singapur über Hongkong über Tokio über Seattle oder Los Angeles und dann quer über die USA und dann übern Atlantik nach Europa.
Dann hast du so nah Stock 380 final Millisekunde leidet will kein Mensch ach so du müsstest du möchtest du richtigrum gerootet werden da gibt's ja nur seid seit kurzem eben auch so lustige Glasfaser stricken die irgendwie.
In der Nordsee und wo anfangen wird jetzt kann ich sie nicht wie endlich anfängt geht denn durch die Straße von Gibraltar bis Mittelmeer durch.
Falls ich dann geht dann sozusagen in zwei in zwei Hälften noch nicht sagen aber in zwei Teilen um die arabische Halbinsel rum vereinigt sich denn dort wieder.
Geht dann unten durch um die um den indischen Subkontinent rum.
So ein bisschen durch den Indischen Ozean und schmeiße mal rechts und links mal so so links ab und sie movie4k will glaube ich heiße.
Da gibt's dann halt eben auch ein Ding.
Nach Singapur das heißt du hast den von Europa aus geht's hinüber Frankreich Marseille ins Mittelmeer dann auf Sonne auf den Abzweig von diesem Kabel und daneben auf dem Kabel lang.
In richtige Richtung um den Erdball rum nach Singapur.
Außer trotzdem immer noch die 185 Millisekunden von da nach Berlin best best Routing.
Also nichts Transsibirische Eisenbahn Transsibirische Eisenbahn würde man denken gibt auch Provider geht immer wieder probieren dann wird den arbeitet Kabel immer wieder geklaut.
Wie bei der Deutschen Bahn mit dem Kupfer eben aus dem Grunde würde Team geklaut weil die Leute denken Kupfer.
Kann ich gut gebrauchen schneiden durch die ein Fest ist kein Kupfer aber ist natürlich nicht wieder zusammen oder schmeiß spleißnadel und deswegen haben sie damit Stabilitätsprobleme,
mich der letzte Therme ausgiebig mit Leuten von NTT ist so ein großer japanische Telekommunikationsunternehmen jemals Staatsunternehmen dort unterhalten zu dem Thema die Orte,
Problem haben das so gerne mal ordentliche bis von Europa dahin haben wollen nach Asien und habe den Vater mal Landweg ist doch billiger und Kulanz oder sagt er aber den geht dauernd kaputt weil heute mal versuchen das Kabel zu tun,
da ist es asozial besser geschützt im Meer.
Ja also um deine Frage zu kommen ja man kriegt er durch man kann derzeit keine da benutzen aber Otto Normalbürger so haben will also Netflix und Facebook und Co und soweit die haben ihre CD installieren Singapur zustehen.
Kann man Spaß mit haben cool ich will auch ein Wirbeltier.
Ja mach doch immer nie seit ich hier jetzt bin,
hatte ich jetzt ein einziges Mal eine Upgrade Option also ich bin jetzt hier seit.
Und 2009.
Also seit fast 8 Jahren und wann ADSL VDSL.
50 Megabit oder anders ausgedrückt ich sage immer Upload ist interessant also ich habe ja ne 10 Megabit.
Verbindungen Internet 10 Megabit Fischfabrik ja und nichts tut sich.
Sogar nichts ist vergangen.
Friseur Vectoring dann kannst du ja mit 40 Megabyte vor dich hin Bratzen vielleicht sogar schon.
Die Telekom hatte etliche stellen Berlin jetzt umgerüstet habe ich gesehen wenn man sich nicht mehr genau die Fritzbox machen guckte welchem Modus die läuft oder sowas auch bei Verwandten von mir im Süden von Berlin.
Und die laufen jetzt mit wegdrücken die wäre natürlich jetzt wieder runter gedrosselt auf den Tarif den sie bezahlen.
Aber du siehst dann dass das Ding im Vectoring Modus ist und theoretisch auch 100 Megabit bringen würde im Downlink und 40 im Uplink oder 38 irgendwas,
aber die natürlich auf den Tarif von 50 X runter erdrosselt werden und das.
Meinst du das kann man sehen kriegst jetzt noch deine Fritzbox und dann gehst du auf DSL-Informationen und da steht da wenn die im Vectoring Modus ist.
Kann also auch passieren ja aber das ist dann trotzdem so ein bisschen na ja wenn man sagen fast Ende der Fahnenstange.
Kann man noch mit supervectoring spielen aber sind eher so Sachen,
ich fand es halt einfach schön die Kinder sehr lockere Tom Neuwirth halt jetzt eben einfach nee zeig mir mal dass ihr den erst schwimmen da oben wo die SS steht nicht im Grünen,
guck mal Vektor Vektor full du bist schon im wegdrücken Modus und du weißt doch nicht mal guck mal da Empfangsrichtung Senderichtung.
Ich habe dir Vectoring und ich kriegs nicht angeboten musste ich meinen guck mal Leitungskapazität A45 Uplink 45m mit Uplink.
Ich verkaufe dir denn nicht aber die 40 verkaufen sie der die 140 kannst dir kriegen dein Ding läuft schon im Bett drin du bist derzeit nur softwaremäßig gedrosselt auf 50 10,
genau wie ich es gesagt habe aber auch echt neu ich hatte die schon mal nachgeschaut und kannst du mal gucken wie lange der schon ab ist so in diesem Modus,
bitte eine Abteilung ist für ein Ding.
Eine Abteilung wo steht jetzt seit 8 Tagen 21 Stunden.
Also wenn du da nicht geblutet hast wegen Stromausfall sonst und was kann er durchaus sein dass du das gerade voll die Abwehranlagen 21 Stunden also mir drei Stunden 881.
Kann durchaus sein ich glaube ich krieg mal gleich perfekt,
Sparkasse Altensteig öffnungszeiten,
einfach jetzt rausgefunden an das mit ihrer Kunden auch an dem Port identifizieren kann indem sie hängen soll bestimmt Sachen bestellen.
Umbestellen neue Sanford Nutzer und ich mich nicht mehr authentisch nee nee nee nee zum einloggen für die Fritzbox so.
Ja also kannst jetzt hier mal dein appling vervierfachen das ist doch schon mal was du Verwaltung noch nicht ob ich das kann weiß ja nicht ob es der richtige lassen er gleich werden könnte ich das aber,
nur weil es jetzt immer das technisch möglich ist heißt du selber legen lassen dass der Kunde auch bekommt was er kriegen könnte.
Also ich bin jetzt noch nicht ich bin jetzt ja noch nicht in so Modus wo ich dir also ich gehe jetzt davon aus.
Ganz ehrlich dass mir das nicht angeboten wird weil.
Also wünsche wird schon vermarktet also dort bleiben bei meinen Verwandten wo ich das gesehen habe da da konnte man sieht auch blicken die haben halt bloß und da haben die Provider durchaus mal recht die haben alle mit den Schultern gezuckt im gesagt ja.
Oh ja das Recht medipro weitersagen gebrauchte Regina und das ist in der Tat so Otto Normalbürger draußen außerhalb unserer filterblase saftig.
Facebook geht's ja der Film ist noch nicht die Angebot im Handy ist erst gibt wenn diese Nachfrage möglich ist bei uns.
Warum haben die alle Leute irgendwie noch nicht genug Festplatten verloren Backups gemacht.
Oder was meinst du doch trotzdem ist immer noch also metrische scheiße aber immerhin du kannst nicht immer noch also zumindest mal 40 Wer ich meine ja das wäre schon mal ein Schritt nach vorne.
Ach Grad Zimmer was kluges ich muss hier gerade mal,
er soll ich dazu noch zu sagen jetzt mal mit dem Glas kann man auch durchaus mal kann ich noch mal zu verlieren warum ich z.b. gerne Glas haben möchte,
the water was also das Denim Hotel die Hand ist otelo renoviert wurde da stattfand und so etagenweise und alles was neu gemacht haben haben sie gnadenlos mit Glas Klick geteilter gibt also Glas zum Gästezimmer.
Im Hotel,
einfach sagen wir fangen jetzt garnicht mal mit dem anderen scheiß und zwar aus einem bestimmten Grund der wird immer gerne oder wird nur selten erwähnt ich habe neulich mal gesehen in einem Artikel in seinem heiße Artikel hat mal jemand diesen Grund kurz angestoßen.
Ich möchte gerne Glas haben dich wenn ich jetzt dringend meine dass jeder unbedingt 10GB zu Hause brauche oder nutzen sollte oder sonst was weil du sagtest schon richtig da gibt's jetzt noch garnicht soviel Angebote für,
ich finde Glas wichtig weil die die technisch bessere.
Infrastruktur ist die wir brauchen für unsere Kommunikationsgesellschaft es wird immer mehr gemachte Telefonnetze traditionell wird abgebaut und hin und her alle Notrufe und also was läuft da drüber wir fangen an darüber vielleicht an Telemedizin zu machen oder,
keine,
wann kannst du auf demselben Glas wo du ein G drauf machen kannst kannst du auch 10 und 100 g und mehrfach 100g machen kannst du auch ein Terabyte draufspielen.
Und im Krieg gerade ein Herzinfarkt weil es wird ihm gerade l Angebote,
ich habe jetzt vom von der Telekom im Brief bekommen dass irgendeine Technik umgestellt werdet ist die sind auf die neuen Erzengel haben weniger wegbringen,
hat nur eine Seite drauf verbraten wohl nichts drin steht außer dass ich einen Tag nicht telefonieren kann mich nur so ist diese dies kann ich ein Bild von Sims Foto von Sims Gesicht machen,
was ist das schlimmes neues Rennauto die bieten lAOLA1 an.
Nein diesen Standort Hinweis auch nicht das ist gerade das Ergebnis für ja dann hier noch mal 500 Megabit.
Warte mal was bieten die anderen so auf jeden Fall erstmal die 140 schon mal kicken der oberste,
er sagt er unten möchte gerne drum rufst du morgen einfach mal den Arno an der macht das klar und was kommt dann Spaß zu.
Ja ja welcher Seite guckst wenn du dann da gerade Maja 45 tagmonat.
Hallo Schatz ich Euro für ein ordentliches netzold geht ja garnicht außerordentliches weiß ich nicht hier steht ja nur Adapter 40mm jemanden Link wo man da hin klicken haben aber was ist jetzt was ist denn diese,
Speed XXL,
ich bitte jetzt gerne den schlauen Gedanken noch zu Ende während du ja ein Herzinfarkt einen längeren Penis,
man muss halt sehen die Wahrheit Minute dich mal Nutella.
Wecke mir Test.
Diese glasgeschichte hat noch einen anderen Vorteil außer dass man darüber schnell Daten übertragen kann sie ist ziemlich unempfindlich sie ist unempfindlich gegen Blitze.
PSD kannst du auch schön in LoL in route Überschwemmungsgebiete tun das im City überhaupt gar nicht und man muss nicht überall im Feld aktive lektronix verstreuen.
Hättest ja mit dem Kupfer Zeug so aufgrund der kurzen Reichweiten muss der überall deine Kiste hinstellen.
Bitte mit Strom versorgen muss teuer die du kühlen musst wurde hängerkleid komplett Elektronik drin und so weiter und so fort net verdient der Telekom hier mit ihren Kisten auf der Straße am 8,
mit hast du mit Glas nicht mit Glas hast du mit handelsüblichen Bauteilen hast du Reichweiten zu von 10/40 90 km auf sonderglas Strecke.
Bei dem ganzen billig Material WG porn was eben sehr billig gespielt und auch 20 km deswegen machen die EZB und dem Hotel weil du haben die haben dort einfach keine 20 km vom guestroom selbst in einem riesen Hotel bietet wartet wahlweise 500 Betten.
Spaß ich jetzt dadurch diese Geschichte dass sie aktive techtronic auf den Etagen noch mal haben bist du diese komischen Verteiler Räumchen wo denn zwischendrin die wieder warm werden weil er welche Switches dumm rum und sowas,
und du kannst dann halt eben schön passiv machen Glas kann man ordentlich verlegen heutzutage mit den Schläuchen für die gemacht werden wohl ganz normale Leute ohne Spezialkenntnisse einfach diese Schläuche legen können.
Und deshalb einfach die stabilere Technik für die Kommunikationsgesellschaft in der wir uns befinden oder in die Wand noch weiterhin ein bewegen,
ich habe es neulich gerade steht auf meinem Landsitz bevor ich da abgesprungen war ja noch ein bisschen diese Gewitter Nummer hier in Deutschland oder gerade auch in Brandenburg und wir hatten aufgrund der tollen kupfertechnik die dort ist fast 8 Stunden,
keinerlei Verkehr.
Warum hat ein Bäumchen umgehauen war der Strom weg damit war der DSL weg weil der Kästchen in dem Dorf oder nicht mehr mit Strom versorgt.
Und der LTE Mast auch nicht und deswegen Amerikaner keinen Strom hat dann lass das ist schief da ja schon aber kannst du sagen ok immer Knoten der Strom braucht,
ja aber der ist in dieser Stelle wendet mit blas machst ist der vielleicht 25 km weg und da sammelst du soviel ein dass sie auch nur eine scheiß Batterie unten einzubauen,
mitmacht aber die Telekom nicht für den Einzelnen Kasten wo 20 people dranhängen.
Dass oder Vermittlungsstelle in Gänsefüßchen hast du mal ein paar tausend von den Dinge zusammenkommen dann brauchst du auch noch und Licht Batterie und nein.
Also hat noch 8 Stunden keinerlei Notruf capability und das fand ich eigentlich auch für ein für ein Industriestandort wie Deutschland selbst auf dem Land doch recht beschämen und solche sagen kann man halt eben alles besser bauen mit Glas Tim wann hast du denn jetzt entdeckt.
Du kriegst jetzt richterlichen von den wecker wird ja nie mehr mit mir ernsthaft ein Giga Download und ein halbes Kilo Upload an.
Für 120 Tagen Blick drauf bestellen.
Schlaf drüber ich will nicht drüber schlafen,
Hercules Moped aber der IP-Adresse mit Mama auf dem.
Das ist jetzt hier aber auch wirklich Hardcore das sieht so aus als ob sie als ob jetzt hat sich mein Haus mit Glas angeschlossen so wäre also nicht nur mit Vectoring.
Ja hier ist auch ja ja hier ist auch Pfeiffer und er sollte so wie neu gemacht weil Nachbarhaus auch so und so für neue.
Das jemand umgestellt haben.
Naja für Haus alleine bauen die jetzt nicht im Stadtteil um also wenn du sicherlich schon eine langfristige Planung gehabt haben dann die war ich bloß bis Handy Eingeweihten.
Muss ich eine Klassenfahrt hier seit Jahren die Podcast voll von oben nach unten.
Interessant also was heißt das ja eigentlich alles also erstmal weg bringt ja sozusagen die Mutter ist einfach nur das.
Das Kupferkabel wenn er jetzt aufwecken anklickst muss dann deine Fritzbox nicht heute machen dann läuft sie einfach morgen mit Hunde aber ehrlich jetzt fiber habe kriegt er direkt richtig ist Glasfaser eine Wand.
Und was weiß nicht es wird in verschiedenen gegen verschiedenartig feilgeboten eventuell.
Da gibt's doch was von auf dem 54.90 aber ich kann dir auch kann dir auch da net Router oder sowas mit dem SFT dafür zur Verfügung stellen ich habe jetzt diese diese diese diese,
Bandbreite noch nie das nicht nur die Downloadrate sein ist dann die Bandbreite der Tarife so noch nie in dieser Fülle gesehen ne weil du jetzt hier sozusagen alles aufzählen,
einschließlich irgendwie diesen 12 Batterie schnell ist nämlich diese 100 da geht mit 100 MB 40 sodass weiter so ich dachte Vectoring das wahrscheinlich Vectoring das heißt aber VDSL fiber.
Weil du wissen ja Kupfer ist Glasfaser genau und das Wasser Kupfer und Krieg ist Frieden und widerstand ist zwecklos so dann gibt es Telekom gibt's da noch eine 5 € Option Speed XL,
ja die das dann auf 200 MB Download und.
Wird und 100 Megabit Upload das auf einmal wieder aus 40 wird 150 5 € mehr muss er fragt warum ist das nicht leiser egal,
dachte schon so was ich kriege 100 Megabit Upload nächste Zeile ja dann noch mal 25 € monatlich und dann gibt es Beat XXL fiber 500!
Dann bin ich aber 200 Megabit Upload 80 sozialer Tag.
Und dann stand hier irgendwas von GIGA wenn man die Hardware klickt Dennis kriegt nur es.
Also muss ich noch mal checken ob das so an oder was ist diese Website.
Was mitunter formil gleichzeitig oder schnell hintereinander reinpressen kann pro Sekunde.
Eine brauchst du von mir noch eine gute Empfehlung für ein bisschen ordentliche 3 funkzeug Seestraße oder das in deiner Wohnung auch die Bits brennende Zahl alles,
ja weil das Internet ich wollte das immer habe es ist zu teuer so aber es gibt zumindest schonmal ne und dann muss das jetzt auch hier rein.
Heulen weil ich werde das bestimmt gut gebrauchen können.
September noch sehen wann dann wenn du 500 hast.
Bitte bitte sag appling.
Ich dieses Upload und Download ist schön dass du Leon das magische ja sorry hast ja recht kannst du machen wenn ich nicht hier bin aber sonst ablegt.
Dann kannst du auch das erste Mal richtig messen was da draußen als ich schnelles,
ja sie war sowieso ein Backup nicht lange die Schnecke durchläuft weiß ja nicht woran es liegt jetzt mit diesen Dingern das Leben da draußen und wir können jetzt z.b. sagen unsere Freunde mit dem Apfel die haben CDN warte bedienen kann.
Nehme ich,
wir haben alles am Start was nicht zuhört aber du kannst du mir eine Message schicken und dann.
Wir sind im Garten gegangen.
Das mit dem Klee man sich aufteilen kann weil Klimas ist ja auch geschrieben ZFS root on Linux dann fange ich mal an weil du kannst ja kurz mal Pause machen kannst mal durchatmen,
Unfallrettung jemand Fenster aufmachen auf,
auf was habe ich doch gerade von dass du gemacht aber Kassel aufmachen und habe ich letztens geguckt weil das war ja auch diese ZFS Developer Conference in leider noch mal bisschen ausruhen für.
Was aus wenn der noch mal wieder neue Hörer die uns noch nie gehört haben und dann auch mal guck mal vielleicht nicht was ZFS ist.
Birnbaumring WhatsApp ZFS.
Ja ich glaube das einfache Form,
und auf FreeBSD ist das Meer bin ja Standard heutzutage,
auch bis eigentlich von San entwickelt wurden aber von Orakel gekauft und dann wurde es kurz vorher das war ja Open Source haben sich das Leute abgesplitterte bevor könnte man sagen und das heißt jetzt Open ZFS,
da gab es auch letztens eine Konferenz ich glaube weiß jetzt nicht mehr wo Kanada ist auch egal.
2 Tage ist auch ganz klein sind so viele Leute und da gab es da so ein paar schöne Vorträge darüber was in der Zukunft so voran damit man so bisschen Bescheid weiß die diesen gleiche Konferenz ich hab doch letztes Jahr schon.
Und da war ein Developer der hat da berichtet dass er an encryption für ZFS arbeitet und.
Ja ich muss jetzt erst noch mal was erzählen was gesagt hast hast du das übliche copy-on-write du kannst so,
dann dann teile sie mit eigentlich ein riesen Pool über mehrere Platten mit verschiedenen reden,
dann ziehen dann oder so keine Ahnung also dann Redundanzen also dann ziehen deswegen früher halt.
Mirror und und stripe und die haben was was rated heißt was in RAID5 ist dann haben sie gradesaver sowie RAID6 dann haben sie sogar was betrayed keine Ahnung 7 gibt's ne.
Ja tolle Teilsystem viel Scheiße riesengroß sein kann hört auf deine Daten gut aufpasst,
damit hast auch damit,
auch damit mit der Idee mal klar kommt das meine Festplatte Daten nicht wieder so abliefert wie man sie mal drauf geschrieben hat und so also drauf verlassen kann nur Datensicherheit,
an die falschen Hände verloren gehen dass sie keiner kriegt er sie nicht kriegen soll.
Gibt's hübschen für ZFS und dann kann man da einfach einen Pool den man auch schon hat wenn man jetzt auf die neueste Version geupdatet hat,
sag ihr ich hätte neues sub file system aber diesmal mit Krypto der Kiesow irgendwie vom prompt Thomas Mann gibt es von hantelmann kann den Kiefer auch als teilnehmen oder noch irgendwie von woanders und ja das hat immer ewig gedauert ich habe mich nicht so gekümmert und habe ich vor einer Weile mal geguckt was denn das neueste openzfs on OS X irgendwie ist,
und habe gesehen dass das auch schon irgendwie Ende August oder so rauskam und,
siehe da diese Version hat dieses ein Köpfchen schon mit dabei weil auf FreeBSD gibt es noch nicht und die bei Premiere sind immer sehr weit vorne und,
ich glaube die bei uns also das hätte was anderes denn sind die ersten die das mit encryption haben.
Und habe das ausprobiert und das hat gleich sofort super funktioniert die Anleitung ist ein bisschen,
die versteckt in den Manpages weil die manpage muss so viel tausend Sachen Abbild dass man das gar nicht so schnell findet aber wenn man dann erstmal hat dann dann geht's relativ einfach und dann hat man Karton also.
Wieder der Hammerschmid Kupplung file system fummeln will ein bisschen anders als das was Apple macht mit ihrem apfs,
mit dem Fall wollte der sollte sich das mal angucken und ich nehme Wagen ist dadurch jetzt kann man noch nicht beweisen weil die anderen haben ja noch nicht aber es müsste kompatibel sein wenn man so eine Kupferplatte auch zwischen OS X und FreeBSD und später dann auch Linux hin und her wechselt müsste das eigentlich gehen.
Zum Thema später an Linux das gibt's auch schon eine Weile auf Linux war aber mal so ein politisches gehagelt.
Weil die Lizenz ist so alles irgendeine von diesem trifft sich Open Source Lizenzen nichtsdestotrotz haben welche oberschlaue neuer entschieden mal dass diese CDDL glaube ich ist,
unter der die Sitze ZFS rumfliegt Office openzfs oder sowas nicht kompatibel ist mit der GPL und der der Linux verbreitet wird deswegen wartet bisher mal so dass ich die Linux-Distribution früher gesagt haben nee das kann man nicht mit ausliefern Walde,
dürfen wir nicht,
passt nicht zusammen auf Norderney,
Gitarre installieren,
irgendwann hat aber jetzt schon mal vor inzwischen fast zwei Jahren Ubuntu mal gesagt auch fucket verklagt uns doch wir liefern nicht einfach mal mit Auto.
Also seit 16.04 ist der Ubuntu ist es standardmäßig mit dabei deswegen will ich jetzt auch noch mal weil viele Leute das gar nicht wissen immer denkt nach ZFS muss ich nachher zulässt gefummelt uns online ist mit dabei.
Und ich kann man also einfach benutzen auch die ganzen Tools sind dabei auch die selbst alle Mechanismen die man braucht um ein ZFS root zu machen also auch da rein zu booten,
nicht mehr essen extra ext4 file system zu haben womit man jetzt erstmal um die bootet um den welche Datenpartition zu haben sondern man kann komplettes rote System auf einem,
auf einem ZFS laufen und booten lassen ohne große kopfständer der einzelnen Teile sind wird einem nicht bei der Installation von Ubuntu angeboten,
Dacia Sandero reinschmeißen,
mal sehen ob sich damit jetzt nächstes Jahr wehtut also im April wenn die nächste LTS Version rauskommt aber ich habe mit mal so ein bisschen aus geknusper.
Es geht sogar in einer Cloud der Tipp lautet.
Wenn er schafft installiert eure bunte auf das Ende der Platte der virtuellen Platte oder wie auch immer.
Dass ich kleine kleine 4G 8GB Partition wohnt wo rein Husten von dem Installationsmedium dann hat man den vorderen Teil der Platte frei dort generiert man sich einen ZFS und dann kann man auch noch,
keine Ahnung vielleicht mal seiner mal Link wenn ich den wiederfinde rein wie man den Budvar macht kopiert seine alte Betriebssystem sozialen nach vorne in ZFS bootet dann.
Mit ZFS root also mit dem gesamten System in ZFS hatte natürlich hinten auf diese alte Partition rum zu lungern die kann man aber platt machen unter Entfall System kann man immer gut nach hinten verlängern das geht auch mit ZFS,
das heißt Satan wird an den vorderen Teil den schiebst du noch mal denn oder erweiterst du bis zum Ende der Platte und dann hast du ein Komplettsystem warte auf läuft.
Mache ich jetzt schon seit einiger Zeit mit Forums habe ich früher auch schon gemacht von Hand wie gesagt immer gefummelt aber jetzt somit aktuell 16043 RTS.
Sagt alles an Bord kann man machen kann ich auch empfehlen wo ganz gut und hat natürlich die ganze ZFS Vorteile und Replikation und blablub und ja.
Und jetzt schon lange darüber diskutieren ob man alt mit Lucy bauen, wer hat gesagt Spaß dann hat man muss nicht extra mit keine fummeln sondern bunt du aktuelle LTS Version kann das auch.
Allerdings habe die Version diese damit drin haben die hat noch kein ja kein Problem ist aber auch relativ schnell kommen was soll das,
und wo ist denn das eigentlich immer eine Kopie von dem ZFS on Linux die Amazone,
ja dann musst halt wieder nach Zina muss jetzt mal gucken ob es da für mich,
DPSG sonst in Bad Buchau offen aktuell.
Haben wir diesmal gerade verpasst irgendwie oder die Tasten ein bisschen länger als der lumpenmann heißt da.
Sehr schön um wenn man es möchte ganze System hat ich habe heute einmal eine VM gebaut bitte so prototypisch was ist denn schon eingerichtet.
Da ist mein Account drauf und die ganzen überdies die man so haben will und Wissmann ist ein bisschen kuschelig gemacht und wenn ich jetzt sozusagen der neue der neue Bauer den,
der Clown ich die vom Prinzip dadurch indem ich halt einfach sonst hätte fest Feature benutze nämlich ZFS send that hast einfach auf der neuen Maschine gutes vom zieht noch von diesem Installationsmedium,
Bridge Setup riecht es von Hand den Pool ein und machst dann mit ZFS send übers Netz von von meiner Brust Typ Maschine kopiere ich das einfach rein,
also brauchte deswegen weil die Leute einen Clown myself auf der Messe aber ich hab halt meine Fans verstreut auf der Welt die sind halt nicht alle auf derselben Hardware und ich beim selben Provider.
Aber doch mit der Schnellleiste mit Eiskaffee irgendwie dran denken.
Ich kann auch einfach ZFS send über eine SSH machen und drüben rein Kübeln und Sonne oder so irgendwo anders auf der Welt oder muss den Rest alles holen.
Musste mal das alles wohin mit der Bitte der in Ruhe Ubuntu-Installation hat ja keine Ahnung zweieinhalb Gera sonst immer nur Frühstück.
Wir reden ja hier nicht über DSL-Anschlüsse zu Hause sondern weil inhalt irgendwie im Inter Dings, die jeder.
Ja soviel dazu erstmal kurz und knapp.
Weißt noch einmal was iPhone reden.
Naja da sitzt die Öhrchen Fraktion.
Ich habe zwei und du ich habe auch zwei ich habe nur eins ich habe natürlich auch nur eins hätte ich aber fast gehabt,
kann ja nie wissen eine eins kaputt geht dann will ein iPhone twenty wie es so schön heißt also blöde Frage gibt's eine blöde Antwort ja du Blödmann,
unsere Antwort auch nicht.
Ja aber da ist immer das Gespräch,
weil mein altes im Arsch war das ist ja irgendwann anstellen mit seinen Unfall kaputt gegangen.
Ja deswegen wollte neues haben das dachte mir wenn schon denn schon 18 hätte man ja auch nehmen kann weil ich hatte sie mal vorher.
Aber irgendwie dachte ich muss auch dass du erst mich hat der große Bildschirm gelockt muss ich ehrlich sagen also scheiß auf face ID aber dieser Riesenbildschirm.
Das dachte ich ja das ist genau das was ich haben will viel Platz in der Höhe und den Wecker gestellt bin morgens aufgestanden geklickt.
Navabi natürlich nicht so weiter wie das morgen so ist musste ich halt auf die Toilette das ist scheiße Ende sitze jetzt hier so voll lange bis die da so an starke und mache mir fast in die Hose oder ich gehe jetzt schnell.
Und, und wahrscheinlich warte ich immer noch und dann ist alles entspannt wenigstens sehr komisch wieder dann ging es natürlich also erste Minute verpasst kostet eine Woche von der bestellten weil du rutscht er dann nach hinten in genau so und dann irgendwie Klick wollte mit.
Mit einer Kreditkarte bezahlen ich selber kann also von dem bekannten geht nicht weil man kann nur welche nehmen die auf den eigenen Namen sind man kann keine fremde die Karten benutzen blöd bitte bei manchen guten da kannst du andere Namen nicht mit Bitcoin bezahlen bei Apple.
Lena aber zum Glück.
Also dieses Wetter wird mit der Kreditkarte mich wieder dass ich eine Minute kostet wieder eine Woche nach hinten zum Glück konnte man mit Paypal bezahlen das geht irgendwie schnell weil wenn du mich überweist dann warten Sie bis dann Überweisung da ist und dann würde ich erst ein,
das heißt dann kannst du bis sonst wann warten okay,
also PayPal ging schon mal einigermaßen Arbeit haben sie gesagt so Lieferzeit wäre der 21 was vorgestern gewesen wäre dafür Männer schöne Scheiße und,
dann habe ich aber geguckt dass man ja im Apple Store hier wie gucken kann ob die welche vor Ort haben und sich die reservieren lassen kann oder muss man halt am gleichen Tag abholen.
Oder habe ich das gemacht und hat mir tatsächlich welche am Start und dann gefallen Arbeit abgeholt. Fertig dann hatte ich eins irgendwie.
Ja vor zwei Wochen war das also relativ schnell also wenn da Leute immernoch Variante nicht mehr,
weil ich habe mein Telefon auch nur von dem 64 dies hat nur die Hälfte benutzt so ca so 33 GB und dachte das reicht mir hier auch habe auch schon gedacht ob das eine gute Idee ist aber eigentlich reicht das bis das voll ist eh schon wieder das nächste,
falsche Leute die jetzt immer noch warten weil sie vielleicht ganz ganz spät bestellt haben weil sie vielleicht sich nicht morgens den Wecker gestellt haben einfach.
Relativ früh morgens oder muss es immer am gleichen Tag machen bei Apple klicken sich das Ding reservieren wenn sie sagen sie haben ein Star dann einfach hinfahren abholen und das was man bestellt hat kann man ganz einfach kämpfen und dann kommt das.
Das Geld noch nicht mal zurück weil sie buchen erst wenn sie losschicken das heißt lange nicht losgeschickt das habe ich auch gar nicht abgebucht und dann kann man ganz easy switchen sozusagen.
Soweit bald meine Story dieses Gerät zu bekommen.
Wie heißt das Grading on space grey space grey mit kobaltblauer Silikonhülle weiß.
Mag der dunkle blau ist die Nacht schwarz sind und tagsüber blau.
Es ist mir ernsthaft die erste Frage wie ich das bestellen ich wollte.
Ach scheiße Entschuldigung stimmt da war keine Umhängetasche Rucksack morgens um um 8 Uhr oder um 9 Uhr,
noch nicht mit Rucksack durch die Wohnung könnte man machen aber nicht so weit ist es noch nicht außerdem dachte ich ja das geht ja ganz fix und ich bin wieder da und ich warte wahrscheinlich immer noch wie das immer so ist mit Wartezeiten wo man ewig wartet und wartet,
aber war diesmal Apple dann doch ein bisschen schneller als als ich sonst echt ein,
also der Bildschirm ich dachte bei alle ja von diesen mega Bildschirm geschwärmt haben so nett und dieses perfekte schwarz was ja auch stimmt aber und auch hören von den von den Sattel in Farben die es wohl haben soll es kann ja auch diese HDR und so weiter nur darum was hatte er war das doch oder.
Bin ich hatte darunter nennen sie ist nicht da.
Bild vom Display an den dem Umgebungslicht Umgebung hermacht,
er hat aber auch eine höhere ja ja aber das ist nur so ein bisschen mehr,
gedacht hätte irgendwie sich was mit Knall ich na so das war cool drauf hast deutlich viel besserer als als beim beim als beim iPhone 7,
deutlich viel besserer eine was ist für dich gut ist für dich knall ich gut nee ich habe dich schon sehr ich frag jetzt mal was zu erreichen für auf dem Bildschirm hast du ihr Leute von dem ITF Meeting hat natürlich auch alle Model Model X oikawa.
Lena oder Lena Lena Lena Lena. Das Bild von von den Siebzigern irgendwie 512 x 512 Pixel,
genau das ist aber das lorem ipsum der dass jeder der letzten 30 Jahre alt ist einfach.
Ja mein Prof hatte sein Skript auch voll damit ja ich habe ja noch nicht sämtliche Kodex wurden mit diesem Ding da erklärt und,
gezeigt was die für Nebenwirkungen haben weil die hat heute auch so so Federn am Hut und du kannst Zeit an den Federn am Hut kannst du sehr sehr schön sehen was du da so für Bröckel Artefakte rein kriegst wenn dann Algorithmus nicht stimmt,
aber das ist das Bild doch viel zu schlecht das ist ja wirklich das aus den Siebzigern wiederhergestellt haben,
also ich würde schon inzwischen alleine und nehmen deswegen wie gesagt wirst du mit diesem Bild da auch ne.
Ja wenn man eins von hinten von den Raumfähre,
Apple mitgelieferten Bildern nimmt dann sieht man das schon stärker die Farben weil die natürlich sehr stark darauf als wäre es auch nicht vom Hocker,
gesagt das ist ein gutes Display aber ich habe irgendwie durch,
durch den heute noch nachdem er navigieren nicht übers Wochenende fotografiert.
Bald ein eigenes Foto von dir dass mein eigenes Foto von mir letztes Wochenende in der Biosphäre Potsdam kann ich sehr empfehlen mit mit Kindern da mehr hinzugehen die freuen sich jedesmal weißt du aber das nur am Rande.
Ja sonst fragen was machst du noch erzählen ich weiß nicht also fällt schon mal versucht,
pink zu laden die anderen erst mal alle den den den den Ikea irgendwie.
Also nicht mehr und ich nutze es schon auch ganze Menge das hält ziemlich gut.
Dann nachts Mahlzeit drinne hat meistens immer noch 20% also nach dem zweiten Tag abends unerträglich dran und morgens ist halt wieder voll und da.
Lüders also interessiert.
Amperestunden das Ding also 2007 Milliamperestunden das schon schon ziemlich fährt das ist so eine Ole Glotze braucht weniger Strom,
komm drauf also schon wenn die Pickel schwarz sind dann die sind halt schwarz der Kernenergie das Problem ist aber der Bildschirm ist ja doch schon relativ groß dadurch verbraucht dadurch wieder mehr.
Also also gefühlt hält der Akku von dem länger jetzt als das 6S mit dem externen Akku Gehäuse von Apple zusammen okay,
aber ist doch mal schon extrem runter deswegen hatte ich ja auch dieses externer Akku Gehäuse weil,
der schon vor einem Jahr soweit runter war der Akku dass ich gesagt habe ich komme nicht durch den ganzen Tag auf dem Kongress mit dem Phone und ich habe keinen Bock auf,
Akku mit Kabel leise und so weiter also live bei Veranstaltung auch Madrid battery pack hinten,
der ist der Akku ist sehr gutes vorne setzt jetzt super neu aber das ist jetzt wirklich also ich habe jetzt noch halben Akku.
Also irgendwie hat man ganzen Tag nicht geladen schon okay.
So fazer die muss aber gesagt funktioniert einfach macht nie Ärger Soli.
Zum Thema face ID ein kleiner Tipp für Brillenträger wenn ihr face ID einschaltet oder einrichtet dann muss man das Bild zweimal scannen,
und als Brillenträger sollte man es einmal mit und einmal ohne Brille machen sonst hat man wie ich das Gefühl dass man denkt so abends im Bett das Licht ist so schlecht denn das Telefon unlock,
Michis leck mich am Lech das lag daran dass er mich ohne Brille nicht mehr so richtig erkannt hat.
Ansonsten macht er das aber eigentlich ganz gut.
Ohne Brille hat er das nicht erkannt ohne Absender mit Brille angelernter und dann hat er mich ohne Brille nicht erkannt und dann,
bin ich immer drauf gekommen dass mir versuchst es noch mal und dann ging es ohne Brot Milch habe in der ohne Brille angelernt und wenn ich dann meine bastel Brille auf habe und davon habe ich zwei drei verschiedene je nachdem wie weit ich wenn wir gucken muss und dann waren die Problem also,
ich habe jetzt auch nicht drauf geachtet manchmal will er schon dass man den Code eingibt.
Und 80 habe ich jetzt nicht drauf geachtet ob es daran liegt das jetzt irgendwie deine Zeit abgelaufen ist das manchmal wieder machen muss damit man den Code nicht vergisst oder ob er einen hat mich erkannt hat also wer will schon manchmal den Code haben aber das war ja bei Touch ID auch Sonne ab und zu will er einfach mal.
Ja palm er lernt ja dann immer also wenn du eine Fehlerkennung hast und dann unmittelbar danach deinen Code eingibst dann wird in dem Moment noch mal,
Bild genommen damit wird dann das ja so anpasst ja genauso,
dann lernt er das halt mit und trainiert quasi noch mal das Bild also was was für mich ein großer Umstieg war kein Homebutton mehr zu haben.
Zermatt Zermatt wirklich die gesamte Navigation auf dem Form verändert klare mal kurz unter die doch was gehört von klappt nicht im Liegen doch locker.
Im Bett ja ich liege auch da so dass das Kissen mein Kind ab Denkmals ist ein Kissen versunken also mein Mund sieht nachher noch aber mein Kind ist auf jeder Penner senkrecht aber man so quer liebe das ist auch egal,
nee also damit hatte ich jetzt keine Probleme wie gesagt nachdem ich dann zweimal angelernt habe einmal mit Brille und einmal ohne hat's dann auch im Bett wo ich meistens keine Brille an habe wieder an Aurelia nur distilleria,
na du mir jetzt ja auch machen dass ich halt das habe ich habe ich gehört das ist aufgegangen also ja.
Vielleicht muss ich dann ein Bild Vergelter weiter hat jetzt geklappt lasziv lasziv über den Tisch in der Metaebene ausbreiten.
Na noch ein guter Tipp ist manchmal wann schaltet der mit dem Power-Button hier so so ein damit einscannen kann oder toller Vorfeld,
hochhebe und wenn es dann nicht klappt.
Machen meistens noch mal aus und noch mal wieder an und damit man es noch mal versuchen kann wenn das Schloss nicht aufgeht aber der Trick ist einfach man schaltet ein und wenn er nicht erkennt macht man kurz senkrecht das Telefon und dann wieder nach vorne dann probiert das normal ja oder so.
Hört sich gerade geht man wieder zurück oder wasche ich auch egal welche Richtung kurz einmal du hast ja sowieso,
na jetzt nicht mehr aber jetzt geht's auch so kann man den zweiten Versuch machen oder dass man noch mal zweimal klicken muss dann noch mal ausrollen Kennzeichen gestehen dass wenn du.
Wann sagt er dass er man hier im Programm drin ist dass man irgendwie von unten muss man so doll hochziehen damit er mir die anderen Programme kommen damit man umschalten kann.
Man kann auch hier unten so streichen das geht auch und es viel viel entspannter man einfach so.
Hätte ich nicht kennt kennst du den auffallend keins aber in die Richtung geht's auf den auf den anderen vor uns konntest du ja so auf den auf den Home Button tippen ohne zu klicken damit er sieht also halte untergeht,
hast du das geht wieso Doppeltsehen,
wie teuer die sind Doppelklick im Regen damit du runterkommen Medien doppelt App doppelt App du kannst du hier unten nach unten ziehst,
bis dann zeig mal vielleicht habe ich nämlich nicht an.
Ich habe das nicht an das ist nicht an kannst du das nicht anhaben na weil wieder irgendein bedienungsteil wie ausgemacht haben muss.
Habe ich mir schon gedacht und dann und dann bin ich irgendwann an den Punkt gekommen und wollte es von ausmachen und es ging ums verrecken nicht aus.
Habe ich das erste Mal seit gefühlt 5 Jahren Siri nach etwas gefragt nämlich,
wie schalte ich das Telefon aus willst du die Einstellung und dann gehst du immer ganz unten dann hat er tatsächlich hat Siri mir erklärt wie ich das Telefon ausschalten indem man irgendwie den Power Button und einen der Job die obere larium laut leise taste zusammen.
Drückt und Getränke nach der Notruf nee wenn du gedrückt hältst dann macht er irgendwann den aus wenn du hältst dann.
Mach deinen Traum Unfall die Tatort ganz schön überbelegt weil wir Screenshot ausmachen Notruf und dann wollt eine App beenden,
und dann lies die sich nicht nach oben weg Philippen und dann immer muss alles mir na ja dann macht es so wie gerade eben schon mal frag sie Siri frage ich,
wie beende ich eine App antwortet Siri.
Du scheinst keine App mit dem Namen wie beende ich eine zu haben wenn du möchtest keine AppStore danach suchen,
frag mal was der beste Podcast der Welt ist.
Also Deutschland was ist der beste dieses hier gefunden nein das will ich jetzt nicht sehen.
Was ist der beste Podcast der Welt in Deutschland.
Doofe Frage doofe Antwort ist alles klar meine Websuche zu der beste.
Der weltbeste Podcast hat folgendes ergeben dann gibt's hier einmal die 7 besten hier ne selbst suchen wollte ich jetzt nicht wollte die künstliche Intelligenz Frage ist keiner gut.
Was ist der beste Podcast der Welt.
Das ist immer derselbe Dreck das ist weg dieses scheiß Siri für die ganze Spracherkennung ich sag euch das wird nichts mehr habe ich soll mein reden das wird einfach nichts werden.
Durch dich auch so ja ansonsten na ja hier ein emoji das haben wir ja schon saufen Arsch schon durch.
Das Thema mehr oder weniger in der Sendungs Vorbereitung auf Twitter,
findest du denn dass das Telefon sich jetzt mit der Gesten Geschichte ja sehr viel mehr IMAP verlangt einfacher zu bedienen ist.
Oder hast du das Gefühl du musst jetzt mehr Aufwand treiben um dasselbe zu tun.
So ein Mix aus beidem also bestimmte Sachen ist die Geste Easy ja manchmal ist wie mit der mit der Tastatur hier vom neuen MacBook Pro du kannst,
dein Finger nicht so und dieser Rille parken damit du deine Cursortasten schneller wirst und sowas auf dem wohl auch du kannst halt dein Finger nicht schon auf dem Homebutton parken sondern,
Home Button klicken ist halt nur dein Finger ist schon da du machst du so,
ganz kleinen Druck ist ja noch nicht mal Klick weiter dann haben sie auch automatisiert mit dem Drucksensor dann also musst nur bisschen Druck auf deinen Finger geben jetzt musst halt immer so eine Bewegung machen ist natürlich schon auch zeitlich natürlichen ganz ganz andere Aktion als und kleiner Klick da unten aber so im Großen und Ganzen geht's eigentlich also man gewöhnt sich schon recht schnell,
daran es ist es nicht wirklich problematisch es sei denn du hast halt ab und zu dann mal wieder ein iPad,
Futternapf mit dem Finger von unten hoch zu zweit damit es Teil anlocken,
du dir dann denkst ein falsches Gerät also das ist ein bisschen bisschen dämlich wie wenn du irgendwie ab und zu mal an Windows sitzt und verzweifel zur alle Tasten anderes anderes machen aber ansonsten ist es irgendwie.
Achso und das einzige das einzige was ich wirklich schlimm finde ist zum ist für mich als Linkshänder worauf ich immer bestehe ist dieses control Dings oben,
genau das ist rechts oben das ist halt einfach für meinen linken Daumen nicht mehr erreichbar.
Das finde ich auch eine Verschlechterung vor allem nervt mich ja eine Sache oder iOS 9 wirklich maßlos 99,
eleven eleven eleven eleven.
Ja dieses neue ControlCenter finde ich ist okay das jetzt an sich okay aber mir.
Wenn ich jetzt meine Kopfhörer wechseln möchte ja tut es häufig,
Schalter gehst du in einen aus und steckt in andere nein nein ich überhaupt keine Kopfhörer mehr irgendwo reiten deshalb irgendwie komplett auf Bluetooth umgestellt und ich scheiß vor allem mit meinen Kopfhörern zwischen verschiedenen Rechnern hin und her ich habe mein Airport.
Bin ich irgendwie auf meinem Laptop wechseln wir auf meinem Mac Pro auf den anderen ich bin ein Fan des 3,5 mm,
ja das kann ja sein aber du hast ja keine 3,5 Millimeter Klinke an einem komischen neuen Adapter.
Ich will Bluetooth machen so und geht nicht das heißt ich muss umschalten am Gerät.
Musst ihm sagen wechsle jetzt bitte den Kopfhörer was muss ich tun ich muss erstmal also jetzt alte nicht iPhone XP also Control Center aufrufen ne was bei Mix halt noch mal.
Schlimmer ist als jetzt bei den,
bisherigen Geräten weil kommt halt nicht von unten unten ist jetzt neu belegt also kommt das jetzt von oben es wäre also sehr weit weg und bei den x-Wert hat,
richtig weit weg ist ja noch mal noch mal viel Nummer weiter als das schon mir alles enttäuscht Zentrum ist nicht mehr benutzbar sind es da so und das Audio Widget was vorher beachten.
Nur eine von drei Optionen war die aber persistent war das heißt wenn ich das die ganze Zeit benutzt habe dann ist es auch Kontrollcenter hoch ist das da sofort und ich sehe sofort hier ist die App,
der Control Center kann ich jetzt auch machen dann ist das so ein so rechts oben so ein so ein halbes Widget deshalb nimmt nicht mehr den ganzen Bildschirm ein.
Dann sind da so zwei kleine Mini tiny vor und zurück Buttons wo ich die ganze Zeit immer daneben tippe weil einfach das Touch target nicht richtig ist.
Was noch schlimmer ist wenn du dann das noch vergrößern und Fokus bringen willst und erstmal die Auswahl zu haben dann musst du da länger drauf drücken.
Ja da Forst hat aber das hast du ja nicht angemessene.
Ja trotzdem Post das ist ja genauso bekloppt also länger drücken Vorteils ist ja genau derselbe quatsch ich muss noch mal mehr Zeit oder Energie darauf verwenden so aber dann muss ich halt da länger drauf drücken und dann hast du da das.
Und dann musst du noch mal drücken Dings einstellen muss ich noch mal drücken um irgendwie die Auswahl zu haben versus vorher hoch Auswahl von dem Audio direkt.
Fertig aber jetzt ist das irgendwie jedesmal Sonnenweg irgendwie querlist Messegelände,
und ich weiß überhaupt nicht was das soll und dann funktioniert schon mal drauf und dann funktioniert auch nicht richtig also in mehreren Fällen habe ich einfach Probleme ja gehe ich halt jetzt mal oben schon später tags darauf irgendwie Jani hat wohl doch nicht so geklappt,
also das ist wirklich relativ,
im mies und und und und und und treibt ehrlich gesagt so die Kopfhörer expert sie gerade so schön war geworden ist mit den Airport wieder komplett Adapter oder.
Schlimm,
kannst du das aber nicht übel also gut dann müsstest du wahrscheinlich die Musik gerade laufen haben weil wenn du die Musik laufen hast und dann aktiviert hast du ja die Auswahl drin wo du es gerade rüber hörst oder,
ja also sind das sehe ich wo die Auswahl auf dem Lockscreen.
Wenn du Musik laufen hast und habe keine Kopfhörer und das anzustecken aber wenn du das Laufen hast die Musik hast du im Lockscreen steht bei mir immer drin headphones.
Ja du hast dann ist der Weg kürzer wenn der schon was du willst ja eigentlich nirgendwo etwas.
Du wirst auf deine Kopfhörer umschalten ist das natürlich echt ein bisschen suboptimal aber über den Lockscreen würdest du immerhin.
Ja dann wäre dann muss aber schon was laufen muss das ja also wenn ich jetzt nur rüber weil ich da gleich was starten will dann dann ist dann halt nicht da und wenn wenn das Audio halt läuft dann habe ich halt meine Kopfhörer im Prinzip auch schon,
am schade dass manchmal hilft das trotzalledem ist auch da die Auswahl halt wirklich noch mal über diesen extra button.
Habt ihr habt auch schon auf euren Telefon iOS eleven drauf ja ja ja.
Wenn man es ganz leicht hoch schiebt dann sieht sie das so aus wie früher dass das messages oben in der Mitte steht ja das gibt's ein paar Szenen.
Dann ändert sich auch von dem einen in den anderen um also irgendwie finde ich das nicht so schön und das ist ja so ein Standard erbelding oder weil du mir ja in den in den auch so,
das Setting steht immer ist aber ein bisschen hoch hier besteht Setting deiner Mitte so wie es früher war also um wie ist es jetzt so,
schalte jetzt so zwischen zwei user interfaces optisch ein bisschen hin und her ich bin ganz ehrlich das okay weil weil weil diese ganzen Screens und die sind ja auch gerade diese ganzen settings Sachen und so weiter sind.
Dreamfall überladen überlegt was du so vor fünf Jahren auf dem iPhone einstellen konntest du was für heute dafür Option hatte ich ja schon ab,
und jetzt.
Du hast ja auch nur ein bisschen kleiner da wo er früher hat auch mal oben in der Mitte ein großer Titel kommuniziert halt auch.
Der Titel alles was groß und fett und faul Telsnig ich find's okay also ich lade Euch ein Problem damit oder kaufst du dir so ein riesen iPhone Explorer den Titel du wieder den gleichen Platz hast den ja überall größer sind.
Also halt Leute die kein Iphone Examen die sind jetzt noch mehr angekackt als als vorher.
Geräte haben die aber im unterschiedliche Nutzer unterschiedliche Benutzerführung oder nutzerinteraktion haben was halt voll inkonsistent ist.
Und.
Ich muss nicht vorstellen können dass sie das auf lange Sicht so fahren wollen weil ich meine da sollten große Frustration wenn du ein iPhone X hast und über Jahre.
Weil entweder verfolgen sie das Ziel das alles irgendwann nur noch ohne Button funktioniert gut wer weiß wie das nächste iPad aussieht vielleicht das hat doch noch schnell die ne also.
Aber bei euch ist das Kontrollcenter aber noch von unten nach oben schieben ja okay.
Irgendwas dass ich nicht ernst nehmen kann also schmerzvoll auch besser gefallen vorher was,
Apollo geht's euch was kann ich machen Sie es jetzt noch mal weg geändert haben wirklich nur das Audio Widget wirklich schlechter geworden,
also von dem.
Tut mir leid dass ich einen kleinen richtig zugreifen das war.
Ja das stimmt.
Das ist schon alles ein bisschen größer ist das ist schon ganz sinnvoll und dass man ihm auch noch so seine wichtigsten direkt Button rein konfigurieren kann das ist alles ganz sinnvoll ich finde alles Schlechte mehr konfigurieren konfigurieren,
die unteren untere Leiste kannst du quasi konfigurieren,
da kannst du alles so reinballern was du möchtest was mich alles alles was halt angeboten wird und was ich unterschätzt hatte war dann tatsächlich die Größe vom iPhone,
X
also es ist ja eigentlich nicht viel größer als das nicht bloß so vom reinen Gerät aber da der Bildschirm halt jetzt einmal komplett übers ganze vorn geht hast du heute dann doch den zu kurzen Daumen.
Was ist hatte ich das hatte ich unterscheide also vorher beim normalen iPhone auch schon nicht mehr gereicht oder hat der Daumen noch nicht mal MSI mit dem Bildschirm und den Öhrchen das wäre genau die richtige Größe,
was wollen wir was erreichen so geil sein soll finde ich geil aber die sind da halt ja egal.
Stören überhaupt nicht also man guckt die innerhalb kürzester Zeit weg wollen süße sind ganz viele Termine da sind da sind halt der sind halt diese Zeilen Teile von der Statusbar drin und in der Mitte,
ist ja sonst nix in der Statusbar die Uhrzeit aber.
Das war's denn es ist sowieso total platzt also mein snapchat doch gar nicht auf weil den Space noch nicht nutzen das sozusagen noch der.
Bekommt man ehrlich und modesinn aber nicht ausblenden.
Du hast heute keine volle Statusbar sondern nur rechts und links über den Rasen schwarze Linie die alles schwarz ist.
Hatte die App die du mir zeigst dann einen schwarzen Hintergrund na dann nehmen wir eben eine elk was ist eine App die weiß ist nicht da.
Meinst du dieses Ding nicht bequatschen das ist da ja natürlich ist da bestimmt nicht na ja.
Und was ganz lustiges wenn du die App weg ziehst.
Dann wird ja ganz ne also der Teil der hinter dem hinter der Nord ist der wird ja irgendwie trotzdem gerendert.
Irgendwelche Apps haben wir ja auch schon Easter Eggs versteckt.
Ein bisschen albern finde aber bitte ansonsten muss man vielleicht noch den Standard Tipp geben wenn ihr noch viele wissen aber manche vielleicht nicht dass durch das owlet hat Apple jetzt einen schwarzen Bildschirm Hintergrund beigepackt wenn man den nutzt.
Spart man wirklich ziemlich viel Batterie weil die Pixel dann dort nicht an sind und das deutlich weniger Stromverbrauch ist da noch diesen anderen Tipp damit gehört hab auch kein schwarz Hintergrund so hässlich muss mein Telefon jetzt nicht werden,
wollen wir mal das ganz schick dass du so schön ein schöner greyscale dem Foto was die Damen im Springboard geht das vielleicht aber dann hast du,
dann habe ich meinen Streamer im schwarz-weiß Modus und wenn ich dann diesen schwarz Modus von Apple Benutzer dann müsste ich eigentlich mein Zimmer erst wieder auf weiß stellen damit der bitte dann doch wieder auf schwarz man kann also muss das schon alles dann irgendwie so ein bisschen dadrauf anpassen das ist mir irgendwie nix und auch schwarze Seiten surfen das ist mir auch wie auch nichts,
lasse das Teil jetzt schon mal längeren Tag nicht geladen das hält 2 Tage.
Es in 48 Stunden 48 Stunden und wenn es genutzt bist du noch da.
Habe ich geguckt von den 48 Stunden Dingsda man das glaube ich 12 Stunden benutzt.
Also schon ziemlich viel würde ich sagen dass ich dabei mein iPhone se mit iOS 11 hält jetzt sowie vielleicht mal so drei oder vier Stunden noch.
Ja ja wirklich durch.
War sofort auf morgen auch unheimlich langsam geworden ist bis es wahrscheinlich liegen aufsetzen dass irgendwas braun ist das halt auch aufgefallen überfordert.
Gespannt wie sich das jetzt entwickeln werden ab da auch der Akku irgendwie in die Knie geht weil so ein bisschen liebäugel ich ja mittlerweile mit so einem.
Stoßgerät mir so ein X Gerät finde ich erst noch größer ja aber kleineren Bildschirm,
aus einer breiten Breite hat so ein bisschen mehr aber vielleicht noch ein bisschen länger,
ach du du warst nie mit dem Blackberry,
Ich will du weißt aber dass du dass du deine Bluetooth-Tastatur pennen kannst auch beim iPhone.
Katrin drauf bitte draufklicken und ich sehe nicht was ich dafür das finde ich gut Möbel in Tastatur ist,
und schieben verarschen tust mit Bluetooth gepairte.
Das ist schon ein Bier das ist noch Sachen packen und dann,
das Plus unter Sex haben dieselbe Kamera oder,
nee ich glaube das X hatte in beiden das ist hat er den die waren und Helenesee was eine normale Linse aber beide sind optisch stabilisiert und das Plus hat nur eins von beiden ob die stabilisiert glaube ich.
Ja gut die vordere Kamera ist sowieso irgendwie fancy mit.
Ja sie kann man als von so viel besser noch mal auf dem Weg,
Clemens,
der ist das ist schon reingezoomt damit der ganz drauf passt die coolen Club Sie immer die Kamera abkleben wollen.
Jetzt wird Telefone erhalten über einen Code eingeben.
Aber der Hauptgrund ist warum ich mich für so ein Telefon interessieren würde es in der Tat eher nur die Kamera,
ich habe es mir kurz angeguckt aber ich fand Aberglauben bisschen bekloppt ich habe ich habe hier voll solcher ein einziges Foto bisher mit Portrait Modus mit zum iPhone 7 mal gemacht.
Ehrlich gesagt ich war also doch gleich sagen dazu disclaimer ich bin,
absolut kein Foto Nerd Jannis wenn wir alle wieder erzählen dass man ja mit so Spiegelreflexkameras noch viel tolle Effekte erzielen kann aber so für ich nehme ein Handy in der Hand und ich schieß mal so ein Porträt.
Durch diesen Blowout ne kommt es irgendwie echt krass rüber.
Ja einfach mal das überlagern solange Algorithmus das richtige macht ja dem Moment hat halt einfach gepasst sicherlich Max da Grenzen geben aber es war halt vor.
Weil Hintergrund da war so Natur Adivasi aber nee das war halt alles so ein bisschen ja du hast recht das eingetreten es war einfach so für diesen Cache Moment.
Also für das casual Instagram-Fotos das ist eine Avatar Generator also ich meine was machen sonst immer führen,
hoffe dran ich kenne das hier wenn ich so Podcast mache ich aber laufende Meter wechseln gestern gemacht oder so ja fertig,
für die Veröffentlichung hätte ich dann gerne noch ein Foto dann schicken Sie mir irgend so ein Foto wie sich vor.
Sowie Jalousie wenden und was nicht auf für verstörenden Hintergründen irgendwie mal eben fotografiert haben womit du nichts anfangen kannst was es nicht und ich freigestellt bekommst oder bzw muss einfach so so wenig essen,
poppt einfach nicht so an wenn die irgendwie alle jetzt porträtmodus Nummer fahren dann da ich ganz anders aus.
Brillen sieht man aber dass sie ein bisschen mit dem Bügel siehst du dass es beim Bügeln um wecke.
Nein ist also mit Bügeln haben wir so schlimm.
Das ist ja das mit diesem blindenzeichen,
bitte taucht Judith auch jetzt nichts ehrlich gesagt ich hätte nichts gegen eine bessere Kamera also bei der Kamera,
Muttermal machen das wirklich super also gerade so ich merke ich habe auch eine Spiegelreflex noch irgendwo zu rum flattern aber ich habe irgendwie auch mit gehabt und Südamerika wirklich einmal genutzt.
Zum Telefon ist halt doch irgendwie praktische wie griffbereit halt auch nicht wieder Standard Uri aus den man erstmal ausrauben möchte,
ein bisschen undercover unterwegs sein bitte gerne mal jetzt mal eine generelle Ansage machen wenn ihr das Telefon aus der Tasche zieht in der Mensa zu fotografieren erst recht wenn du dieses Bild dann auf Twitter oder sonst und wie veröffentlichen wollt.
Bitte den Dreck von der Linse diese Milch,
Bilder immer diese diese vernebelten Dinger nur weil die Leute ihren Taschen siffermann auf der Lauf der Glotze an weißt schon dass es kein Dreck ist sondern dass irgend welche snapchat features,
so Taschen von Humanoiden zwei beide Typen sind in der Regel dreckig.
Wenn du dich traust sind entwischt es reicht doch schon mal einfach nur am T-Shirt mal kurz an oder stehlen sie aber ist es wirklich so hast du mir diese Milch bildet geht mir total auf den sender vor einigen Fotografien die Leute noch geh ins Licht.
Und das so richtig dann hast du richtig so Nebel drauf und denkst du so dick soll eine geile Kamera sein von dem iPhone 8 oder was glaubst du selber nicht.
Bitte Absicht sich das also ich habe das vorher über die die Firma bekommen und habe dann.
Apple Store mir schnell so hier Cover geklickt ja auch zum Selbstabholen ja haben sie da kann ich gleich hinfahren bin ich dann hin und dann hat die Frau versucht den Barcode zu scannen und dann gings bei dem.
2 vor mir schon nicht regnen über Apple nicht so gute Mutter an und heller machen Kings bei dem vor mir schon nicht so richtig an,
dann gucke ich so dieses Teil an was sie deine Hand hatte und da war auch die Linse zum Barcode scannen was soll ich zu gequatscht meinst du die Wärme auf die Idee gekommen die sauber zu melden damit sie vielleicht irgendwie nach dir.
Gib mal her kurzem T-Shirt rubbel rubbel.
Ja vor allen Dingen die hatten da hatte der vor mir hatte halt auch irgendwie ein vorn gekauft und dann gibt's hier hinten auf der Rückseite diese ganzen vielen ganz kleinen Barcodes,
und auf der Seite haben sie extrem riesen Zettel hingeklebt mit einem gigantischen Barcode.
Was versucht die Frau zu scannen natürlich den Windows Code auf der Rückseite manchmal auf der Dachterrasse sind echt alle fit bei bei bei Apple aber die war irgendwie lauffähig ausbaufähig ja also na ja.
Nee aber ansonsten ich bin froh und zufrieden und sowas läuft das.
IPhone 7 Bild.
Wenn ihr schöne Fotos geteilt iPhone 7 in Höchstform du das ordentlich ausführen so anguckt hier.
Ja ich will irgendwann auch noch mal noch mal ein Shootout zwischen der Kamera und meiner meiner Nikon D90 machen die ich jetzt auch schon seit Jahren sie liegt jetzt auch schon eine Weile lang nur noch rum.
Weil es halt irgendwie doch Gewicht ist im Antrum ist zwar nur so eine kleinere irgendwie consumer Kamera.
Aber trotzdem irgendwie na ja.
Da lieb gehabt E-Geräte ich habe meine Kamera auf lange nicht lange fährt die hatte auch immer schöne Fotos gemacht aber es ist halt trotzdem unhandlich das Ding.
Auch meine schicke Minolta so ziemlich klein 2 m mit 22 Megapixel aber irgendwann dass das halt überholt voller Techniken und dann merkst du ne neue holen bringt auch nicht weil die ist ja auch sofort wieder überholt also bleibt beim Telefon.
Nee die Kamera glaube ich 12 Megapixel oder so ja mein Ding ist ja nur überholt aber.
Zeige mir gerade die Gerüchteküche vom iPhone SE2 das heißen mag.
Und dann ich einfach nur sehen ja natürlich dass ich keine keine keine doppelkamera war halt so aktuelle Chip zu erzählen da wenn sie an dem Gehäuse oder weiter festhalten dann nicht mehr.
Und heute also face ID hat zweiseitig soll ich nicht.
Wo denn okay ich mein das hätte natürlich oben den bereits erledigt natürlichen ganz anderen Markt ab das ist ein Gerät das von sowie für.
Billig 350 $ verkaufen und iPhone X kostet halt ja die saubermachen.
IPhone rrrr.
Also der langsamer Button das merkt man schon Touch ID mein Tipp,
du hast halt hier noch du hast halt hier noch zum richtigen also du meinst den der bei man den den den Reifen warum lange darf er nicht mehr mechanische sondern nur noch auf Touch genau das ist aber schlimm ehrlich gesagt besser als wenn ich wenn ich so ein Testgerät in der Hand habe sonst 7 oder 8 Wo seid keinen richtigen Wattenmeer hat das finde ich irgendwie eklig,
wieso total wichtig dass das Telefon leise in der Bedienung ist halt mit dem alten Schalter nicht gegeben.
Ich war von eine Weile auch vom sie mal auf dem 6 klasse da ich habe da ganz konkrete Anforderung der hat halt gar keinen mehr der ist aber die Wahrheit leise weil du nicht mit diesen mechanischen Hub hast.
Wolltest das iPhone Ten das macht total viel mit diesem Taktik mit dieser taptic Engine an allen Ecken und Enden wenn man irgendwas bedient macht es rappelt es einen an das ist für mich ein bisschen komisch geht aber.
Salon cooles Feature wenn man sich den wecker stellt morgens und der rattert voll los und du nimmst du dann so ein kuckst reingetan wird automatisch leiser,
also geht doch nicht aus aber es ist der märkischen du guckst drauf da muss er jetzt ja nicht mehr so vollen Alarm machen weil du bist ja anscheinend deine Augen wach du bist du bist wach so hoch dass mir noch gar nicht mehr doch.
Sehr viel ist jetzt so attention orientiert oder wir haben einfach Sachen drin die mehr davon ausgehen so ah okay du bist auch am Gerät und du nimmst mich wahr,
was bisher hat nur Nachteile also wenn man es jetzt wirklich dann geht's schneller aus weil er merkt du guckst nicht mehr drauf,
ist aber manchmal will man auch irgendwie du wartest doch selber was da irgendwie gleich passieren oder wartest dass du seujet Antwort kommen willst einfach offen da hinlegen dann merkt aber auch du guckst mich hin und Wok aus dass er so ein bisschen so der Nachteil aber du hast dich immer noch auf 30 Sekunden stehen ne,
Diesel mach den Bildschirm nach 30 Sekunden aus kann man ja nicht mehr umstellen haben sie halt entfernt,
doch natürlich hier automatische Sperre 30 Sekunden sind 5 Minuten habe ich das letzte drucken und habe warum ihre Meinung ist nicht mehr da wo ist das in anzeigen Helligkeit.
Display brightness und dann das iPhone 10 heißen würde als iPhone X draufstehen.
Ja ist doch egal willst du dir nicht so ein bye bye bye Simon alle nicht mit hingekriegt.
Wird immer X-Men aber das ist ja und X.
Model Ben Hill Filme wie haben die Römer ihre ihre ihre Zahlen ausgesprochen.
Da nix wahrscheinlich oder wie auch immer gibt ja keine Originalaufnahmen.
Aber Latein wo man was wurde durch eine Menge darüber,
ist doch auch was hast denn Pfefferbeißer beim Vatikan mal Nachhilfe ist Quinn Quintus oder so,
ist der Hoden der 505 eingeschlafen,
könnt ihr dann schreiben Sie doch auch nur hin ja stimmt aber ich hatte ich hatte genau diese Anzahl von Jahren Latein in der Schule 50.
Nein fünf er hat sich für 50 angefühlt aber waren fünf und ist es vielleicht für ein halbes Jahr was hängengeblieben wenn überhaupt.
Ich nutze immer noch gerne was beim Verstehen von romanischen Sprachen.
Mir hilft mir Hälfte eigentlich mehr dass ich mich ein bisschen mit Französisch beschäftigt habe dass er sich über über Latein mitgekriegt habe aber ja.
Die Spinnen die Römer genau.
Was ist eine Kleinigkeit habe noch ich habe noch was anderes ob das iPhone war sonst soll ich nichts einfällt nee ich habe gerade nicht so viel fragen muss aber auch sagen.
Ich habe mich jetzt dafür entschieden erstmal zu warten und es gibt halt so keinen richtigen.
Deal breaker so wo ich sagen würde aber das muss ich jetzt unbedingt haben.
Und dann ist es ja auch echt noch eine Menge Holz das man irgendwie für das Teil auf Tisch legen muss das habe ich jetzt auch nicht so jede Woche raus.
Aber aber Gigabit klingt genau.
Hallo kannst du ein Jahr auf deine dein Gigabit verzichten hast du so ein Telefon na toll auf dich verzichten na toll.
Ja ja wir verzichten achso LTM Telefon dann verlassen sie diese Leute die am Mercedes E mit zwei oder drei Gigabyte im Monat auskommen Telefon.
Ich liebe Pizza Optifit Knopf ich habe ich habe es neulich jetzt das erste mal geschafft die die die Warnung SMS zu bekommen.
Sie haben jetzt noch 10% ihres Datenvolumens von den zehn kleine hat jetzt schon richtig verbraucht kannst du mir das einstellen wo die so warm.
Das kann sein ist egal aber noch nicht gefunden man muss ja auf Magenta Seiten rum ich löschen sorry das.
Nee mache ich nicht gut das iPhone Thema fürs erste überwachten das.
Ich habe da eine Kleinigkeit mitgebracht aus Singapur.
Wollte damit gerade noch einreichen damit hast du bei Apple sind vielleicht noch mal kurz was anderes einwerfen nach letzte Mal diese lustige Debatte über Mac und so.
Ja und passend dazu gab es ja jetzt.
Die Berichterstattung das offenbar in dem neuen iMac pro kompletter A10 Stein drin ist.
Also,
der Prozess offen die wir jetzt hier gerade für das iPhone se im nächsten Jahr zu sagen der neue der aktuelle oder,
A11 ist jetzt auf A11 Bionic und der A10 Jugendweihe Nick iPhone 7.
Es ist immer sehr iPhone 7 Prozessor quasi oder eben auch der künftige se Prozessor der hat halt seinen Weg auf dem Balkon in den iMac pro,
was heißt aber nur als Supporter oder na klar das wird halt irgendwie Siri Klimbim und sowas Hey Siri.
So eine Sachen werden dadurch natürlich möglich vielleicht aber auch andere Sachen ja das zur Tanke Hauptprozessor sich.
Abschalten kann und der ARM-Prozessor verwaltet dann irgendwie die Idol Mutti ich weiß nicht so ganz genau was sie damit vorhaben aber offenbar ist das Ding da drin.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen dass das so eine schrittweise Annäherung ist so wirst jetzt nicht,
suicide nicht der mein Prozessor du siehst den auch erstmal nicht so du siehst nur die Dienstleistung die quasi da geleistet werden,
aber naja gut Ding da jetzt bestimmt nicht an uns irgendwann kannst dabei rauszunehmen du kannst aber argumentieren im.
Im MacBook Pro ist ja auch schon am Prozessor drin weil das Teil was die Touch Bar macht ist ja auch ein ARM Prozessor.
Also will ich auch argumentieren ja das ist ja nicht das heißt ja nicht dass wir das sehen dass dass du da drauf hat Programme laufen ist ja doch weil.
Was macht denn das Teil was macht man mit Touch ID ja.
Secure enclave lalala was wird der Prozessor im iMac pro machen ist noch nicht so ganz genau ich vermute halt im Wesentlichen im Bereich.
Äußere Erscheinung aber vielleicht immer so Idle Management ist und in den künftigen MacBook Pro ist wenn meine Schwester die sehen.
Davon gehe ich auch also und warum ist er erzählen halt dafür wichtig weil sie da ihre ganze beschleunigte.
Sachen mit drin haben weil sie in dem Prozessor diese Einheit ihren new rentenwiese so schön nennen drin haben und danach bestimmt er gleichen 11 einbauen,
ja natürlich in der nächsten Generation wäre natürlich auf den elf gehen im iMac pro ist kein face ID drin.
Mehr mein Mac Pro ist momentan sowieso im iMac iMac pro ja gut ja was wie mistresses.
Ja für mich ist der iMac irgendwie kein Rechner aber der iMac ist für dich kein Rechner mehr nicht so richtig weil.
Ach quatsch denn hier eigentlich mit Telefon reden meinst aus,
also macht auf mich jetzt nicht so den Eindruck das ist kein rechter ist weil das ist irgendwie eine ziemlich ja leistungsfähige Maschine mit dem Bildschirm den ich gerne hätte.
So ich habe nichts gegen so einen 5k Monitor nur deshalb hier gerade keine Option und ich denke wir werden.
Ist mittlerweile relativ sicher dass dass wir jedes Jahr eine weitere Schippe gereicht bekommen bis.
Du hättest es ja weil dass das haben wir jetzt gelernte ist einfach keine Zukunft für Apple du schaust siehst ja was sie jetzt machen sie bauen Ihre Event immer mehr Dinge sehen die mit ihr arbeiten.
Apps die damit arbeiten,
Programme Bildbearbeitungsprogramme für creative stuff Simulation Sachen wo die Apps auch wirklich Andy Kern als Kern Publikum von Apple,
appellieren gibt's derzeit aber so nur unter iOS so warum sollst du nicht auf Mac geben.
Ist halt schwierig wenn die Prozessorarchitektur die Apple da gerade verwendet das einfach nicht kann und er will es auch nicht selber einbauen kann.
Ist also ein weiteres gutes Argument warum ist mehr oder weniger sogar unvermeidlich ist das ist auf ARM hinausläuft.
Ich halte auch Insel langfristig da nicht unbedingt für konkurrenzfähig der Tag ist jetzt noch nicht da aber der kommt.
Überzeugt Apple ist auch ich meine so dermaßen gut in Prozessor Bau ja bin ich da aber auch mal nicht so ganz was vor der ich meine es halt einfach mal doppelt so schnell wie der Rest.
Doppelt so schnell wie der Rest das war in den Gigahertz Bors Megahertz races.
War das immer immer der Sieger.
Na gut vielleicht also es würde auf jeden Fall mal reichen um um inter die Karotte vor die Nase zu hängen die Pille raus das durch.
Ist das neue Nokia.
Ja nie gehört es hier fast na ja.
Und so total und irre und ich sag dir das durch.
Ich meine die sind sind so oft von von einem die angegriffen worden und habe dieses AMD Grafikkarten die Niere konfisziert und hatten und hatten.
Immer wieder ein echtes Problem aufzuholen aber sie haben es jedesmal geschafft und ich kann mir vorstellen dass das das Intel.
Schneller sein als alle anderen ist der Business ich glaube es dir einfach für Probleme haben werden einfach Ihre Mitarbeiter zu behalten weil die sich Apple einer nach dem anderen rauszieht.
Guten Tag schon sie meinen Israel scheint die Sonne auch da sitz Intel.
Na umso leichter dann müssen sie ja nicht so weit fahren und sind deine Straßen seit Tagen Sofa an der Straßenseite und so und dann.
Gibt's da sozusagen auch noch eine Menge zu holen also ich glaube das.
Diese CDU die CDU Business ist einerseits halt das mit am besten funktionierende Ding bei Apple die liefern einfach sein.
Jahren kontinuierlich gut.
Und es wird jetzt auch immer wichtiger und spätestens mit dem beginning of line dass sie für kleine Stückzahlen wieso ein Mac Pro Anfang Prozessor zu bauen das lohnt sich einfach nicht.
Die haben den Prozessor schon für die größtmöglichen Stückzahlen gebaut ja aber das ist kein Prozessor für Mac Pro,
noch nicht ja noch nicht Ja wird auch nicht,
doch wird es werden Witzenhausen ein Prozessor sein für deinen für deinen MacBook Pro ich meine dann dein Telefon was da auf dem Tisch liegt das iPhone X ist genauso schnell wie dieser Computer den Unternehmen stehen hast.
Wenn ich sogar schneller du hast ein Quad ja wahrscheinlich ist dein Telefon,
heißt dein Ding mach mal Mama Geekbench auf deinen dann einfach nix und auf dem auf dem Laptop auf den du jetzt gerade schaust dann erzähl mir noch mal was von Zukunft das muss ich erst irgendein Telefon.
Das habe ich schon getestet ja gut aber du hast ja auch das neueste 15 Zoll ja gut du hast halt das fette teil.
Das geht schon noch.
Ach der ungläubige so was ich dir noch sagen wolltest das ja gar nicht SDP so stark für den Mac noch interessiert das sieht dass sie da noch große Schritte machen glaube ich einfach nicht wohl.
Das Interview mit dem Hardware spielt wieder von Apple dem wie auch immer was Chef sein,
und da meinte er lasse sie arbeiten jetzt schon halt an der CPU von die sie in zwei Jahren bauen oder in dreien so natürlich und da meinte seinen sein Hardcore Vorteil wäre halt das Apple halt,
exakt und zwar exakt sagen kann was sie da brauchen und welche welche Software Features und welche oder was auch immer wieder machen müssen also sagen können exakt dann was Sie brauchen sie können exakt sagen was sie nicht brauchen und die können die CPU genau darauf abstimmen und das kann halt kein anderer so also Intel macht halt auch wieder so Microsoft mäßig die eierlegende Wollmilchsau was sie auch müssen so ein bisschen,
das hat Vorteile hat natürlich aber auch Nachteilen sie hat beim Mac auch mal und wenn sie halt meine CPU bauen die genau das bringt was Max bringen.
Benötigen ja dann werde ich würde mich noch nicht mal wundern wenn Sie in diesem Laptop Race genauso davonziehen WiSim.
Im Telefon Race davon ziehen.
Was mag heutzutage mag Performance nicht so das entscheidende Ding sein ne weil wir irgendwie mittlerweile so viel davon haben das,
sehr viel mehr von anderen Ressourcen wie viel Speicher ist da drin ist was haben wir für Bandbreiten davon hängt auch ab aber wenn es halt auch bedeutet dass du dieselbe Geschwindigkeit mit doppelt so viel Laufzeit,
springtanz.
Dann wird halt spannend ne wenn sein Laptop wirklich mal drei Tage lang nicht geladen werden muss immer wenn du mir sagst dein iPhone X oder X oder was auch immer hält zwei Tage mich ehrlich gesagt schon so ein bisschen überrascht.
Weil es um die seit zehn Jahren da drauf dass sie an diesem Helden Wachen Tag.
Wenn es gut läuft Ding irgendwie mal drüber hinwegkommen so einsam sei doch nicht zeigen weil ich habe das ja auch Süßigkeiten Uhr,
kann ja sein dass wir jetzt an dem Punkt langsam ankommen wo ist tatsächlich die Laufzeit mal nennenswert länger werden.
Aber das wäre mal bitter nötig ich habe z.b. mir auch watch Upgrade jetzt geleistet wollte mal ein bisschen Performance haben und dann halt eine Apple watch hier eine aktuelle Series 3 also tanze Ding Diallo,
Variante mit roten Punkt ohne roten Punkt.
Also kein LTE und auch kein Edelstahl 36 Stunden das ist doch schon von gestern jetzt und ich habe noch.
Scheiße man kann sich gar nicht lesen 55%.
Aber na wäre mein iPhone se hier schon die ganze Zeit am Kabel hängt weil sonst wär schon wieder alle geworden während dieser Sendung aber meine Apple watch wiederum das überrascht mich halt auch die sind jetzt seit heute morgen.
Um 6 Uhr durch und es bei 73%.
Da hat sich enorm was verbessert so richtig enorm viel irgendwie gefühlt könnte es die Uhr jetzt auch locker zwei Tage komplett also zweimal 48 Stunden schaffen,
bike24 Ersatzschlüssel gesamt schaffen also da sind Vorteile dann gerade große,
Schritte gemacht und das finde ich gut natürlich aber auch daran weil das jetzt ein bisschen größer ist und sie noch mal die.
Die Platine ist ja Sandwich Lerntechnik da sind ja zwei zwei PP-Folien also,
Platin kann man ja nicht mehr sagen Sie davon haben sie jetzt übereinander gelötet dadurch sparen Sie eine Menge Platz und deswegen haben sie dieses LC Batterie drin es ist einfach eine Hochbahn so ein Stück und einmal so seitwärts.
Soll davon mehr Platz da nicht so dass die die sparsame also Spaß oder wo das bestimmt auch aber ist auch hauptsächlich weil es einfach mehr Platz für die Batterien haben und das Telefon ist etwas höher als das sieht man hast ja 0,7 mm hör auf.
Übrigens du hast gerade deinen dein WLAN Dings aufgemacht,
und er hat mich gefragt ob ich das wlan passwort mit Jana LHD.
Wusste ich irgendwo eine das hatte gerdiken in Singapur da sind als ein Restaurant gegangen was ein bisschen unterirdisch war und da,
hat mit LTE der nicht in Sachen Qualität oder in seine bisschen mäßig aber die hat WLAN und die hatte meine iPhone in der Hand und die Kellnerin kam einfach vorbei und raunte mir ungefragt das WLAN-Passwort zu.
Da wo sie übliche unten Tipp dich dazu ein und dann Pop du bei mir so auf.
Der sitzt ja noch andere Leute am Tisch hat ja nichts mit Tisch aber die anderen Leute die damit die aus meiner Gruppe die in iPhone da hatten.
Die denn nicht vielleicht auch der WLAN-Passwort hätten haben wollen und so also weiß ich auch gerade meinte wo das geht doch nur wenn es gerade in Hand eintippen will ne kommt er nicht einfach so also man kann's Leuten ja nicht anbieten sondern nur wenn ich es einmal eintippe,
dann kommt Preisliste gegeben und kurz danach kam die Ansage.
Das ist mein Passwort eintippen ist ja schon so ein bisschen überholt habt ihr auch noch die anderen Dinger dann können wir das noch mal kurz testen ja also die alter Schwede ja habt ihr die Metaebene kann ich ja zum anklicken hier Zack.
Wollt ihr kurz in Geekbench score hören independence kaufen am Telefon,
also Single-Core macht der Mac Pro das Sitzen 14 inch Retina late 2013 44 Jahre alt der Macht 3510 Chor ungefähr,
und das iPhone X mal 4200 single core,
das MacBook macht 6750 multi-core also zwei aber hat das Ding nur ne.
Und das hat zwei ja und das iPhone X macht 10400 multi-core.
Deutsche Songs als Exkurs hat 16 Corsa C.
Bei mir ist das iPhone also nicht dabei Sex hat soll was die auch irgendwie inbetriebgenommen bekommt ihr noch alle gleichzeitig nicht so Sparmodus und hin und herschalten sondern,
bitte haut einfach was weg das Telefon ist einfach lecker schnell und jetzt erzähl mir noch mal das mal so ein Laptop kein ARM Prozessor einbauen kann das ist eine reine Migrationsphase zu dem Zeitpunkt,
Migrationsproblematik diesen meiner Meinung nach jetzt nur noch dabei sich darüber Gedanken zu machen wie sie den ganzen Scheiß rüber geschoben bekommen.
Wieso schaffen innerhalb von einem Jahr die komplette Prozessorarchitektur crossline auszutauschen der einzigen Einschränkung mit Pro unklar.
Also big iron Mainzer Navigations und so weiter kann mir durchaus vorstellen dass sie da noch eine Weile auf Insel setzen.
So Universe binary simulieren und so weiter das hatten wir alles schon das weiß auch nicht wie es bei den abends dann so ist mit den PC iPod Sander Thunderbolt und dann das ist auch alles so das ist das was sie jetzt hat bauen müssen.
Aber das ist halt auch leistbar so jetzt schon könntest.
Wir könnten uns ja mal eine MacBook Air testen.
Oder MacBook Air wird also das iPhone tendered bei mir meine Liste hat ungefähr 80% der Rechenpower von meinem Mac Pro der 66 richtig voll lecker dazu so wie deiner sozusagen wie viel Prozent.
Ca 80 als Ersatz iPhone hat ja so 10500 mein Mac Pro 12600 also das sind so,
um die 80% auf deiner natürlich ist Lotta du hast das Ding ja zweimal drin diesen Text gerne aber,
ich habe nur den Eimer wann ich glaube die nächste Generation wird nächstes Jahr wieder vor anziehen kann sein und die Inselwelt wird da nicht so mithalten kann,
also Speicher mäßig ist der Laptop immer noch vorne das ist das einzige so memory latency is not so groß und memory bandwidth sind sie ein bisschen Kopf an Kopf ansonsten ist es von überall schneller,
schon krass.
Also das hat mich durch Apple Aktien verkaufen jetzt.
Ich gucke mal ob ich noch irgendwelche finde wie viel ich was ich geil finde LLVM da ist sie wirklich doppelt so schnell mehr als doppelt so schnell dass Frauen,
ich will auf dem Fahren kompilieren.
Eine Kleinigkeit die ich mitgebracht habe vom IPs Meeting man hat dort vorgestellt.
Mal wieder einen neuen öffentlichen Nameserver ich habe wieder das jetzt da ich weiß dass wir sehr viele Hörer haben die noch der.
Der V4 IP44 Welt verbunden sind und jeder der dort ein bisschen bastelt kennt die berühmte IP-Adresse V4 IP-Adresse 8.8 8.8.
Oder 8.8 4.4 nehme ich den Google public public Nameserver Nazi 888.
Hitler Hitler wir sind zu viele achten aber der ist ja auch ganz beliebt und dann schick und ganz schön,
es gibt aber Leute die meinen das wäre doch jetzt meine schöne Sache da noch mal was neue an den Start zu bringen vielleicht auch mit anderen politischen Prämissen und das sind die Leute von Quad neuen da gibt's schöne webseite dazu Quad neuen also Guagua den,
net.de Nameserver der Haupt Nameserver von denen läuft der unter anderem auf der A43 9.9.99,
auch eine Handykarte Adresse die relativ gut erreichbar ist die haben nicht von langer Hand vorbereitet haben also schon ein paar hundert von den Dingern weltweit verstreut.
Die bieten jetzt noch was mit an das wenn man Nameserver abfragen Macht auf dieser neuen also mit vier Mal der neuen Adresse dass sie dann bestimmte Website ausblenden nehme ich die die dafür.
Gelistet sind das ml wo er verbreiten das Handy von Sicherheitsfeature.
Kann man als Deutscher gleich wieder kreischen sein und überhaupt und plant nicht möchte der kann natürlich 1999. 10 benutzen der ist denn unzensiert,
aber gleich Infrastruktur,
gibt's Events auch auf V6 haben sie gleich von vorne rein mitgemacht da freut sich unser berücksichtigt der Freund Felix von Leitner,
die heißt nämlich glaube 250 Koolance ft Doppelpunkt re also um wie viel Uhr kann man sich merken.
Die V6 Adresse für das Ding sie wollen auch noch weitere basteln alles gibt auch 99 19911 sind noch mal für spezielle Anwendungen sie wollen auch noch weitere basteln mit unterschiedlichen policies kann man sich ja mal durchlesen.
Ist auf jeden Fall mal interessante Sache wir jetzt nicht immer nur den Google seine Daten in den Rachen schmeißen möchte und die Jungs versprechen hoch und heilig dass er keine IP-Adresse speichern und Plan wird kann man mal durchlesen,
ja ist auch interessant zu wissen werdet auch mit initiiert hat und auch mit betreibt da sind also auch z.b. Polizei von New York und Polizei von London und wie mit am Start man sich auch was zu denken aber,
kann man sich mal durchlesen ist ebenfalls jetzt neu heißer Scheiß mal lesen perform ganz gut das Ding muss man mal ausprobieren so lange Zeit mal beobachten was da so kommt.
Bei dabei vielleicht nicht so gut zu merken einen öffentlichen nehmen aber nicht auch immer wieder gerne benutze.
74 82 42 42 von unserem bekannten Freund von hurk electric die also auch diese kostenlosen vor 600 und sowas schon betreiben.
Auch die haben öffentlichen Nameserver an öffentlichen Reserve am Start kann man auch mal gucken benutze ich wie gesagt auch ganz gerne ist auch recht responses recht nah immer also wie sagt auf schnell was du da mal so im Chat,
freenet hayy.net.
Unbedingt selber heißt ordn ist also open open resolver DNS ordn es. Hd.net.
Findet man dafür Nephridien ist und wir gibt's da eine Webseite dazu Uni gibt's keine Website oder zu aber der nimmst du weißt du.
Findet man 74-82 42/42 für die Leute die auf A4 stehen.
Ich gestehe jetzt der in V6 oder das habe ich nicht im Kopf die gucke ich mir mein copy and paced.
Free DNS ist noch wenn man da so selber Domains eben auch betreiben wird auf dem Ding immer noch.
Schmeiß ich gleich nein deine bellybutton neuen ist die Adresse von IBM gesponsorte ja mit den neuen Bereich die haben die Adresse beigegeben ein bisschen schneller als Apple mit ihrer 17.
War ganz lustig ich musste dann nach dem dazu sagen die Leute die die Tat ankündigen wollten auf der Veranstaltungen kamen wir noch einen Tag vorher in snoke und meinten so.
Wär doch kein sexy wenn wir das auch Routen würden nicht so hatten wir doch schon aber habe festgestellt dass it in einen von diesen fünf Provider da rein geschmissen haben und die hat mit geblockt.
Ich habe es nicht verlernt dennoch entblockt auf meinen auf meinen anmailen hin sogar relativ schnell,
die sind diese Adressbereich mit denen neuen wurde früher schon mal benutzt wurde auf der Scheiß benutzt es kann sein dass der daherkommt ist kann im auch daher kommen dass in manchen asiatischen Kulturen die neuen eine böse Zahl ist.
Möchte mich im japanischen also steht neuen für Schmerz.
4 hört sich an wie tote und neuen hört sich an wie Schmerz und so deswegen ist es also die habe ich ja so ein bisschen mit dem Aberglauben den Zahlen zwischen Lesemodus alles über 888 weil das ja da die Glückszahlen ne,
weiß ich jetzt nicht aber doch kann aber sein dass die jetzt wieder geblockt wird weil ist ja böser Google und China und so sind immer wieder erstaunlich dass die chinesische Firewall alles geblockt ist,
bis auf die SSH attacks das kriegen sie ein wenig geblockt.
Bitte rauskommen von den Main.
Permanent von chinesischen IP-Adressen Folge Heimat ja also ist wahrscheinlich die beste Methode um dort auch ein VPN aus China zu betreiben es einfach ein f****** SSH Tunnel.
Weil offensichtlich kriegen sie das nicht mir ist er letztens passiert ich hatte noch raspberry pie und habe den.
Nicht schnell genug mit einem Passwort versehen,
und gleich SSH Bruteforce Dings installiert der andere raspberry pie sucht die das Passwort an mich gedacht haben und hat daraus geballert ohne Ende also 1000 requests die Sekunde und nehmt ihr Daten doch erstmal - mail,
nimm das ernst,
hör jetzt auf Dinger mit dem bekannten Passwort Netze handy auf neues Passwort ändern nach dem Mittagessen.
Nee wir sind auch lang.
Vielleicht noch ein kleines Bitcoin Update da ist ja auch irgendwie.
Also kann alles Mögliche holen aber ich weiß bis dann einfach gar nicht mehr wo ich anfangen soll was interessiert deswegen meine Frage habt immer raus damit wenn nicht dann nicht.
Na ja also ich würde sagen jetzt mal so dass das größte Ding was da jetzt passiert ist ist ja dass dieser weitere Fock,
Diana König oder abgesagt und Sein Tattoo Ex war das wieder nichts jetzt schon das dritte X heute nach Zeit hast du ja auch kennen,
hören tut er mir ist aber was soll das heißen,
als er die Blockhäuser verdoppeln das wurde das sollte letzte Woche so um 16 Uhr rum stattfinden ca 15 16 das ich dachte auch ich vielleicht schaffe ich noch wenn die,
diese Sendung die letzte Woche gewesen wäre das ist genau dann noch mal Ansage dass da dieser vorbei ist ja schon gefährlich und so,
aber noch so eine das Wochenende davor hatten sie es ja dann schon abgesagt dann gesagt ja nee sie haben doch nicht genug Zuspruch und sie wollen ja die Unity nicht gefährden und teilen und blabla und sie sagen das jetzt mal ab weil sie sind ja die guten haben sie zeigen.
Doch noch ein bisschen,
Schiss gekriegt oder nicht auf jeden Fall versucht positiv daraus zu ziehen und dann war das abgesagt der Witz ist aber dass ein paar Leute diesen Ford natürlich trotzdem machen wollten weil sie dickköpfig sind oder weil sie Spaß dran haben und haben dann festgestellt stop,
16. November war das dass der Code den der Jefferson da geschrieben hat das.
Der kaputt war und zwar sollte bei einer bestimmten Block Nummer sagen wir jetzt mal 401000 ab da sollte nur noch.
Größere Blöcke als ein Megabyte angenommen werden mithalten Ford auch entsteht weil der normale bis man würde diese Block ja nicht annehmen hat aber irgendwie so formiert das nur bei 400001 diese größeren blocke dann erzeugt werden das heißt.
Die eine Bedingung konnte nicht erfüllt werden weil sie erst ein Block später sozusagen.
Erfüllt worden wären und dadurch hing das und kam einfach nicht mehr vorwärts also fest,
wenn die diesen Ford so durchgezogen hätten diese meiner die das so machen wollten und die original die will aber wollten das eigentlich meinen nicht das ist voll blöde Idee wir sollten das hier gemeinschaftlich machen und wenn dann nur mit Ansage und sie wollen diesen diese vergrößern eigentlich gar nicht am Arbeiten die das durchgezogen.
Dann hätten alle bitcoin-client die das mitgemacht hätten die hätten einfach wären stehen geblieben und es werden nichts mehr passiert und hätte mein erster Software-Update müssen hier und da und dann wer weiß ich nicht von halben Tag,
gibt's keine keine Überweisung die durchgehend dann bricht der Preis zusammen bei alle Decken Bitcoin ist kaputt aber keiner kann überweisen also es wäre ein riesen Trubel gewesen der Preis wäre eingestürzt paar Leute hat mal richtig viel Geld verdient weil sie es wüssten oder weil sie mal irgendwo vorne mit dabei sind und und handeln können aber wahrscheinlich auch,
ganz ganz viele Leute nicht ganz viel Geld verloren und das wurde sozusagen zum Glück noch mal abgewendet und ja ist jetzt sozusagen,
ausgefallen dieses aquatool bedeutet dass das klassische Bitcoin muss,
Nikon classic sagen uns noch finden Cash zu unterscheiden da man sagt Bitcoin also wenn man es richtig unterscheiden will sagt man dann Chor,
ansonsten ist dieses Bitcoin Kurs schon das Bitcoin und Bitcoin cash sagt man halt Bitcoin Cash manche sagen auch nur bikash weil dieser wieder ja wir wollen nicht dass die unseren Bitcoin Namen benutzen so aber sie streiten sich noch so ein bisschen rum,
da musst du mal gucken wie lange die Bitcoin Cash Leute das so aushalten was was ist Bitcoin geholt.
Betongold ist es auch gerade das sind immer die Chinesen die auch noch mal gefragt haben die waren der Meinung man müsste jetzt den Meiningen Algorithmus das Laufwerk nicht mehr so machen dass das die Eltern machen sondern die haben da irgendwas.
Was andere sich einfallen lassen damit der normale man mit seiner Grafikkarte das wieder machen kann also es ist so einfach nur gefragt und super Parameter gerne zur typische altcoin so ein bisschen.
Morgen und Parameter ändern und halt Fett Geld verdienen weil so ein Bitcoin gold ist gerade so 100 $ wert.
Dafür dass ich sozusagen nie mich mit mit Feingold beschäftigt habe ich aber für jeden Bitcoin den ich habe habe ich jetzt noch mal ein Bitcoin geholt.
Mal 100 $ also ich meine ist einfach die generierender Geld und muss auch noch sagen damit irgendwelche neuen Clients installiert und dann wir zusehen dass man das schnell wieder ein Bild verkaufen,
also Bitcoin Cash Portia letztmals schon dass ich das verkaufe das ist ja wir haben berechnet den Code ja immer im Verhältnis zu bekommen weil die hat ja schon die steigen ja auch.
War das so zwischendurch mal bis über 40 % bei einen Bitcoin Cash von Bitcoin wert also,
ja wo ich das geweckt hat man das so 13 14 % also wenn du jetzt deinen dieser Zeit genau war so ein paar Stunden lang zu 40 % für deine Bitcoin Cash bekommen also in normal Bitcoin jetzt sind die so bei 1000,
Euro.
Auch kein Fehler ist auch kein Fehler ist und dann kann man auch gleich nicht mehr denken warum die das machen genau deswegen das generiert einfach Geld aus dem Nichts mehr oder weniger.
Ich bringe auf investierende rein und du verdienst ja dadran Fiat Crypto mit dazu da um Geld zu vermehren.
Bis jetzt keine Antwort auf ich würde das so sagen.
Also beide ganz schnell also gibt's denn eigentlich ist hier warum man das Forcas ich glaube ich verstehe das nicht nur nicht das Gefühl gibt da verschiedene andere kryptowährungen die eigenen Kot haben mit eigenen eigenen Sicherheit,
Feature sowie monero die sind total anonym digital so.
Privacy Filter sind ganz hoch anonymer du kannst das nicht verfolgen nicht dass es eigener Kot und alles ist neues hat überhaupt nichts mit Bitcoin zu tun und die machen so ihr Ding so dann gibt es alle Leute die.
Ja sind halt pfiffige Developer vielleicht die neben den Bitcoin code.
Ändern so ein paar Parameter geben dem Ding den Namen Bitcoin Gold und sagen hier ist es und wir machen das jetzt halt so und das ist das ist meiner Meinung nach simples simples Geld generieren,
und die Liebe kein Gold gemacht haben ja sogar angesagt wir folgten das aber dann gibt's dieses Betongold nicht sofort sondern wir machen erstmal free Meinungen,
Erstellung erstmal selber 8000 mit Condor Münzen und dann lassen wir den Rest so das heißt sie haben sich erstmal selber Geld generiert.
Dann geben Sie das frei und das ist das ist Geld generieren also das ist so Geld scheißen für die kannst du auch machen,
machst du Letty kein Marzipan.
Und wenn es dann soweit ist dann sagen wir sind die auch 100 € wert oder vielleicht sogar nur 50 weil ich kennt das keiner aber ist egal dann hast du halt,
Pimpinelle deshalb wo Bitcoins mehr wert als letzte Zeile oder wir machen das.
Aber ich bin noch mal kurz beim Thema ja jetzt war ja die Intention von dem.
Bild auch gesehen haben die Intention die da verkündet werden können eigentlich auch bedeuten.
Scheiß drauf wir machen du irgendwas anders ob Sache wir erzeugen hier irgendwie noch mal Geld und dann haben wir und was dabei verdient.
Hat das auch vielleicht anderen Tag das Kleid auch so sein trotz alledem ist es ja ist aber auch ein technisches Rennen nämlich mit diesem Bett der Bitcoin Cash mit drin ist ist dieses,
deswegen nenn ich ja Cash wir sind besser für,
das Kessel austauschen von Geld weil wir haben ja die großen Blöcke man kann jetzt irgendwie Block machen der 8 Megabyte groß ist bei uns geht die Transaktion durch das heißt die Transaktionskosten sind niedrig.
Das korrekt an der Seite ist es ja so das hin und Bitcoin die jetzt auch nach diesen jetzt auch noch mal nach diesem gescheiterten fork.
Und wenn ich dich sehe auch der Grund Überzeugung der Chor Entwickler,
nach wie vor bei diesem ein Megabyte Grenzbereich bleiben wird mit Worten die Blöcke sind irgendwie voll Didi jetzt sowie committed werden sind auch voll mit Transaktion und es ist gar nicht so einfach.
Mit niedrigen Transaktionskosten warte noch was rüber zu schieben also ich habe sie es nicht wirklich beobachtet und ich weiß auch nicht ob du das getan hast aber ich habe gehört dass da schon beträchtliche,
mit Regel genommen werden die das Verschieben von Kleinstbeträgen wirklich tatsächlich vorkommen unattraktiv machen es ist alles korrekt aber ich glaube.
Kann dann nur zum zeigen mutmaßen aber die die Korte wer dabei denken sich halt dass diese diese Verdopplung bei Bitcoin Cash als er mir auf 2,
mir sogar wenn sie wollten könnten sie soll einfach so auf 8 Megabyte hochschalten dass das auf Dauer halt auch nicht reicht dann kommt halt vielleicht noch mal 12 Jahre mit aus,
aber du müsstest halt schon wieder erhöhen und die sind da mein wieso dauerhaft Erhöhung was ja auch größere Blöcke ist die länger dann über snapchat brauchen dadurch entstehen höhere Latenz dann haben wieder meiner finde mehr Blöcke parel und die ganzen Probleme der somit kommen das geht gar nicht dass deine Platte das nicht speichern kann bei,
Platten können das Speichern das gar nicht das Ding da ist mehr so die,
wie schnell sich das so verbreitet und Block im Netz das dauert ja dann halt auch länger dass dass er ein Problem ist und dem Chor Developer glaube ich die wollen halt anders skalieren und eine Sache sind halt diese sogenannten Lightning networks,
wo halt das von Bitcoin ausgelagert wird dann wird das da abgearbeitet und dann später wieder ins ins Bitcoin zurückgeschoben so könnte man das jetzt ganz grob vereinfacht erklärt aber das würde halt,
skalieren ohne Ende ohne dass man ein Bitcoin jetzt so doll viel machen muss oder dass man unendlich riesengroße Blöcke braucht und das Hammer aber dafür doch wie die die Summe der zu bestätigenden Transaktionen nicht größer oder doch,
doch mal die kann man alle ins Lightning network ausleihen sind so der Meinung,
man kann diese Milliarden von Starbucks die man bezahlen will nicht in Bitcoin abholen das geht einfach nochmal separate Pools mit die ganzen Transaktionen macht und die werden dann so komplett als fertige Transaktion spool,
besteht ich nehme an dass alles Bitcoin ausgelagert,
second layer einfach die machen das die machen das irgendwann die Milliardenbeträge werden verschoben.
Ikoffice werden aber vielleicht schon in Leer 3 irgendwie verschoben ist und so parallel Networks also,
es ist alles kompliziert mit dem Lightning network weil die da gibt's sowieso ein Routing Problem hast du da wohl noch haben die dir das Geld dann da so hin und herschieben zu erlernen aber irgendwie sowieso wollte eskalieren,
okay ja das verstehe ich das hast du nimmst nicht die Transaktion als solche rein sondern uns nur eine Referenz auf eine Liste von Transaktionen mit rein und damit er Block dann wieder klein irgendwie so.
Hörzu mansherry machen aber wir können die ganzen Suppen Währungen habe ich schon mal erzählt das war halt dann bitte zu früh damals auch was ich aber zu früh war ich fand der hat erstmal die Grundlage überhaupt,
gelegt um Obmann,
doch Kupfer grafisch halbwegs zu verstehen was er überhaupt ist also mittlerweile gehen wir hier so locker mit so begriffen wir blockchain oben Alsfeld irgendwie Merkel trägt alles erklären und so,
und ich habe es auch damals,
merkte man sich halt nicht andauernd und und fortwährend mit solchen Themen beschäftigt und ist einfach die Quote des Aussteigers doch recht hoch,
ja aber man muss schon immer wenn mal wieder so.
Metalist full filement erfahren um einfach diese ganzen Sachen und das regt genauso das mit EASA fühle ich mich jetzt mittlerweile schon wieder so ein bisschen sprachlicher Reichenbach / Podcast mich.
Gestellt habe,
aber halt sehen wie andere Leute mit den Augen rollen das kann ich gut verstehen das ist einfach dieses ganze Prinzip ist schwierig war lustigerweise gestern.
Ohne TU Berlin da ist immer so einmal im Jahr,
also got the Queen's lecture das ist sowieso von von von von Botschafter Großbritanniens gesponsert und dann holt immer irgendeinen UK Wissenschaftler der halt in Berlin irgendwie die Lektion des Jahres gibt und so geht das auch nicht das Neuhaus,
nee das Spiel kein Orchester ist für dich relativ trocken 50er potthässlich about a von der TU Berlin seit ich auch immer mal sprechen sollten da was bedeutet man nichts in Berlin.
Das Hauptgebäude da direkt am ja aber dann kennst du dann kennst du nur den Neubau nicht in Altbau das Problem ist ja dass das hier steht ja vor dem Neubau,
dass das da ja irgendwie die Hälfte von kaputt war und statt dass sie den Altbau ordentlich vorne wieder aufgebaut haben haben seit diesem Neubau vor den Altbau alter 70er Jahren und so weiter ist halt so macht aber nicht besser.
Also Britta sind passé indischer Herkunft,
der mittlerweile da Chief scientist tralala für bei Opa ist und halt so ein bisschen über ihr geredet hat und dann fand ich das insofern schon mal ganz interessant als dass ich so bin 90% des Torx sogar keine Probleme hatte so ich dachte mir so ja ok kommt hier noch mal irgendwas Neues,
und hat alle anderen so so aha okay die Zukunft und so künstliche Intelligenz und alles,
Burger Prinzip einfach so die die Grundprinzipien erklärt und das wären prinzipiell bedeutet das für Sie.
Das klassische programmieren auf dem Kopf stellst ne also werde vorher halt von einer people mir tat probier's halt jetzt irgendwie andersrum nicht dein Programm erzeugt irgendwie Daten sollen die Daten erzeugen ein Programm und gut das ist halt ja das was.
Was man hat irgendwann auch versteht wenn man sich so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt wenn man sich damit beschäftigt aber nochmals halt nicht.
Irgendwann mal hat parallel einfließen lassen so also Block blockchain und er dass dass das macht die Leute wuschig und ich kann es auch sehr gut nachvollziehen Anschluss fahre ich dann auch noch beim.
Beim Bootcharter Botschafter zum Dinner geladen,
Staatsbürgerschaft zurückgeben weil ich habe ich habe dann doch drauf verzichtet den Botschafter zu beleidigen aber ich setze mich auf einen anderen die irgendwie da noch rumliegen irgendwie eine indische Flagge rumgehackt habe ich gesagt das ist alles ganz großer Mist S&S.
Dass dass das irgendwie sie alle ins Verderben führen wird.
Hast du gesagt das mit LAN das ist eigentlich anders herum denken was ich mich da mal gefragt habe weil ich doch jetzt verstehen Leuten drüber gequatscht hat ob man.
Also ich weiß nicht ob es zu dem Zeitpunkt schon so viele Entwicklung gab als es Prolog,
Prolog ist ja schon noch mal eine andere Art zu programmieren so dieses wissensbasierte und ich glaube auch dass man in Prolog also seine Wissensbasis aufbauen konnte Verknüpfung und darin hat,
und wenn man neue Verknüpfung hinzugefügt haben die etwas anderes impliziert hätten hätte die Datenbank auch das gelernt.
Frage mich halt immer ob das so eine Vorstufe,
der Vorstufe das richtige ist ein Prolog mal kurz in der Uni zu tun gehabt und fand es halt schon spannend die,
Denkweise zum Programmieren und Prolog ja es ist was dran also ich muss zugeben ich kapiers mit Prolog selber mich nicht so beschäftigt aber ist ja auch die Vorlage für erlangen,
also alle der der der Vorlagen und ist ja sehr dick karaqeva Programmierung das hast du formulierst sehr viel mehr irgendwie das,
was du eigentlich haben willst und nicht so sehr wie wie wie du den Flora hinsiehst und Adam und Elexier ist ja so dass du halt deine ganzen Methoden für all die Fälle definierst die ja quasi auch so ein bisschen deine Realität deklarativ,
Julian also du gehst davon aus dass folgendes Ereignis eintritt und dann müsste so darauf reagieren aber du sagtest nicht genau in welcher Reihenfolge diese Ereignisse durch dein Programm durchfegen dann irgendwann passen eigentlich nur noch die Daten,
drauf ja also user input netzwerkstream ich Files was auch immer und dann ist der Floh,
implizit also dass die Programmiersprache nimmt die hat eigentlich den dispatch was jetzt eigentlich korrekt der nächste Teil des Programms ist ausgeführt werden wollte mehr oder weniger ab weil du eben dich selber nicht mehr diese ganzen Fall Entscheidung kümmerst Realist,
sicherlich konzeptionell da ist zu vergleichen nur dass du haltbar er überhaupt gar keinen Code mehr schreibst der was weiß von dem was eigentlich am Ende getan werden muss sollen du eigentlich nur noch auf dem Framework aufsetzen was überhaupt generell der Lage ist.
Aus den Daten andere Daten zu erzeugen die dann eben diesen Flow steuern wobei ein Programmierer halt nennenswert voraussagen dauert treffen kann wie dieser Code der da entsteht,
aussieht und was er eigentlich am Ende genau tut ich möchte in diesem Zusammenhang erwähnen die Männers.
Wie heißt die Abkürzung wenn Maschinen educcare notes and crosses machine woher man eine eingebaut hat die aus 144 Streichholzschachteln besteht wo.
Bunte Glasperlen drin sind und das Teil spielt tictactoe.
Und ist relativ gut da drin immerhin immer wieder ein,
zum ist ein Brot zu erzählen habe ich es überhaupt nicht erzeugt Streichholzschachtel spielen Tic-Tac-Toe miteinander nein eine künstliche Intelligenz bestehend aus Streichholzschachteln es gibt an bestimmte Regeln wo du.
Also wenn der Spieler ein Kreuz macht dann,
guckst du in der richtigen Streichholzschachtel nach was der nächste Zug der Maschine ist und je nachdem ob die Maschine dann hinterher verloren hat oder gewonnen hat änderst du den Inhalt der Streichholzschachteln.
Leider sind der Speicher der mechanische.
Nee das Spiel selber dauert nicht lange aber das Teil an zu lernen dauert ein bisschen länger ich hatte ich hatte da in so einem in so einem Mathematik,
YouTube Channel Video gesehen Daten sind es in so einer teils Firma aufgebaut und dann durften halt die Besucher durften halt gegen die Maschine dann Tic Tac Toe spielen und,
dann hatten sie am Ende des Tages war die Maschine dann halt auch gut trainiert.
Und dann haben sie die Regel noch mal bisschen geändert und haben am nächsten Tag das mit den nächsten Besuch an wieder gemacht und irgendwie zum ist die ganzen Kids hatten wohl eine helle Freude da dran gegen einen Haufen Streichholzschachteln Tic-Tac-Toe zu spielen,
das ist ja ich fand fand das insofern es ist ganz lustig weil man an der Stelle doch relativ gut sehen kann wie sonnen.
Bison machine learning prinzipiell mal funktionieren kann,
wie denn das sein kann dass man das visualisiert doch ganz gut mal irgendetwas lernt auch wenn das jetzt wirklich der niedrigste niedrigste Level ist überhaupt,
und vor allen Dingen funktioniert das glaube ich immer nur dann wenn die Maschine anfängt was uns braucht man noch viel mehr Streichholzschachtel.
Tim hast du deine schon mal Hardware wallet besorgte für deine Bitcoins gibt's nämlich den Tresor 2 jetzt im Presale der kommt erst im Januar aus.
Und da gibt den vierten Wetter wird leider probiert stehen sie machen wird um 10 € teurer ich habe am Anfang ja leider auch kein Gas ich hab nur noch gar kein geklickt.
Hätte schon längst machen sollen aber das ist eine Tresor zwei na der hat einen das Mädchen Größe hat ein größeres Display hat auch ein Touch Display also da oben ist der 2 das unten im Bild ist dahinter,
und da kann einfach ein bisschen mehr es halt viel moderner und man kann den Pin direkt auf dem Tresor eingeben was man früher immer über sonnen.
Virtuelles Keyboard auf dem Rechner machen musste wo aber keine Zahlen man seine Zahlen wann auf dem Tresor angezeigt oder mit der Rechner nicht weiß was du für ein Pin Up das kann man jetzt alles direkt auf dem Tresor machen also sei einfach ein bisschen bisschen schicker und bisschen toller.
Aber.
450 Euro sollte man mal drüber nachdenken wenn man paar Bitcoins hat bei den Preisen jetzt ob man doch nicht sein Geld mal ein bisschen auch gegen einen gehackten Rechner sichern will.
Das hat.
Und der Tresor Software gibt es auch eine Beta-Version also auf den alten Tresor dass man seine Bitcoin gold irgendwie also dass man dies plätten kann dass das sicher ist damit man die dann wenn man möchte auch verhökern kann.
Muss das ja immer so ein bisschen Split ne weil der Kita erstmal für gleich beide Währung der gleiche dann splittet man das erst mal auf damit man da nicht aus Versehen das falsche ausgibt.
Note bist du durch,
ich denke wir haben auf jeden Fall unser klassische Zeitlimit schon gerissen da haben viele eine unterschiedliche lange würde ich noch ansprechen ja wir können auch Kleinigkeiten nach die fahren,
und zwar gibt es ja seit einiger Zeit van der Burg 3.
Und es gibt ja jetzt von Apple auch offiziell die Möglichkeit tatsächlich Grafikkarten Überfahren der Ball 3 anzu,
schließen und ich habe mir dann einfach mal so zum gamen halt mal so eine Fanta Bo3 Box mit hardwell mit Grafikkarte geklickt ist es schon da,
ja ja und das erzählt dass am Ende der Sendung,
andere Dinge waren ja scheinbar wichtiger das ist diese Gigabyte aorus GTX 1070 Gaming Box ja das geht richtig von der Zunge,
also eine Nvidia 10-70 ist da drin genau das ist indianisch,
genau eine Nvidia 10-70 10.80 ist momentan das des höchsten verschiedene 488 pajoma das aber nicht 10-70 ist ein bisschen drunter.
Irgendwie finden bei uns ja das funktioniert erstaunlich gut also ich habe das Ding halt an diesem skull Canyon.
Mini-PC dran,
das ist ja dieses dieses Teil von Intel was im Prinzip nur aus einem Prozessor und und sie war noch gar nicht annehmen oder nee ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert ich müsste am Firmen Mac probieren ob das überhaupt geht hört es irgendwann mal ausprobieren ich habe doch jetzt sofort dafür sagt man ja ja sowieso,
aber prinzipiell ist es ist es ist es ganz gut jetzt mal abgesehen davon dass diese Box zu Hardware mäßig echt schwierig ist weil die ist relativ klein.
Und da ist halt so ein Netzteil mit so einem Twins Lüfter drin und das Teil des macht ein Geheule es ist unglaublich,
ja dann sollte man von dem er die Finger lassen sich mal die anderen angucken geschnitzter mehrere Anbieter die so,
dzisiaj Boxen anbieten und es muss ja auch nicht meine Grafikkarte sein das ist im Sande wollte eigentlich egal macht eine Menge Sinn,
aber man könnte auch eine 10 Gigabyte Karte z.b. rein machen wenn mein passenden Treiber heißt es richtig aber die Box ist halt karte und Box zusammen kostet halt irgendwie so viel wie sonst nur die Karte ist ein bisschen mehr drin karte werden so eine Box irgendwie ich habe zugeguckt fängt so bei 300 € an,
wann ist noch nichts drin.
Also deswegen fand ich das jetzt mal ganz interessant aber die hat halt auch so Eigenarten wie du steckst halts Thunderbolt 1 und dann fängt das Ding an die Lüfter zu laufen.
Na und dann ist auch egal ob da Strom drin ist weil du was undervolt so viel Strom kommt dass die Lüfter laufen und habt ihr sie nicht alle.
Obwohl es doch gar nicht mehr benutzen ist oder sonst immer dann gehen einfach die Luft an weil die da sich ihren Saft holen genau an deiner machst du denn,
mach den Rechner aus dann denkst du ja okay dann muss jetzt die Box noch abstöpseln dass sie aufhört zu lüften und dann weiß sie sind diese diese ganze Hardware dann geht der Rechner wieder an.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen wenn du das pandaboard abstöpseln geht der Rechner wieder an und bootet dann irgendwie.
Könnt ihr mich nicht mal irgendwas in das ist und wie erschossen Betaphase raus Sintra Klimbim,
Nena ich glaube schon also da ich bisher nur mit Windows 10 probiert habe und ich kann dich jetzt zurück nichts dazu sagen aber da funktioniert es einfach ohne Probleme.
Auf Windows ja gibt's das ja auch schon länger sie irgendwie so einer Betaphase ist und mit heißer müsste das jetzt eigentlich normal sein,
also ich werde ich werde mal ausprobieren ob es zu sowie für Sirene 20:18 Uhr da wollen wir das irgendwie finalisieren ja oder nein,
guten Grafikkarte nee nee nee aber so ein paar Benchmark kannst ja schon mal machen so sick.
Ja okay ich mache mal Band mal vielleicht auf die drei Spiele spielen die alle anderen Spielen.
Also dass wir haben die schönen Bilder auf dem PC dafür habe ich ihn ja ja aber da muss man ja Windows-Version Rücken unter der Toten das geht aber.
Kann man machen ne du bist ja auch also das zweite auch noch viele andere Sachen egal ne.
Wieso was jetzt uns nur träumen nee also also ich habe das jetzt auch das erste Mal so ein Spiel wirklich mit,
midsummer mal rechts unten Grafikeinstellungen,
gespielt so einfach mal alles auf nach ganz rechts geschoben alle Regler und es ist nach wie vor flüssig und das kannte ich so vorher noch nicht so irgendwie ganz nett.
Welches Spiel wo man alle abschießen muss oder wo man mit dem schnellen auch mal nach anderen Messern muss abmesser.
Kappmesser alle alle umbringen muss ja nee nicht alle aber das ist ja auch das beliebte Spiel,
habe ich nur auf deine neue Spiele spiel halt diese Assassin's Creed Reihe ganz gerne weil sie hat so ein bisschen Open World ist als wird immer mehr openwork bei mir geht und weil du halt nicht.
Nicht notwendigerweise direkt auf Konfrontation gehst kannst du viel rum rennen kannst ein bisschen Sightseeing machen kannst auch irgendwie alten Gebäuden rum klettern und so ich finde es immer ganz nett aber tust du das jetzt mit ultra Settings eingespielt und das wurde langsamer,
allerdings noch nicht die aller neuste Version aber.
Dass das was ich jetzt gespielt haben sie zwei Jahre alt ob das auf Ultra Settings gespielt und war völlig in Ordnung.
Kann man mal machen.
Er ist auf jeden Fall spannend ich träume immer noch von dem Riesen fetten Apple Monitor mit Ethernet dran und alles was man braucht und die Grafikkarte auch und deaktiviert sich dann also der wird dann auch mit Thunderbolt 3 angeschlossen ist sozusagen im Bildschirm,
die Grafikpower drin ist ein Test Underworld 3 Kabel ist glaube ich nicht ganz 20 cm lang der ist ja auch total bekloppt da kannst du ja was anderes kaufen.
Dann hatte mein Handy und das Ding geht auf dein Rechner ne sowas.
Ein Rechner hat ja das macht er glaube ich immer wenn ich außer das falsche Gold was gibt auch welche dir deinen Rechner laden mit 60 Watt oder so also wie gesagt da ich es nicht am Mac benutze ist mein Sohn auch relativ egal und der andere Rechner der hat ja sowieso keine Batterie.
Ja aber mein PC braucht eine Kiste gar nicht gut man sich so ein Gamer-PC na ist gut dass du dann noch meinen Laptop.
Nee ich habe wie gesagt skull Canyon ist so eine Art Sorte so kleine Dinger ja Mini Dings ich glaube doch nicht so ein kleines das hat mir das hergeleitet dann noch mal so ein riesen Gehäuse daneben zeigen habe ich da diese skull Canyon Dings hast doch eh immer nur zu Hause.
Gleichen PC kaufen ja weiter hätte ich mir jetzt noch mal einen komplett neuen PC kaufen müssen.
Willst du doch für den Preis von dem Gehäuse da schon fast gar nicht ganz an mich wirklich.
Ja aber das ist nicht der normale Anwendungsweise und Skullcandy mit somit zum externen Grafik nein Eier sind wirklich auch so für also Game Party ist also da ist ja auch eine Tasche dabei.
Dann hörte musste eigentlich ran so eine Umhängetasche wurde Teil rein kippst und dann wahrscheinlich dieses externe Ding jetzt.
Also mit Windows an einem Windows-PC betrieben oder an dem Mac unterhandeln einen Windows-PC,
von Windows auf Mac Katze aber nicht unter nee das nicht getestet ob das auch geht nee du hast das nächste Mal nicht mitbringen.
Was das Ding ja doch kleine Umhängetasche Umhängetasche also nicht allzu schwer ist kannst ja mal mitbringen kann man testen ob der dann z.b. auf password cracking mit mit hashcat irgendwie kann und so.
Auf Mac.
Das ist Ausblicke das wirklich unfassbar,
ich würde noch was einschieben was ganz kurzes mich kurz bedanken weil zwei Unbekannten hören und Patrick der mir die mir was von meiner Amazon Wunschliste geschickt haben deswegen wollte ich mal DANKE sagen,
ich habe jetzt auch wieder was bekommen vielen Dank,
ich immer lacht ach nee Amazon nachfragen warum auf meiner Wunschliste so wenig drauf steht der Weise leergekauft ist ausverkauft sozusagen ja sie ist leer gekauft aber ich habe sie halt auch nicht befüllt sie war auch eigentlich nie sonderlich gefüllt und das hat auch einfach was damit zu,
tun dass es einfach ehrlich gesagt gibt gleich so viel Dinge die ich jetzt unbedingt haben will.
Ja und das ist dann halt auch irgendwie man man like dann schnell zum Tanz und ich bin anders hat gerade mal wieder dabei auch Zeug vor allem entstanden mich zu enthalten.
Richtig.
Ich habe irgendwie diese Woche sehr viele Dinge entsorgt verschenkt weggebracht anderen Leuten gegeben,
hier wird auch zu dem Lehrer der Metaebene es noch einiges zu tun habe irgendwie alles rausgesucht was jetzt voll was jetzt auch noch mal verkauft wird was auf Ebay geht so in den nächsten zwei Wochen,
weil so viel Zeug und so also ganz ehrlich also wer die Metaebene unterstützen will.
Findet alle Hinweise dazu oder Metaebene Slash Spenden und sagt ganz klar lavale ist einfach das Gute SEPA und insbesondere der sepa-dauerauftrag sind einfach mal,
die beste Drohne Plattform Erbach ist einfach die Beste Spendenplattform ever und das ist.
Lässt alles irgendwie abzugsfrei durch und vor allem die Daueraufträge sind halt auch das was,
das höchste Kalkulierbarkeit hat ne, versieht okay das ist so das was so regelmäßig kommt klar es wird immer wieder mal was.
Eingestellt, oder was neues dazu wird auch Einzelspenden und so aber dass das trägt einfach wirklich und ja wenn ihr so zeigen euch darüber Gedanken macht was ich mir zu Weihnachten Gutes tun könnt besser jetzt.
Sascha Praxis ist es raus jetzt aber.
Leute tschüssikowski ja wir leiten jetzt hier mal das Unvermeidliche Ende ein oder Mahlzeit.
Dass alle noch jemand hat noch irgendwas kluges zu sagen wir sind in drei Wochen erst wieder online und das ist dann auch die letzte Sendung in diesem Jahr so sieht's aus.
Es gibt schon weg von Clemens naja also hat verschiedene Gründe ich verreist sein ein bisschen das ist ein Grund und dann ist ja auch bald Kongress und behaupten Weihnachten und Pipapo aber.
Wir kommen wieder keine Frage.
Music.